learn how to create and deploy a full
stack web application using svelt
versailles and postgres and you'll do it
all in your browser hello and welcome to
the full stack development course my
name is mike nicholas i am your
instructor for this course and i will
talk about myself and my background in
just a little bit
before we get to that i want to
introduce you to the
course the technology stack and a little
bit of how we're going to be developing
this
now why do we do a full stack web
development course
i have been in the industry for a couple
of years and one thing i noticed is that
there is a lot of information online
about web development different
frameworks different technology stacks
there's a lot of information about
back-end development and there's a lot
of information about how to build
and model your database and your
back-end systems now
what i think
has been missing is this entire
end-to-end
full stack web development like what
how do you connect the website
to the back end like of course there's
rest apis there's graphql there's
different
um
ways of communicating between the front
and the back end you can find that
information online it's again like
anything else lots of stuff out there
but how do you really connect the front
end to the back and what are some of the
best practices
so i've got just to watch out for
and the same is true for
the connection between the
server side or the back end and your
database right you could use raw sql
queries you could use a an object
relational mapping an orm
you could use a nosql database
where you persist json-like data or
documents
but again how exactly are you going to
do that and in this course i am going to
teach you the full end to end from
building the web application connecting
it to an api
and then persisting data in the back end
in the database
we will be talking about the entire
thing we will also be deploying that
into a production-like environment so
that at the end of the course
you have what it really takes to start
your next project
whatever you're going to build by the
end of this course will be the starting
point for your next project so you don't
have to build all this gluing together
by yourself
let's talk about
where we're going to develop that most
of you are very familiar with your local
development environment
where you have
a bunch of tools installed a terminal
probably some kind of command line
interface and probably some editor of
one sort or another
in this course i'm going to be using
something called gitpod.io
gitpod is providing
developer environments in the cloud
for each task that we're going to work
on so imagine
instead of
you know curating and maintaining our
local environment where we install
certain versions of node or java
what we get is a new environment always
clean from scratch automatically set up
for each task we're gonna work on we
will get into that in more detail as the
course progresses and i will introduce
this as we go
one thing to keep in mind is if you do
prefer your local environment
that's perfectly fine you can follow
along in
everything we do
by using your local environment there's
no problem with that
let's talk about the technologies you
can see on the screen on the website we
will be using a framework called swelt
swelt is currently in version three it's
been stable for a while and it's used in
production by a number of big companies
the api slash backend and also the
hosting
uh framework for swelt itself will be
called will be uh it was wealth kit
swell kit as you can tell by the name is
developed by the same team
and very recently the founder and
creator of swelt rich harris
announced that he is joining versailles
full-time so swelt is now backed by
a large player in the industry who
really cares about making the web faster
lastly we need some kind of database in
this course we're going to use postgres
we will be talking about other databases
at the very end when we talk about next
steps
and
you know this is a stack that i chose
because i'm very familiar with it and i
think it is future proof in terms of
uh what you learned and what you can
apply
at your work or in your next um
you know free time project over the next
few years
lastly we will be using two deployment
platforms one is versailles
we will deploy the swelt kit application
to yourself and serve our web
application from there
and secondly we will use something
called a railway
a hosting provider where we will be
hosting postgres
and you'll see
how easy it is to set up a postgres
database on the railway connect with
from swell kit in versailles and get
everything up and running
that is a very high level overview of
what are we going to be talking about
and how are we going to be developing
this
let me also give you a little bit of
background
about myself so that you have an idea of
what i'm talking about and why
i do have the experience to teach this
course and help you
with your next full stack application
so
i have been a web developer since 2000
so it's been a couple of years
and the web has gone through a number of
transitions
um you know things like jquery
well first of all php and jquery came
out a whole bunch of different things
happened since then
i react is uh very big lots of people
using that and then i started using
swelt about two and a half years ago
when it was at version two
and i've advocated for it ever since and
you know with the recent announcement of
versailles backings welt i think this is
a really strong framework to use for a
course like that
now at the moment i'm a developer
advocate at gitpod
and that's obviously why we will be
using gitbot for this
course and i will be introducing the
concept as i mentioned before it's not
mandatory to use it but it is there to
give you an idea of what the future of
development looks like
you can find me on my blog at mike
nicholas.com this is where i share
you know any of the open source projects
i i um launch or release you can go
there have a look there's a bunch of
swelt related content there's react
related content from the past
so go check that out if you're curious
about what i when i talk
next uh you can find me on twitter
at mike nicholas same handle as my
website url
and this is where you get to see
my daily thoughts it's usually about
full stack development
it's about mentoring
i talk a lot about
career growth i wrote a book about that
as well
giving you tips and tricks on how to
manage your career in the software
industry so yeah do do check it out on
twitter definitely lots to uh lots to
share there
and a couple notes on my previous
life before i joined gitbot i spent a
few years at google
where i helped enterprise customers
migrate their workloads from
on-premise to the cloud and you know
kind of help them with the migration and
um
digital innovation as we went through
that
i spent a few years at mobify a company
now acquired by salesforce
where we build mobile-friendly
e-commerce sites on top of a desktop
application so imagine a desktop site
that wasn't mobile friendly mobify would
kick in at runtime and convert that
entire website into a mobile-friendly ui
and um
learned a lot about you know monkey
patching all sorts of things when i was
at mobify
prior to that i did a couple years at
layer 7 that was an api gateway
security company
my role there was to train and teach
the product to
customers of layer 7. so as you can see
i've been around for a while i've had
different hats around my own business
for a while and now i'm here teaching
the full stack web development course
and
with that let's get started
all right let's have a look at what you
will learn in this course a couple
things i already talked about that's a
swelt on the front end swelt cage to
build the api and host the web
application postgres for the database
versailles to serve the website and the
api and the railway to host the postgres
database
i talked about data before so no change
on that in addition
to all that we will
look at typescript so the reason we're
going to use typescript is because i
want to show you
a fully typed environment where
we actually can use typescript and
autocomplete for our database models so
if we have
a database model called to do
item
and that has a number of
columns
we can then use that autocomplete in
typescript to access the values in these
calls this is all possible because of
prisma
a tool that we're going to use in order
to generate these types based on a
database schema now prisma will also
help us to run all the sql queries and
abstract all that from us so
even though we are using a sql database
postgres
we are not actually going to write any
sql queries
it's really beautiful you can absolutely
love it i can promise you there will be
an interface generated or a client
generated by prisma
where we can just use it with typescript
call functions on it and it will fetch
data from the database do all the sql
queries the conversions and all for us
the last thing we are going to dive in
is npm scripts
you may have heard of tooling like gulp
or or other tools that help you
glue together your your development
environment and start
you know dev servers and watch for file
changes and things like that
we
will simplify that in my personal
opinion
by using npm scripts and basically have
all the scripts that we need in order to
test deploy and
develop the application this will all be
part of npm scripts
inside a package.json file at the root
of our project
this is at a high level what we're going
to learn
you do not have to be an expert or even
a beginner in any of that all you need
to know is basic javascript skills
the rest i will teach you as we go
through and as it becomes necessary
so
don't expect to be a typescript expert
by the end of this course however if you
have never heard of typescript or have
never used it you will be just fine
going through this course and i will
guide you and teach you everything you
need to know in order to develop this
project
the same is true for any other any of
the other technologies that we are going
to be using
fantastic with that this gives you a
good overview of what we're going to be
learning now let's move on and look at
how we're going to build our developer
environment
there's one more thing i want to talk
about and you also notice that i have
slowly disappeared from the screen
that's just so that we get the full
real estate here to focus on the course
and i will be back later to
show you a few more things now what i
want to talk about is one more thing
that we're going to learn
that is called git pod
now with git pod you can spin up fresh
automated developer environments for
each task
in the cloud
in seconds
now that's a fancy way of saying that
instead of using your local development
environment
what you get is a new developer
environment fully automated for every
task we're going to be working on
you will see how this works as soon as
we start coding very very shortly but
for now i just want you to be aware of
this and as i mentioned just a little
while ago you don't need to use it but
if you do want to see
what
it looks like and how it works
definitely give it a go you get 50 hours
for free
per month so plenty of free time to
actually get through that entire course
together with me here so
with that in mind
check out gitpod.io if you're curious
otherwise let's quickly move on and get
into the project overview and discuss
what application we are actually going
to develop
okay now that we talked about what we
will learn let's have a look at the ui
of the project that we are going to
develop
you can see we are going to build a
to-do application and i'll explain in
just a second why we focus on the to-do
application
the ui
you see here is developed
by the swelt team and you get that out
of the box if you create a new swelt
application
that uses the default template
now
why are we copying something that
already exists
because this course is about full stack
web development so i don't want to spend
time building the ui and instead we will
use something existing and we'll spend
the time
in the course focusing on
deploying
gluing the things together
writing scripts and automating a lot of
the process for the deployment of the
full stack application
what i do want to talk about though is
focusing on the why
we chose it to do application and the
reason for that
is very simple 82 application gives us
everything you need in order to build
your own project once you're done with
this course
to get started we have to
create to do items so we can tap here to
add a new item
that will teach us how to send
new data to the backend from where we
will persist it in the database
you'll always need that functionality no
matter what application you build
secondly we will learn how to read
the items that we created
so that teach us kind of the opposite
way we're going to go to the database
and ask for information that will be
sent to the backend and from there to
our front-end application
next we will learn how to update an
existing item by checking it off or
marking it as done
that will teach us how to
go to the database and edit or update an
existing item that's already persisted
and lastly we will learn over here how
we delete
an item from the database
if you take the initial letters of
create read update and delete you get
the acronym crud that you may have heard
of or read about before
crud is the foundation that you need for
any project that you will be working on
the future so if you know how to do that
as part of a very simple to do
application
you can apply that exact same concept to
your next billion dollar idea that you
will be developing
with that out of the way
i want to move on and give you an
introduction to
the architecture of the entire
end-to-end stack so that we can see how
the front-end the api and the database
all communicate with each other
now that we've seen the ui of the to-do
application i want to talk about
the
end-to-end architecture what is this
going to look like once it's all
deployed
onto their cell and railway
the very first thing we will be working
on is the front end we're going to build
that ui it will not do anything when we
click on any buttons but at least we
will build the user interface
with all the different states and all
that so that
the real focus after that can be on the
rest of the architecture all the stuff
that's white at the moment so let's have
a look at what we're going to build
as i mentioned we will be using swelt
for the front end
to develop that web application
now
in order to serve the web application to
our users we have to host it somewhere
and the hosting
for the web application will happen on
versailles
and we will be using swelt kit they have
the same logo but uh swelt on the front
end swelt kit
on versailles to host the application
also universal
on in swell kit on versailles we will
have the apis
exposed for the front end so if we look
at that
we will have the front end make apbi
requests
to a rest api hosted on versailles
inswell kit for example to fetch all to
do's
so a get request slash to do's
and then the swell kit api will return a
json object with the list of the two two
items that you can see in the ui we saw
that just a few minutes ago
in order for swell kit
to return the json we need to fetch it
from the database so let's have a look
at how this looks like somewhere we'll
have to write select star from to do's
send that query to the postgres database
that is deployed on railway
the postgres database will return the
sql response
that contains the rows from the database
for all these items that are persisted
and then
it will be sent to sweltkit and returned
to the swelt application in the browser
from where we can then render the json
and display this beautiful list
you notice there's a missing piece
and
that missing piece
is prisma
a library we're going to be using
that helps us translate
from the
requests that we get in the get to do's
we will be able to just call a few
functions telling prisma to go get our
to do's and prisma will take care
of writing the sequel or generating the
sequel that will be sent to postgres
equally when the response from postgres
comes back
onto versailles
prisma will be the first point of
contact to take that raw sql response
convert it into
javascript objects that
we can then turn into json responses
that are being sent back to the browser
so swelt on the front end
sending an api request to swelt kit
from where we use prisma in order to
send a request to the postgres database
on the way back when the response comes
back
prisma converts the sql response to
javascript objects
swell kit
creates the response for the browser
sends it back and the browser displays
the to do items that we fetched in the
first place
a very standard
three-tier application
and this is exactly what we're going to
build as part of this course so let's
move on and get started with coding
okay let's get started
with the initialization of our
application
first things first we need to create a
git repository somewhere so we can host
the code start creating pull requests
you can do that on bitbucket gitlab or
github
i i choose github here but this works
with any other hosting provider as well
so at the top right i'll start by
clicking the plus new repository
i want this to be part of git pod dash
io
full stack
web development that's the repository
name
i want to make it public so you all have
access to it and you can look at the
source code and follow along
as well as i want to add a readme file
just so that we have some
content in the repository when we get
started
let's create a repository
and that only takes a couple seconds
now
we've got this all set up and
we are ready to initialize
our swelt kit
application so that we can then build
the front end and eventually deploy that
application
to versailles
the first thing you notice
on my screen
is that i have a green
git board button
that
i
added here as a browser extension
if you're interested in following along
and i i recommend you do um to just
experience
what it is like to develop your
application in the cloud and access it
through a browser you can install that
gitbot button
by opening a new tab and go to
docs
and search for browser extension
under references browser extension
you can click the chrome link if you're
on a chromium based browser or firefox
if you use firefox i believe there's a
safari extension as well
that you can find as well
so once installed
then you will see that green button if
you don't
want to install that for for some reason
you can achieve the same behavior as the
button does
by going to your url in the address bar
and prefix the url with gitpod.io
that's gitpod.i
that works for
github gitlab or bitbucket repository
urls
when you hit enter that will start a
gitpod workspace
for that specific
url that you provide
the only difference between
using the url and using the button
is that the url navigates away from your
repository page
whereas the button
over here creates a new environment
and
opens a new browser tab and then starts
the workspace there
so i prefer the button just manually for
that reason and also it's easier than
changing the url
before we do any work
we don't want to
work on the main branch so let's quickly
create an issue
so that we can do our work in a feature
branch and then merge that branch back
into the main branch when we are ready
for that
let's call it initialize
the application
we submit that
and now
we are looking at an issue
and we still have the gitbot button so
the same concept applies prefix to url
gitpod.io
or install the browse extension
we're going to click
the button here you see it opens a new
tab
it creates
a developer environment
from scratch and that's every time we do
it we work on an issue we use a brand
new environment
and we will later automate this
so that
it will download dependencies start the
dev server start database it will all do
all that for us
so we don't have to do any of that
manually
so that's a pretty good start
what we're looking at here
is
vs code
accessed through a browser
but also we have access to
the terminal so if we go to the
hamburger menu terminal
and new terminal
what you see down here is just a
ubuntu-based
operating system where we can
run commands that you can run locally as
well
and we can use that just as a local
environment
by the way if you prefer to work on your
local computer
then you can certainly clone the
repository and follow along locally the
alternative is that you could still
leverage
the high powered
computers that you get through gitpod
but use your local vs code
so again through the menu
at the bottom here
you could say git put open in vs code
or gitbot open in vs code insiders
depending on which version of vs code
you have installed on your local
computer
what that does is
it will basically
start up vs code on your local computer
and connect to the gitpod environment in
the cloud so you would leverage
cpu and memory and hard disk space
provided by gitpod
but access it through your local vs code
instance if you prefer to do that in my
case i prefer the browser
because
you know it's simply opening a tab
but you can use any of these ways
um to follow along a tutorial there's no
much difference
all right we have
a repository with a readme file
that has no content basically
what we want to do next is create
this wealth kit application
so that we can initialize that
application
commit and close that issue
in order to do that
let's go over to the documentation for
swelt kit
so
kit.swelt
dot def
that's kit.swell.dev
hit enter
and on that page
there's a bunch of good information the
docs are very valuable
but what we care about at the moment
is
how to get started
npm init
swell.next
and the name of our application
in our case we already have
an application created when we created
the git repository so let's just copy
the first part npm initswell.next
we copy that part
and in our terminal
in the terminal we can paste that
and then we can just instruct the
command line interface to use the
current directory instead of giving it
a
application name if we give it a name it
would create a directory for that but we
are already
in the full stack web development
directory so npm init swelled that next
period
it's asking if we want to install that
package
we say yes
that was very quick downloaded a few
things and
now
it is
telling us that this is better software
expect bugs and missing features
that's just a warning
as well kit is used in production
numerous companies including gitpod's
marketing website
so
this is
not really a concern just something to
be aware of that there may be
breaking changes but the documentation
is extremely well done and it tells you
how to migrate if there's something
breaking
the next thing we notice is that
the directory is not empty that's
because we already have a readme file
in our case we can safely say yes that
we want to continue so we press y
and now it's asking us which swelled app
template
you have two choices here
we can choose the swell kit demo app
which gives you
three pages
and one of the pages is the to do
application that we are going to build
the other alternative is skeleton
project
that's what we are going to use
because the skeleton project gives you
a
very bare minimum foundation
very little configuration very little
code exists
and that's really the
best way for us to go through
the entire full stack web development
from the beginning building the web
application and
documenting or talking about every
single line of code that we're going to
write
so by the end of it you fully understand
why the code is there what it does
and what its impact is to the overall
application
so which swelt app template
let's choose skeleton project for this
question
the next question is do we want to use
typescript the answer is yes
that will help us when we start to
introduce prisma
as well as when we work with the code
in our application so let's say yes for
the question whether to use typescript
and then eslint
for code linting
we're going to say no
that's you know either way works but for
the purpose of this course we're going
to say no
and prettier for code formatting
i highly recommend you do that in your
projects
once you went through the course and
you're more familiar with the full stack
web application development
in the case here we are not going to
configure this as part of the course so
we're going to say add prettier for code
formatting no
there we go
it updated our readme file so we can
close that browse tab
the other thing we notice is that it
gives us some next steps
the first is npm install
to
get all the dependencies and run all the
scripts so let's do that
npm
install installing the command line
that downloads a few
necessary dependencies such as swelt and
swell kit
and
the other step
was to get in it we don't need to do
that because we already have a git
repository
and git add and git commit we will do
later in a slightly different way than
using the command line interface
what we do want to do though is npm run
dev
that will start our development server
and we can have a quick look at what we
get to start with
so let's run that
npm
run dev
it starts the server in localhost port
3000
and gitport
noticed that there's no service running
on that port
so it prompts us to open a preview or
open a browser
if i click open a preview
you can see that the simple browser pops
up right within my editor so that i can
review the code of my application
right here
the alternative is
if we go to the footer and we click on
ports 3000
you can see it switched to the remote
explorer tab on the left side
port 3000
has
an option in the middle to open the
preview again
same as before
or
on the right side if we press the globe
we can open a browser which opens a new
tab
and now we can inspect
that
web application just the way we would do
on our local computer
okay
that's
a pretty good start i think
we satisfied
the requirement of the first issue which
was to initialize the application
what we're going to do now is commit
these changes
merge it into the main branch and then
we will follow up and go through
the
folders and directories that exist
in here created by
the init script when we created the
application earlier so that you
understand all these files and what they
do
all right in order to commit and push
these changes
we can use the source control tab on the
left
if you're familiar with the command line
interface
we can control c
in the terminal cancel the server and
you can use
the git commands
right here that works as well let's use
the ui for now
so we have to give it a commit message
we're going to call this initialize
the application
and we can click the button
with the check mark up here to commit
alternatively
with the text field
enable or focus you could do command
enter or control enter depending on your
operating system
and
get the same result i'll click the
button for now
it is asking us that
um or telling us that there are no
staged changes that's because we didn't
stage any of that
and it offers us to automatically do
that for us and then commit the files
in this case we're going to say yes
that's what we want
take all these files and commit them
wonderful
we have it committed we have not pushed
it to github yet
so we could press the publish changes
button right here
and then we can go to github create the
new pull request and
merge that into the main branch
the alternative and i believe
faster way
is to use that icon next to the commit
the one here that says create pull
request
if we do that
you can see that
it automatically creates a pull request
for us
one thing we want to do is update the
name
of the title that
defaults to the name of my branch and i
will talk about the branch in just a
second
for now let's change the title to
something more
readable
and in the description
i like to say
which issue we're closing
in this case it's number one
if you don't remember which issue you're
working on
you can always look in the footer where
you have a branch name with your
username
slash
the name of the issue
dash the number of the issue
so if we look at the issue here it is
initialize the application number one
the branch name
is the same
now you remember i never actually
created a new git branch
all i did was
i started a gitpod developer environment
from that issue by clicking the gitpod
button
so gitpod is all about automating your
developer environment and making you
more productive
now it knows that
in 99 of the time
when you open a git pod developer
environment from an issue
you're probably
going to work on that feature and you
want to eventually create a pull request
to merge back into the main branch
so git put is smart enough to just
create that branch for you with a
sensible default
in this case it's username slash issued
title dash the number
we don't have to do that any time by
ourselves it's just done for us
so if you don't remember what issue
number you're working on check the
footer
next up we can create that issue
or the pull request i mean
and it's telling us that there's no
upstream branch for that name
that's fine um please publish it for us
automatically
we can say publish branch
that pushes the branch
creates a pull request in github
and you can see now we have a preview
here of what that pr looks like
we could even merge it right away from
here
what i want to do instead is
go back to github and show you what it
did for us
it created a pull request it linked it
to our issue number one because i set
close issue number one
if you go to the pr
see this close issue number one
that's how github knew that they are
connected
and
usually we would ask a colleague to go
and review that we will do that by
ourselves just a bit a little bit for
now we can safely go in here
and say that we would like to merge that
pull request
so we say merge and we confirm
now that
merged the pr
you can see it's merged we don't need
the branch anymore and if we go back to
issues
our issue got closed because the
application is now initialized
we still have that environment running
here
and what do we want to do with that if
you work locally
then you would keep that environment you
would switch back to the main branch
pull down the latest changes we just
merged
and then
when you work on the next issue you
would create
a new issue create a new branch you know
start working and do that over and over
again
with gitpod because we get a new
environment for every task we work on
we can either just close the browser tab
and that environment will automatically
shut down a few minutes later
or we can explicitly go to the hamburger
menu
and say git bot stop workspace
and then it starts to shut down and it
will eventually disappear we no longer
need that
we
never have to come back to it
if for some reason
you
do want to get back to an old
environment
you can always go to gitport.io slash
workspaces
and you will get access to that or click
open workspace from this tab
which would open it again if you needed
to the dashboard will show you a list of
existing workspaces as i said
there's very few reasons where you
really want to go back
we are done with that so we close the
browser tab
we don't need the documentation either
goodbye
all right back to the
main page
we now have our application initialized
so let's dive in
and learn about each of these files
what's important and how we can work
with these
files to build our application
fantastic work we already merged our
very first pull request
there's a few more to go until we have a
end-to-end full stack web application
before we do any more coding though i
want to go through and make sure you
fully understand
what the different files and directories
are within our project
if you are already familiar with a swell
heat application then feel free to fast
forward
10 15 minutes or so
to go to the next section
where we will continue with the coding
if this is the first time you hear about
swell kit i highly recommend you follow
along
and learn about the configuration files
the npm scripts and the source code so
that you later understand where
each file is and what they do and what's
their purpose
so we could
review
the
files and and code right here i think a
vs code
environment is a bit more familiar for
most people so let me start a new
workspace
on on gitpod straight on the main branch
and use that to walk you through
and explain the different uh files and
directories
okay that should only take another
second
we don't need to get started
page let's
have a look so
the arguably most important file in this
entire application
is the package.json file
if we open that up
you can see that
it has a name a version and
that's that's a good start you can start
tweaking that as you go
now the other thing to look at is the
dependencies
the first thing you notice is that
it only has uh depth dependencies so
when you build a swelt
application or in this case a swelt kit
application
then
swelt itself
is not really a framework
that needs to be part of your production
dependencies
in fact swelt is a compiler
that converts
or compiles our swelt files
into
pure javascript that can be deployed to
the browser where the browser then just
parses that so it's very very little
overhead
and
the performance
therefore is is quite good
on on the on the browser side because
there's a lot less code to download a
lot less javascript to parse and execute
so because of that
you
notice that
the
swell dependency as well as the swelt js
kit
dependency for our application framework
they are both
dev dependencies
the other dev dependencies you notice is
swelt check pre-process we'll look at
all that
later
what we also want to look at is the
scripts
there are a number of interesting
scripts that need to be talked about the
first one is def
if you're going to run that i would be
npm run def we saw that a few minutes
ago
it uses a binary
called swelt kit that's provided by our
swelt chest kit dependency
swell kit takes a number of arguments
if you pass in dev
it starts a local development server
that
also provides hot modular reloading
so we can make code changes and we see
the changes in the browser without the
need to refresh the application
the next
script that's defined is build
because swelt is a compiler
before we can deploy the application we
have to run the build script
which goes through our entire
application
compiles all the files
and generates an output
into a directory
here as well the root we will see that
later that directory will then be
consumed
by
adapters we will talk about that when we
get to deploy the application
but basically it's an intermediary
format of javascript files and and
other files needed to deploy
so the build step compiles the
application creates that output
and then we'll skip one and we look at
preview
preview
allows us to
start a local server
based on the generated output from the
build script
so if you run npm run build
and then npm run preview
you get a preview of your application
the way it will look in production so no
hot modular reloading no development
server running this is really much more
closely
reflecting what the production
environment is going to look like
there's two more scripts i want to
quickly talk about this is check
so check allows us to
use a package or a binary called swelt
check
this is very handy because it's kind of
like eslint which checks your javascript
code
swelt check reviews your swelt files and
gives you a warning or hints if certain
things are missing for example if you
have
accessibility issues in your website
such as missing
attributes
for accessibility on your images or
buttons
this wealth check binary will tell us
about that
and give us the output in the console so
we can then address it and make sure
that the applications we build are of
the highest quality
check watch is basically the same thing
but it runs continuously
so while we're making code changes
if we run that in the terminal it will
continue to output
any potential errors and we can fix that
while we're working on the application
the package script that we skipped so
far
is really
something more advanced that we don't
really need to worry about right now but
if you were to develop a library that
you want to publish to npm
you could use use the package script to
help you with that process for the time
being
we can safely ignore that and move on
so that makes up the content of the
package.json
the next thing that's important is
the swelt config file
if we look at that
you can see that there's a couple of
things going on the first is
the config file
that or the config options that we
export
contain
a preprocess
property
and
this basically just
informs swelt
the swell compiler how to
uh prepare the code so if we were to use
um sas or
other uh
in our css for example we could
configure that here
and the swelt compiler would take that
into account when it
processes
the code
the other important property is kit and
one thing you notice is there's an
adapter
defined
at the moment this is using an auto
adapter
provided by swell.js
so later we will replace that with a
vercell adapter
so that we can deploy tupercell if we
were to deploy to netlify or cloudflare
workers we could install
the appropriate adapter
replace that line and we would be good
to go we will do that
later in the course
the
next thing is a target
and you can see in the comment
this is
telling
the application where to render
the the swelt app it's similar to what
you might be might have seen in other
application frameworks where you have a
div called a root with an id root
so it is under source app
html there is a div
with an id swelt
this is where the content of our sweat
files will be rendered into
let's have a look at that src app.html
next
so source
app.html
this is the entry point
where we can specify
html all the attributes we need there
we can specify the head the body
anything that is shared
across the entire application it's a
good place to define
common meta tags that do not change
uh like you know the jar set um put in
the favicon
viewport things all that
later we will learn how we can populate
the head with additional information for
example the page title which changes
depending on the page we're on
and also down here we see that diff
with id swelt
where eventually this weld application
will be rendered into
either server side if we do a server
side rendering
or on the client when
somebody navigates from one page to
another
okay
the next
important directory is under source and
it's called roots and within that
we have a file currently called
index.swelt
if we open that up
you can see there's an h1
element with a welcome to swell kit
content as well as a paragraph
that says visit some link
to read the documentation
that code
is what's eventually
added into that swelt body here so if we
were to
quickly go to the hamburger menu
terminal
open a new terminal
and we run npm run def remember that
starts our development server
and
oh of course that doesn't work we have
the first npm install
we didn't have any dependency
dependencies installed
and with the dependencies installed
now we can run npm run dev
and that spins up port 3000 git port
tells us about that
we can preview see this is the
um the code i was talking about in the
roots
so if we make this
we can see there is a diff id swelt h1
and paragraph
which maps to
what we have here h1 and paragraph
all right
we will
add some syntax highlighting to that
file very shortly for the time being the
vs code that we are using here doesn't
have the swelt
extension installed and that's why we
don't see anything yet
but that's an easy fix we'll do in a few
minutes
good so let's get rid of this
and close all these terminals
good the other thing i want to briefly
touch on
is
the
ts config.json
because we selected typescript
as
a framework we're going to use to build
this application
swelt kit automatically created that
configuration file for us
and
it has
all the
things we need for this application so
there's no need to understand each of
these
properties and configuration values if
you are curious
the typescript documentation contains
notes about each one of those
you can mouse over and then just
click the link to the docs
but as i said
there is no need
to understand what is going on here it
is safe to
assume that the swelt
developer team made a good decision here
on the on the defaults so we can we can
trust them that they did the right thing
for us
good
that
concludes the
introduction to the files so you know
it's very basic for now really all we
need to know at the moment is
source roots index is our index page in
the url
if we were to create
a about us page
or any other route
then swelt uses a file based routing so
if we do roots new file
and we say about us dot swelt
and then here we would have an h1
called about us
and if we were to go and start the dev
server again through the terminal
and
npm run dev
if we go back to the tab that we had
open previously
we can now go to the url
and do slash about us
and then we see the content of the about
us page
so this is how you can create multiple
pages
in our case all we're going to do is use
that index page to build our application
but it's good to know how you can extend
your application to add additional
content
fantastic so
this is all we want to talk about for
the time being
let's now go on
and continue with the
setup of our developer environment
and this environment here we just use
that for
showcase purposes so even though i have
changed files here i can just say
go to the menu here and say git pod stop
workspace
and
i don't have to worry about these
changes they will never interfere
with my new environment that i'm going
to create
to work on
as my part of the next task
so we did that we can close the tab we
also don't need this anymore
and we're back to the
github repository so with that
let's swiftly move on
the next section of this course is only
for people who follow along
using gitpod the automated developer
environments
so if you
prefer to work on your local computer
and don't want to experience
the way it works on git pod then feel
free to jump down to the description and
click ahead to the next section
for anybody who does want to
work on git pod and do remember you get
50 hours for free every month
so that's a good opportunity to play
around get an idea of how this way of
working
helps you and makes you more productive
what are we going gonna do now is
configure
git pods so that when we start a new
developer environment for this project
we want git pod to run
certain commands automatically for us we
also want to
configure
vs code
in order to
make sure
everybody who works on this project has
the same
vs code extensions so everybody gets a
great experience out of the box
and if they want to they can install
other extensions that they personally
prefer but at least there's a base
setup that makes
for a great experience for everybody who
uses that project
so let's go ahead
and configure
the gitpod
environment
we have an issue
con created already
called configure gitpod
if we open that up
and as we did before we click the git
port button
to spin up a new environment
that takes a couple seconds just to pull
down
the necessary
container image and start the ide
there we go
now
in order to configure
gitpod we have two options one
we can go to
gitpod.io slash new
if we go there we can create a new
project we can select the organization
or account
and then our repository and then follow
along the instructions
on the screen to configure
the
project
now
i prefer to
add a configuration file to my source
code
so that
the configuration of the developer
environment is also part
of the
revision history so we can see
what changed and when did it change
and maybe also the reasons behind some
of the changes
so the way we can do that
is we can create a new file at the
project root
so if we right click into the black area
down here we say new file
the file name we want to create is dot
gitpod
dot yml which stands for yaml
gitput.yaml
and
within the file
here we
have certain properties that we have to
define
in order for gitpod to pick that up
what we can do is we can do autocomplete
with control space
and it gives us a number of top level
properties we can specify
now if we don't know what they what they
do
the easiest way to learn about that is
to jump over to the docs on
gitpodioslashdocks
and
on the left side
if we go to references
there's a todkit poto diamond reference
and you can see that all the options
including
sub properties are defined and well
documented
in here so
if you get stuck or if you're not sure
what to configure this is your go-to
place
for the
[Music]
configuration file
now for us
[Music]
i'll walk you through the key things
that we need to
make sure are configured
when we start a new workspace
he saw that a few minutes ago we have to
run npm install
and then we have to run npm run dev
and we have to do that every time
we start a new workspace just like in
your local environment you have to start
a dev server
every time you work on your project
now with git pod we can automate that
so there's something called
a tasks
property
and as you saw if i use autocomplete
for that
tasks
it automatically gives me a
dash
and then
it lets me type something here so again
if we use autocomplete at that level
it gives me a few options
so what we want to do for now we'll look
at other ones later but for now we need
an init
task so we can say init
and init is something that
runs every time
somebody pushes code to
the github repository
imagine your colleague the merger pull
request into the main branch
and as soon as that happens
something called git pot prebuilt kicks
in
so git top
notifies git pod about to change
and then gitpod kicks off a pre-build
where it looks for the gitpod.yaml file
and automatically executes whatever
commands
we specify within the init tasks
so in our case
we want to always download and install
the dependencies for our project
as soon as somebody changes code
so we can say npm install
for the image task
now there's one more thing we want to
add
to that same task so remember one dash
equals to one task
the other thing we want to add is a
command
right here
the command executes when somebody
starts a workspace
so at this time
npm install already executed on the
gitpod server at some point before
somebody starts a workspace
so what we want to do every time
somebody opens one of these workspaces
we want to start the development server
npm
run dev
so with that
we can now
open the workspace anytime we open a new
workspace the server will already be
started for us
and we are ready to start
writing some code
now before we go any further
let's validate that these changes do
what we expect them to do
the way to test that
is to
keep this developer environment so if we
look at the url we are currently on a on
an environment called copper trash
or copper thrush we want to keep that
and we want to start a second
environment
where we are going to test these changes
so the way we can do that is
in source control
we can add a
comment here to commit
the tasks that we configured
so add
init and
command tasks
we can commit and we say yeah please do
uh
stage and commit that
and we create a pull request remember
right next to the check mark we can say
create pull request
and
that's
eventually we will want to call this
um
pull request
at gitport
configuration
duration and we want to close
issue number
three
remember down at the bottom you can see
in the branch name which issue number
we're working on
for now we are not done with that pull
request we want to do more work
but for we want to just test these two
uh tasks uh the two lines so let's make
it a draft so that everybody else on the
team knows we're working on it
yep same message
we don't have an upstream branch please
publish that for us
all right we don't want to run that all
good
ignore that error that's not not
relevant
okay now
going back here we do have a new pull
request at gitpod configuration
here we can see that we added these two
tasks
to the gitpodiama file
now in order to test
that new file
that we created
we can go to the conversation
tab
and what we can do is start
a second
gitbar workspace
again remember the url
starts with copper
and if we open a new one
it
is now amber dragonfly
that developer environment here is
completely separate from the one we have
in the other browser tab
the difference is that
the amber dragonfly
gitpod environment uses
the new configuration file that we added
to the
branch
so look at that
there's some stuff from vs code
we see that a service is available on
port 3000
and in the terminal we notice that
our application is already running on
port 3000.
that is pretty incredible because we
didn't actually do anything we just
automated at once and now everybody who
uses this project
in the gitpod environment gets all of
that
automatically
so what is the next thing every
developer is going to do
when they work on this project
everyone who works on that and wants to
make a code change wants to validate
their changes
so the very next step literally
everybody would do
is
open that
preview url of our development
environment
so wouldn't it be nice if we could
automate that as well
yeah you guessed right we can definitely
do that
the way we do it is that
the environment we just tested whether
the application starts up amber
dragonfly we can close that we no longer
need it because we already tested and
validated the changes to the git for the
ammo file
so hamburger menu
git bot stop workspace
we're going to throw that away
never need it again
now back here in the copper
environment or our developer environment
we can clean some stuff up and back into
tasks
we can now add
something else
at the top level which is called ports
and
we know that our develop our server
starts on port 3000 right in order to
preview the web application
so we can say hey
git pod if you see
a service listening on port 3000
then
do something for us now we don't need
the visibility private that's the
default behavior if we don't configure
it so we'll leave that out
but what we do want
is control space
and then we want to configure the on
open
on open you can mouse over and get more
details about that
but this is basically when
git put notifier recognizes a service
listening on the configured port
and then it will do something for us so
we have a few options here
we can ignore it this is helpful for
you know a database service or
something that
runs to load how to use a hot modular
reloading ports like that that we don't
care about
we can simply ignore them
notify is the
default behavior that pops up that
little box at the bottom here we saw
before where we can open in preview or
open in browser
and we have these two options as a
default here as well
so in our case we want to open a browser
window
automatically so that we don't have to
click that link in the terminal let's do
that
there we go that is now going to open
a new browser tab with the preview
automatically
so
let's have a look we're going to go back
to our source control
quickly double check we added the ports
all right
so let's commit that saying configure
port
3000 behavior
uh yep
same thing
this time around we already have a pull
request so we don't have to create
another one all we can do is just use
these three
dots or click the sync changes
either way
three dots and push
or sync changes and this will say yep
yeah it will pull and push all the
changes go for it
fabulous
we're moving back to the pull request
where we now have that configure port
3000 behavior
as a new commit message
in order to test that and make sure that
the developer environment does open a
new tab
same as before we click the gitbot
button
open a new environment
and you can see there's a pre-built in
progress
that is because my environment is
already configured
so pre-build means it is running the
init script that we configured in the
git.yaml file
that happens only once we were just too
quick that hasn't finished that's why we
saw it in the url on the ui
but there we go now it starts coral
llama
environment again that's the third
developer environment
and it also opens a tab for our preview
that's pretty cool it doesn't ask us
anymore whether we want to open a
preview or open a browser for this port
that's the
vs code pop-up we can just say
no
get rid of that
okay
that's pretty cool now
let's have a look if we go to the
preview environment and we inspect
the um website
you can see wheat connecting
dot dot dot
and if we wait a couple of seconds it
will try to reconnect again what's
happening here is that
swelt kit under the hood uses what's
called vit
and that provides a hot modular
reloading functionality that
we want to leverage
now
unfortunately
by default
the
vit
server
runs on port 3000 localhost colon 3000
the problem we have is that
our web address is a public url
on a gitput.iosub domain
so you notice there was a reload
and it didn't actually
successfully connect
that's not a big deal
we can configure vt in order to do the
right thing it keeps doing that
reloading here until we configure it
so
we are running on
an https url
that
is this super long url here
and no port which means https default
port is 443
so what we need to do is we need to
somehow
configure
swelt kit
to use
this url to connect to the hot modular
reloading server instead of using
localhost
3000 by default
let's have a look at how we can do that
first we are going to stop the server
and
what we're going to do next
is
we're going to close
or actually keep the same environment
here remember the old one we had
where we configured the the tasks and
then we pushed it to github
that environment
is
something we could keep working on
but it doesn't really
make much sense because it's outdated by
now we started up the new environment
based on the new configuration
so we can basically just stop this
stop this environment now
and
no longer worry about it
so we'll shut that down
close the browser tab
now we're working on that pull request
that
we
we opened up
okay so we stopped the server
down here and the next thing is in this
wealth config
file we can come in here
and down in the
um
in the kit
configuration
we can add a new
value so what we want to do here
is wheat
and then
it's called server you can see we get
nice autocomplete for everything
and then the properties hmr for hot
modular reloading
there's two properties we want to set
the first is client port
as i mentioned the default is 3000
and the other one we want to set
is the
host
and again by default this is localhost
the question is how do we change
this port
to 443
and this host
to whatever url we have here that url
changes for each environment so we need
to find a way
to dynamically load
the url and
configure the
swelt
environment
so luckily
the gitpod environment provides a
command line interface
that's called gp
so if we open the terminal a bit bigger
here
i can show you how this looks
let's clear this
if we type gp
url
that gives us the url of our environment
matches the url up here right
however
our url has the port in front
so gpurl accepts
an argument
if we pass the port number
at the end and we hit enter again it
gives us
the preview url of that port that we
specified
and this is the url
that we want to specify for the host
and then port 443 we could
somehow try to hard code that but not
everybody
uses gitpod yet so we have to also make
sure localhost 3000 is configured for
people who work on their local computer
still
let's have a look how we can do that
the easiest way
is to use an environment variable
where we specify whether we run
on git pod
or not so the place to do that
is indicate for the humble file
what we can do here
is in the command so when
the
new developer environment starts up
we want to run
that gpurl 3000
command
and save the result that url in an
environment variable
that means if somebody starts the
environment in their local computer
none of the code in the gitpodyaml
executes because they use a local
environment they don't get the benefits
of this automation
which then means the environment
variable that we're about to set
does not exist on the local host let's
have a look how this um how this looks
like
so here we want to do export let's call
it hmr host
and that equals and then two back takes
gpurl 3000
and then
start the dev server
now
hmr host
after this line
looks equals to this entire url https
blah blah blah
so let's have a look we can take that
hmr host
and
in the swelt config
since this is just regular javascript
that executes
we can use
the
process
dot env for all the environment
variables and
have a look at whether hmr host exists
so we can just do a shorthand
which means if
that url exists
then
process
env
host
otherwise localhost
so
that means
we can now run this script either
locally without git pod or on git pod
and the host is always set correctly
one small tweak we need to do
is that the hmr host
is including the https or the protocol
as well
wheat doesn't like that it just wants to
host because it uses web sockets so it
will then change https
to
websocket protocol so we can use
javascript here
to basically just substring
the
https colon slash slash
so we'll do substring
and https colon slash slash
dot
length
so this
will get rid of that um
of that of that part
um what i mean is
dot length in here
so that it counts the characters here
and then starts from the beginning of
that url
gets starts at this point here and takes
3000 and the rest
the other thing we want to do is if we
have
the hmr host variable set
right here
then
the port is 443 otherwise
the port is
3000
so this workaround here in the swelt
config let's make this a bit bigger get
rid of that
that the few lines here that we added as
a workaround
allow us to run
the
hmr the hot modular reloading on git pod
and also making sure that people can
still run the project locally and also
get the benefits of hot modular
reloading
so there's quite a few changes it's
definitely a good time to go and test
that
in a new environment
before we do that
you can imagine that if we have more
than two commands
like even now we have this one
and this one
if we had two or three other commands
this would start to get really hard to
read
so there's a little bit of a
better way to write that
if
we add a pipe
here and we moved it to a new line with
two spaces indented
remove the and make a new line
we can now add as many commands here as
we want
starting def server
so we can add as many and they all run
one after the other
so it's a bit easier to read and
definitely easier to maintain
as as we go forward we don't need the
echo so we can get rid of that line
but
now we want to go and test this
in a new environment so let's go
to
the source control and commit these
changes
configure
hmr oops
on gitpod
and localhost
all right
we commit these changes
we can close that preview we no longer
need this on browser tab get rid of that
and we want to sync the changes
here we'll push all right go for it
i can probably stop
showing that from popping up
nice
heading back to the pull request
we have a new
entry that's the changes we just made in
order to spin up an environment on these
changes you know how this works by now
click the gitpod button
it spins up
a new developer environment
that now contains that hmr
host environment variable
so let's have a look at what happens
it's good practice that you always keep
at least one environment running here in
case
you know something went wrong with your
configuration
or you run into some issues with the
changes you made
but
just good practice to keep that around
there we go look at that we got a new
um
browser tab we saw that before if we
inspect this now
then we can see that wheat is now
connected
to the
development server
so once we go back and we start making
code changes to that
swelt file
as soon as we save the changes that page
will reload and display the updated code
so that's nice now we know that our new
environment which is now beige condor
we know this works and the configuration
that we made in the previous one was
correct so at this point it is safe to
come in here and close that environment
so hammering menu git pod stop workspace
that's gonna shut down eventually
there we go and we close it
okay very nice
so we now have
hmr running hot modular reloading works
we have a bunch of automation to install
dependencies start a dev server
and what we want to do next
is
let's look at the source
root
index.swelt
this is not ideal
not having any syntax highlighting makes
it really hard to
move along and start writing code
the solution for that is to install the
swelt vs code extension
which is going to help us with
autocomplete it's going to help but with
the syntax and all that kind of stuff
the way to do it is just like you're
used to extensions
over here
and then we can look at the recommended
it already suggests that we install
swelt for vs code
so if we click on that
usually you would click the install
button
but that installs it only for
yourself and
you have other team if you have other
team members you want them to have the
same
experience and you want the
extension to be installed for them as
well
so the way you can do that is if you
look at that page on gitapod
click the little settings icon here to
manage the extension
and then there's a menu item called add
to git for the ammo file
we click that
then we can close the
extension view here
switch back
to the files the explorer and now you
can see that the gitpod yaml file
changed so let's look at that and see
what we find
there is a new section that it was added
vs code
extensions and then the id
of the vs code swelt extension
that basically just tells gitpod that
every time somebody starts a workspace
to also install whatever extensions are
listed here you could add another dash
below and add additional extensions that
are needed for your project
one thing we do notice is that it's
underlined so there's something wrong
with it
and that's
expected because if we mouse over
you can see that the extension is not
installed
we only added it to that file so that
the next time we start the workspace
the extension will be automatically
installed
now we have an option here to say quick
fix and fix that
for us
so if we do we can say install the swelt
extension
or we could start another workspace and
then the swelt extension will be
automatically installed for us
so for now i'm going to opt out to just
ignore that warning
and then when you start the next
workspace you will see how the extension
is automatically added for us and we
don't have to do anything
now there's one more thing
i want to configure while we're here
but before we do that
let's quickly make a commit here
at the swelt
vs code extension
okay
quickly commit that because it's a
unique
uh change we made so the last thing we
want to configure
in the gitput.yaml file at the root
is the prebuilts so let me show you
for github
we can say that
github
prebuilt
and we can give it a couple of settings
so the first thing
we want to do
is
every time
our main branch changes
we want to automatically run the init
script
so in order to do that we use um
master
and then
the value for that is true
the other thing we want that
to run a pre-build is every time
somebody creates a branch
irregardless of whether there is a pull
request or not
but we we basically want to
also run the init script on branches so
that if somebody was to preview a branch
without having a pull request they would
get the same benefits of having npm
install already executed
so the way we do that is we can just say
branches
to
and lastly we want the same experience
for pull requests
so pull requests
true
again if you
want to see what other options are
available
uh head over to gitpod.ioslash
docs
references get polyamol
and then you can jump down here to the
prebuilts and see what else is available
so let me just add that to the top here
hold on
see this url
um
let me just see i think
my syntax is wrong for comments
in
in yaml there we go it's a hash
not slash so
comment easily to find that um we know
about that good
so this is a this is a good place to
to check that in as well and now
git pod will automatically
run
a
init script if for some reason um
you know you don't configure that
pre-built setup then what happens is
when somebody starts a gitpod workspace
they would have to wait for the init
script to complete
so it would just run as part of each
workspace startup
but um you definitely want to enable
pre-builds because that will then
automatically run you know well before
somebody starts a gitpod workspace
and they will run every time the code
changes on github
okay
configure gitpod
prebuilt
push that as well
and we have two commits we want to
push that to github
and
make sure everything's showing up yep
it's right here
so with that
we
could quickly go and have a review
refresh see your latest changes
so we configured an init task that runs
npm install that happens automatically
every time somebody pushes code to
github the command exports the dynamic
url for our development environment url
and then we start the server
if we see something on port 3000 which
is our web application then open a
browser
we also install the swelt extension for
better
syntax support in these weld files
as well as we configure pre-builds
so that they run whenever there is new
branches or pull requests or changes to
the main branch
lastly we updated the swelt config
we created a weed configuration
where we specified a client port and
host
for hot modular reloading so that this
works on git pod as well as on localhost
this looks pretty good
we can now go and
ready for review ask somebody to review
that for us
and then go ahead and merge
the pull request we don't need to branch
and we also don't need that environment
any longer so we can close that
and close the preview as well and the
docs
good with that
we now have
a fully configured gitpod developer
environment that installs everything we
need runs all the scripts we need as
well
and we can move on
with the next few tasks
what we want to do next is
built the html structure
of the application so we've got an issue
open already called develop html
structure
before we get to that let's have a quick
look again at the ui
so what we're going to build is just the
heading the form fields
the
lines for the individual items no css
no
functionality we'll do
everything at a one step once up at a
time so
stay stay tuned for more afterwards but
for now
just the bare bones html structure
in order to do that uh we got an issue
so we can start working on that
and
we'll learn about swelt and we'll learn
about
um different ways of using swelt
functionality so that if you're familiar
with another framework
you can you know maybe map the concepts
between
the the two
frameworks you know as well and whatever
you're familiar with already
okay we have everything set up that
looks good
our environment looks okay
and
the first things first
that
page here is our index page
we want to change the title so that it
says to do's
and start adding the function out of
html structure
under source roots we have the index
swelt file and you can see now
that we have syntax highlighting that's
because we configured that in the git
for the ammo file
we said please automatically install the
swelt extension
so back in the index file
we don't need the paragraph
that is not needed the
h1
is just saying to do's
for now so that it maps to the to-do's
we have here
now below the to-do's
what we want to do is
create
that
plus tab to add a to-do that's really a
input field of type text that's wrapped
in an html form
so that we can submit that eventually to
a back end
where we can then process it and persist
in the database so
in terms of html structure for that
first part of the user interface
we really just want to
add a form so we can use
the
form autocomplete here
it asks us to provide an action we'll
leave that empty for now we also leave
the method empty
that you can see has some options we'll
work on that when we start to build the
functionality
of the application to actually add
and update items
so it's a form and within the form we
want to add an input field
of type text because we will be adding
the
text of our to-do into that field
we also want to give it a name we'll
need that in order to identify
that
text input in the request later when we
submit it
so let's stick to text
we could name that anything that's up to
up to you um text for now does the drop
we also want to add an aria
label so that screen readers announce
this input field
and
people who use a screen reader
understand what this is for
so in this case it's add
to do
and lastly
we want to add a placeholder
and if we look at the mockups
the placeholder we want to add is that
plus tab to add a to-do
so we'll do that
plus
type to add a to-do
and we close that
so
that's you know basically giving us the
initial setup if we look at the preview
you can see we have an input field with
the placeholder it doesn't quite look
like the mock-up yet but we'll get to
that a little bit later when we apply
css to the application
let's have a look at the mock-up what's
next
we're going to have
a dynamic number of to-do items we don't
really know how many and that obviously
changes when we add and delete items so
we'll have to somehow find a way to
show
this list dynamically
for now as i said we care about the
structure so there needs to be some kind
of
check mark here
some kind of text now also when you
click on one of those texts
we want to convert it into a text field
so that we can type and update
the
element
the to-do item and also some button here
to
remove
the item
so that sounds to me like one two
three
different html forms so that you know
when you click this we can submit the
request to the back end
and
check it that's done same for the delete
button remove it let's start have a look
what it looks like
the elements are below the
um
create a to do form
so we could come here
and start writing the html structure
instead i think this is a good time to
introduce you to swelt components just
like any other framework you can
organize your code by writing multiple
components
the way it works in swelt and especially
in
conjunction with swell kit
is that under source
we can create a new directory
and let's call this
lib
a new folder
lib
and within lib
we create a new file
and we call this to do
item
dot swelt
and here
we are going to focus on
one line item
and then once we build that i will show
you how we can include it in the ui
very straightforward the first thing
we'd like to do is
most likely at some point we'll have to
style
that entire row so for example when it's
checked off you can see there's some
opacity happening here on the entire
element
so it's probably a good start to just
wrap everything in a div here
and
then the first thing is that
check mark here so that's a form
with um
some value inside we can then submit
later let's add a form
no action for now
no method for now either
and then we'll add an input
the input
will
contain
the value of the to do item whether it's
marked as done or not
but we don't really want to show an
input field for that
we could use a checkbox potentially and
you know style that to make it look like
a make it look like a circle
for now what we can do is just make a
hidden input field
we can say type hidden
and give that a name as well in this
case we call it done
and then a value
for now we don't know whether it's eject
or not so we'll just leave it empty
until we get to the point where
we start to style the application
the next thing
is we need
a a button for that that circle with the
checkbox
so let's add
a button
here
the value for the button
for the time being anyway is that we can
just call it done
not done
eventually we'll change that and use
some css to make this better
but that does the job for now
we also want to make sure
the screen readers announce this button
properly so we say mark
done or not done
then
people know what's going on
once we start adding functionality and
we know
which to do item in particular that we
are rendering we will be able to
dynamically update this text to show the
correct aria label
whether to mark an item is done or not
done for now we don't know that so
we'll make it more generic and also that
reminds us later that we have to update
this
okay
that
is the form for
this checkbox next we need to work on
that
text that's shown
here that's exactly the same concept so
we can type form
we don't know the action yet we don't
know the method yet either
what we do know is that we want an input
field
of type text
and
we don't know the value at this point so
just add that
and the other thing we want to do
is you don't see it in the mockups but
when we click on that to edit it we want
to show a little save icon right here
next to the delete
this will help visually
tell people that they have to click that
button
or hit enter but it's not obvious that
enter is going to save it so we'll we'll
show a little icon here
for now we'll add a button to just um
have a placeholder there and then deal
with that later
so the button
will eventually be
the save button
and
as well here we want an aria label
called
save to do
that marks
the second
form and the last form over here
is the one to
delete an item
same concept again we can probably start
copy pasting some stuff here
so we'll want a form
and we want to close that again action
method we don't know
what we do know is that we'll want the
button here
that
again for now just says delete
once we use css it will be a nice trash
can
an aria label
to tell
the screen readers that this is to
delete a to do
very good that gives us
the form that
the forms we need for that element
now in the ui we don't see any of that
yet
so what we have to do
is
switch over back to our
source roots index dot swelt
and we have to
import that component that to do item
component we created
the way to do that in swelt
is
very interesting and also extremely
handy so what you see right now is
pure html
this is
no jsx no um
you know library on top of html or
anything like that it's just html the
way the browser understands html
in order to
import a component
in swelt you can add your scripts that
are needed on this route or in this
component particular right to the same
file so at the top
it doesn't have to be at the top by the
way it could be below as well but i
prefer it at the top
you can add a script
tag that's a regular html script tag
and within that
we can say
import
to do item this is going to be the name
of our to-do item component
and where do we want to input it from
one directory up we are in
roots so one up
and then lib
to do item
that imports the to-do item now it's not
used so it get a little um notification
here
but
we can come down here
and say
to do item
render one of them
we go back
you can now see that
besides the
input field to add a new one
we also have
the done not done button
the input field to edit one save and
delete
not pretty but it's all the html that we
need in order to render an item
as you can imagine
adding three of them
renders three to two item
lines
so
i want to show you one more thing
if we were to
move
things around
such as let's say we moved our to-do
application
into like subfolders or
change things around
what
we would have to do is go and update the
relative path
that is used in our input statement here
so in swelt kit there is a
convention where
if we want to access anything in the lib
directory
we can just remove the relative path
and
use the dollar sign
so dollar lib
that
automatically points to
the source lib you can see that up here
in the tooltip
it points to the source lib to do items
well so it
automatically replaces that now we can
move that input statement
anywhere in our code
and it will automatically resolve to the
correct
endpoint or
directory here in the file system
so that's a neat little trick
to
help us
load that to do item
there's one more thing we want to do
while we're working on the html
structure
it's
setting a title for
the application at the moment if we
inspect that
and we go to the head
you can see that there are some meta
tags they come from our source
slash app.html
there's some script some styles
but
there's no title
so
remember
if we go to src slash app.html
there's the meta tags i just showed you
there's no title we could add one here
but then it would be the same title for
the entire application
so in order to populate that dynamically
created swelled head
what we can do
in our index file
somewhere up here
is
use a special component called swelt
colon and you can see there's a few of
them the one we care about right now is
head
if we use that
we can now put any
html
elements that are valid within the head
inside of here and swelt will
dynamically populate that
when the different pages load
so the element we want to add is title
and we want to call it todos
now you notice that it already reloaded
hot module reloading kicked in and the
title now says to do's
and
if we update that and we save
then it immediately updates as well
so that's nice
but
let's make an agreement that the title
should always reflect
whatever the h1 element is here
okay so that the
h1 on the page maps to the title in the
browser
window that's happening right now
because we wrote to-do's twice
fair enough but if we were to change
that
to do's title here we would have to
remember to also change it here
so i'll show you how you can use
variables in swelt
and reference them within the html
let's create a variable called title
and
the name for that is or the value is to
do
by the way that name variable name could
be anything it could be page title
whatever you want it to be
in order to use it
in your html
we can select these two with command d
or ctrl d
to have multiple cursors so we delete
the hard-coded text
we use
opening curly brackets variable name
closing curly brackets
and now you can see the to do here and
here is still the same
if we were to make a change
then the browser updates as well as the
to-do item here
so this is how you can use
variables within
your html
in this world component
so we'll keep it like that that's
probably a good start
and
it's a good reference as well if you
want to update that later
excellent i think this is a good spot
to
declare that issue as complete we did
develop the html structure
that is all in place
now this goes back to to do
and we can go ahead and commit these
changes
i personally like to do a quick self
review before i commit it so that you
know at least i had another look at my
code before i push it
make sure there's nothing obviously
wrong that would just stand out
and then here we want to call this um
use the same develop html
structure
commit that yep
and
we can go ahead and write from here
create a pull request
we don't need
quickly update that a bit structure
and we want to close issue number
five
and we don't need to make it a draft we
are ready to go
so create publish branch
that will
do the work for us there we go
we are ready for somebody to review that
for us
what we did was
we updated the index file
by setting a title
using the swelt head to modify the html
used within the head tag
and then we created a form for the
creation of new to do items and we
render a swelled component called to-do
item that we import from the dollar lib
slash to do item dollar lib is a
naming convention let's configure within
swell kit to automatically point to src
slash lib
this is our swell component 482 item
three forms
first one to mark an item standard not
done
save to do and delete so this looks very
good
we can commit that
and then move on and start
to apply
just a bit of css to make it more look
like this
so that
this is a bit easier to work with as we
progress and start to add functionality
all right
we go and merge the pull request
and delete the branch
and as we're used to we don't need the
our preview we can close that
the same is true for our developer
environment we don't need that either
we're done so we throw it away there we
go
and
that's merged issues are gone
and we are ready to go and
work on the next step
okay with all the html elements in place
we are now going to add
css
so that the web application looks like
the mockups if you remember this is the
end result of what we want to achieve
and
let's get started with that so we have
an issue apply css styles
where we can start a developer
environment
and
continue with our work
what we're going to learn here is
how to apply
styles in swelt components
there's
a few options different ways we'll talk
about that
and
basically the end result is we want to
turn what we currently have here
the
unstyled to-do application
we want to turn that
into
what we see
right here in the uh in the mock-up
okay switching over to our developer
environment
we don't need any of these things at the
moment the server is already running so
we'll just keep that
up and running
maybe first thing we can do is inspect
the web application
so that we can then
uh look at
css different styles
and keep an eye on you know what what's
happening
so
with that
let's let's get started and apply
css to this application
the first thing
i want to
show you is how we can use regular css
files
to
style the application
and
use the styles that we add
across the entire application so that we
can put certain default behavior in
place
that applies to the entire application
where
like we define style
attributes such as the defund family or
primary colors and things like that
so we want to do
this by creating a
css file under source
so let's say source and then new file
and we'll call this app.css
okay this is a regular css there's
nothing
um
nothing fancy about this
the first thing we can do
is
turn that white background that we
currently have into more of this
gradient
approach that you see
on the in the mockup
the way to do that is
we target the body element of the of the
web application
and
for now we can just say the background
color
equals to
a hash value so b9c
62 that could be you know whatever
um you need for your your environment
later
so with that
um it's still white because we haven't
actually loaded that css file yet the
app.css is an arbitrary name that i
chose you could name this file
anything you like
so before we go any further let's just
make sure the changes we apply are
actually visible in the developer
environment
so
in our case we have a source roots index
file
and
in this file
what we can do is import
the css file that we just created a
little while ago so if we go to
the script this is where we import the
to do component as you remember
we can also import
the css file
which lives uh two directories up
and there is the
uh oops my apologies it's one directory
up
and app.css
so with that if we switch back to the
judo application we now have
the grayish background
so that's
one way to load the css file now
one thing i want to show you
is
if we were to add a second route so
under source roots new file
we call this about us
just as a as a test
and within the
about us file we create
the header for now that we see we
changed to url
if i were to switch to about us
it did not apply that change to the css
background here and that's because
as you can guess in the index file we
import the file we don't do that
in about us
i could create a script tag and import
the css file as well
but that would not be very scalable
so instead
there is a special file we can create
at any level within the roots um tree so
if there were sub directories we could
create more
of these files and the file is called
underscore underscore layout
so within src slasher roots underscore
underscore layout
dot swelt
this
file
contains code that applies to all the
routes
within the directory where it's defined
as well as all sub-directories
below that
so what we can do here
is we can
import that css file
at the layout level which then applies
to about us and index and anything else
within the directory or its
subdirectories
so going back here
let's remove the
css import from the index file
and in the layout
we're going to create a script tag
and
import
that css from here
if we go back to the user interface
we notice that
the about us page now shows the
background
but it doesn't show
the title anymore and the same is true
on the index page
completely empty but the background is
there
so
we need to
render
the content of whichever page we're on
whether we're on the root page or on the
about us page
we need to tell swelt
to
render the content dynamically depending
on the url
and the way we can do that in the layout
component
is by using what is called a slot
so slot as a component
and now swelt dynamically replaces line
number five
with the content of either the index
file or the about us page depending on
the url we are on
if we switch back
we have our style
uh our to-do's back
and on the about us page
we have the title
all right that is
a good place to keep that if we wanted
to
add additional
html into the layout file that applies
to
the
other files and roots
we could do things like
wrap the slot in a main
html element and maybe below
we could add a footer where we say
copyright
something like that
and then in the ui
the
if we
were to
if we were to save that
and then go back to to the ui
we would now have the copy right here
the footer as well as on the index page
copyright as well
okay that gives you a good idea of how
you can extend the application and share
some code
across multiple
as always the swelt documentation at
swelt.dev
contains a lot more information about
the feature of slots and how you can use
them in your own components to nest
certain
functionality as well as how you pass
props from
the parent component to the slot and
vice versa
for the time being we don't really have
a footer so let's get rid of that
we also don't have an about us page so
we will drop that as well
but we will keep the main and the slots
so that we can use our css file
back on the index page
good so we don't know we no longer need
that
and we don't need this index file at the
moment either
good
so
this is a good place to be to understand
how we can load the css
now what we want to do
is apply a few more
uh things to um
the website in terms of styling we are
not quite done we are actually far from
done
so
back in the css file
what we can do is first of all
this um color
is our primary color that we want to use
across the application so in order to
not have to repeat that hex value
we can use a pseudo element root
and then we can specify
a css property here called
dash dash primary
color
and use that hex value that we have down
here
to define
the
primary color value
and
now anywhere in our css we can instead
of copying that hex we can just use the
primary color
variable so we'll do var
and we use primary color autocomplete
makes that super easy
so in order to create the gradient
that you see here
we need
at least one more color so that we can
specify the gradient from this point to
this point in terms of the colors
but we're gonna add two more just so
that we have
three colors so secondary
color
and the value for that
is uh d0
dde9
again these are just values i i took
from the example but you can use your
own brand colors
and lastly the third one
tertiary color
and for that
we use the hash
edf
0f8
nice
so this is not really a css tutorial
but to just make sure the application
looks all right
we'll apply a background
and we can use the linear gradient
for that
and
just add a few values here so we want to
rotate by 180 degrees
and then use the three colors that we
defined
to specify
how we are
styling this so let's have a look
here
and
secondary
and
very last one
there there we go
so if we go back
we have
the
gradient that you can see
and the problem is that it happens
kind of three times
two and a half times
and
the reason for that
is that our body
is not really spanning the entire height
of the window so we can fix that
fairly easily by
updating our body definition and add
a min height
of
100
viewpoint height
and now if we look at that
we get that gradient across the three
colors
nicely applied the other thing i want to
do is see that margin on the left here
um i want to take full control over that
and not let the browser interfere
so one
workaround for that is to just basically
set a margin of zero
at this level
so that we can use
our own margins eventually to apply here
now you see there's a line all the way
to the left
good so this app.css file is a good
place to define
all sorts of
global
css properties
one one more thing we could do
is although that doesn't make too much
of a difference but just want to show
you in case you have your own custom
fonts so we could specify the font
family here
and
i don't know pick one or use your own if
you have your own font
that applies as well to everything
good one
other thing we want to do
if we look at this page versus
the mockup the to-do text is centered
and
we can just agree now that this is a
design
decision that we want to apply to all
the
h1 elements across the entire project
once we add more pages we want the same
behavior
so again the app.css is a fantastic
place to configure that
we can say
h1 and
text align
and then make this center
as well as just specify
a font size
of let's say 2rem
this then applies across the board
and makes all our pages look the same
exactly same
and just because we are here
if you wanted to apply
a media query or or really any css
because that's just a regular css file
there is no
special use case or ending we can use
media queries as well if we
were inclined to do so
so for example we can change
if we had a min width of let's say 720
pixels
we can apply
a different font size for example for
the h1
as in you know
something for you to
work with so anything you can do in css
you can do here it applies
to um to do item depending on the
on the media query that applies
okay
with that we learned how we can apply
css across the board
now for
the styling of the
actual
to do up here so the different rows
um the opacity here the margins all
these things
that is css that we don't
want to apply
to all the pages right the to-do
application may live on one
app or one url
uh maybe slash to do or or something
like that and
we only want this css
to impact
that one component
which also means that the browser
doesn't have to download that css
for every page the user navigates to we
only want the browser to download
that check mark for example
when a user actually looks at the to do
application
so with swelt the way we can do that
is straight in this wealth component
we can write css
and make sure that
this applies only there so let's have a
look
at the index file
under source root so we don't need the
global css file anymore
but under source roots index.swelt
we can
besides the script and the html we can
add one more thing
and
that
is a style
tag
so a regular html
style
element
and within this
we can use
css
to target
our elements within that component
for example if i were to
target
a form
like this
in regular
css if it's in the app.css file
anything i put in here into that
definition would apply across the board
across the entire application
because i'm specifying this style
element within my component or my root
here
anything i put here even though i use
form
like this as an element
it only applies to that form
within the component
so any css is locally scoped
to the component which makes it very
easy to reason about
what happens if i change anything in
this form definition
it will not impact anything outside that
component super easy to make changes
down the road without worrying that you
know you accidentally may have broken
the form layout on a different page or a
different part of the application
now we're not gonna target the form like
this but i wanted to show you how this
works
what we are going to do though
is
basically wrap the entire application
in a diff
just so that we can target it and apply
things like
centering of the elements and things
like that so
let's first create
that div
here and then
move
our entire application
inside of that div
so same code as before but wrapped in a
div element now let's give that a class
so class
to do's
and now within the style
element that we defined here we can
target
that to use
diff
and apply css
the
few things we want to do here is we want
to specify a width
of
100
we also want to
limit the maximum width in case somebody
has an ultra wide monitor
we don't want this to stretch all the
way from the left to the right
so let's set a max width
of 42 rem because you know why not 42
and let's put a margin
around of
something like that to center it
and with that we can switch back
and you can now see that
there's a much bigger margin and if we
inspect that
part of the application where we have
our to do's
you notice that there's no margin at the
top left and right
and if i was to
change the size this moves along
and the margin adjusts accordingly
okay
one thing you do notice is that swelt
created
its own
um s-class name
this is just so that we swelt can
uniquely target
that element
with um css so that nothing we have to
worry about and it just happens under
the hood for us
all right
the next thing we want to do
while we're while we're here
is
we want to target that
new
input field
here
and as you see in the mockup it doesn't
really have
a background so or a border or things
like that
so let's go back and
define
the dot new
class
and right now swelt
is telling us that there's an unused css
selector
and that's because
we specified a.new
class
uh here but we actually didn't use it
anywhere in the html there's no new
class anywhere applied so this is a nice
feature of the swelt compiler telling us
that hey
you have this element here but
none of the it's not used so you may as
well delete it and save the browser from
downloading a few bytes
um by not having this this definition
so that will come in handy you'll see
the benefits of that once you start
refactoring your application
you may move
let's say that form
somewhere else and forget to include the
css then you'll get that warning and you
can move the css along with the form
so that everything continues to look the
way you want it to look
so what we want to do
for
the input field here is first of all
just add a bit of a margin here they're
a bit too close together
and that's easily done
by first of all going to our input field
for the new
to do item
and
we have that wrapped within a form so we
can target that form either with just
form or i like to be a bit more specific
and do use a class name
and call it new
and now we still have an error but it's
only telling us that please don't use
empty rule sets it recognize that we
have a class with new so that warning is
gone
and then what we want to say is just
margin here
tiny bit
of margin at the bottom
that applies nicely right there
good
the
other thing for the element the input
element itself
we can target that as well
by creating
another class
so dot new and then within that new form
we're going to target the input element
like this
and that then
applies css for that specific element
what we want to do is couple things
first of all it's a little bit bigger
than the rest
so let's say
font size 28 pixels
and then we want to stretch it oops
stretch it all the way
and give it some padding
such as
oops sorry 1 em
um 0.3
this is the values here are you know i'm
not making it up that stuff that's in
the default template
so
um since we're not really focusing on
the styling part um we can freely copy
that and apply so basically
we add all that in one go
it's a bunch of things that apply only
to that input field
within the new class
so now this looks a lot closer
to what we eventually wanted to look
like
but we do notice it has this border
around it and so
do all the other elements when you when
you select them
we want to get rid of that and we want
to get rid of that
everywhere
in this in this form we could
add the css to remove that border to the
app.css file
and then it applies
to all the input fields across the
entire application
for the purpose of this course i want to
introduce you a concept in swelt
where we can target
all the input
fields
in the current component
and its children
so let's look at this structure real
quick we have an input
element here
and then we have input elements within
the to-do item
remember under source lib to-do item
we have additional input
fields
so if i were
to come here and let's say up here
or actually after the new makes probably
sense
if i came here
and
i would just say input
the styling of that input file
as an input class would only apply to
this input not the children because of
the local scope that i explained earlier
however
swelt does allow us to target
this one input here and the ones in the
components used
the way we do that is
we
limit it to that to do's
class or that element here so we say
dot to do's
and then instead of just input we have
to use
a swell specific
configurations of global
global input
now that means
target
the dot to do's class
so this element on line 35
and then globally within that all the
input
fields
that's how we can apply styling to
that input and the to-do item inputs
inside
what we want to do for these
items is remove that border
so border
1px solid but we make it transparent
and if we go to look at that
that border disappeared and if we click
we still get the
blue border around it
same here same here but the other border
disappeared we can fix that
in the same way as we did here
just that we have to use
a
pseudo element
saying that
target that element when it's focused so
same thing
to start with
but instead of targeting the input only
we want to target its focus visible
state
and then the values we need there
again
no need to type all that this is not the
main purpose of the course
we'll add a book shadow bit of border in
red
and
outline none
if we look at that in the user interface
we now get this red border so we know
that's the element we are currently
typing in
same here here automatically applied to
all these fields
with that
we styled everything we can in terms of
the new
input field
it's now time to move on and
style each individual item
so that instead of having these buttons
and all that
it turns into this nice one row
with the
important stuff that you see on the ui
for that we switch to source lib to do
item
and over here this is where we can start
applying the exact same concept
as we did in the index file
where we
create a style
element
and within the style element we can
create
definitions and target the different
elements
that we have
so
one note here
even though we define the style
element at the top
we could define it at the bottom if you
prefer that there's no order required
script style and html you can order
these three within as well component
in whatever way you are most comfortable
with
good
let's do a couple of things
before we apply the
styles
first of all
let's
use some class names so that we can
target the individual elements
first things first the wrapper div for
an individual line item
let's call this to do
and then we need to target that button
so that we can turn
this done not done button here
into a circle with a checkbox
so this is the button here
and we want to target that with a class
let's call it toggle
next thing we want to target the form
that allows us to edit a to-do item and
save it
so we can call this class
stick to the same name as we already
used for other purposes so text
and we also want to target the button
which will turn into a little save icon
when
somebody clicks in here
by default
if no nobody clicks you see nothing
if somebody clicks on the text
then that save button turns into a
little icon
so we have to target that
and the way we do that is we add a class
name here
and we call it save
lastly we need to target the delete
button
let's give that a name
delete
and then let's start adding the css
required
to turn this all into a nice line
all right first things first starting
with the to do wrapper
so to do
for that
we use grid but we could just equally
use
um flex
if if you're more familiar with that i'm
going to paste all the css in here
again
no need to go through and just describe
all that but it's basically just
applying a few
styles so that
things look like the way they do in the
mock up
but there's great css courses out there
that dive into a lot of more detail
around this
so have a look what we got everything is
now aligned
on the single line so that's a good
first step
next thing you want to do is focus on
that
um
on that button over here
and
actually all of the buttons because
we
can we can apply the same styles to all
of these three
so the way we can do that
is
target the to do wrapper and then all
buttons within
so
all three
and for all these three
we want to specify
just a couple of things
width and height the
same number
so that we can apply a background
position 50 50 percent which makes it a
circle
um remove some colors and make sure we
don't repeat any of the background
if we have a look that gray background
that the default button had is gone
we still have the text we'll drop that
as soon as we have the icons ready
and that will start to look a lot better
buttons look good the next thing we want
to style are the
input
val input fields so input
and for that
we only have really one
input in this case that that's visible
this one oops
the input here is hidden
but this input is visible so for that
we
use flex and then
we'll see why that is as soon as we add
the image
not much changed here until i click you
can see that edit field eventually
next up
let's go and focus on
the toggle
button
so
two ways i could say
dot toggle
that would target that specific button
alternatively i can say i want to target
the button with the class toggle
really up to you
we can do that
and
give that some css here
oops in here
now if we look at that
you can see
not much changed yet because we don't
have the image yet
we'll do that very shortly
next thing we want to do is target
the
[Music]
text
down here
so let's have a look
oops there we go
so i'm going to say
dot text
and the values for
that paste them here
okay now this is
giving us a lot more space
because we are
applying that display flex and flex one
we now have a lot of space to type
and edit our to-do item eventually
good
next up is
the button
for the
save
element
so the
right here
save button let's replace that
text
so for that
we remember we have a save class so we
can target it
with a
definition like this
and the content
we can paste
i'll talk about it in a second here
so what you see is that opacity is zero
by default
which means we don't see anything
at the
by by loading the page and the
background image is just a svg
that is inlined
within that component the reason for
that is that this is such a small svg
with so very um
so few characters
it is probably more performant to
include that here rather than
downloading an external svg file
to to display
so if we look at the at the page
you can see that
um we don't see that save button anymore
if we inspect it
it is still here
dot safe but the
opacity is zero
so if we get it back we see the icon we
also see the save text that's because we
had a placeholder there we no longer
need that so we can delete
the text of that button
so now if we inspect that one more time
we can
uncheck the opacity and we see the icon
so what we want to do next is
when
the
input here is focused
we want to show that icon
like this but only when we have to focus
on that input field if we don't have it
focused then we don't want to show that
so css allows us to do that in a fairly
easy way
and basically what we say here is that
we want
the
we can we can
do this so to do
within that element
input
focus
then target that
and
what we want to do is a little bit of a
transition
so that is a bit uh smoother let's say
opacity
0.2 seconds
and
the other thing we want to do here
is
the opacity itself
we want to set it to one
now let's have a look
if we click in it
you can see that this slowly appears
well it's not very slowly but you can
see that the icon appears
with a slight delay
same here
and here
now there's one more thing we want to do
if somebody manages the application with
their keyboard or uses the web app with
their keyboard
when they
load the page
and they hit tab
it goes into the input field to create
an item if we hit tab again
we go to the done
button one more time
we
focus on the input and
you can see the
[Music]
input focus is what we just specified
now the problem is
if we tab again
the focus now is on the element
to edit but
because the focus is lost on the input
field we also lost our edit icon so we
can easily fix that by just adding a
second
definition here which is
if the save button
has focus
then also show the save button
so now if we
do that again we come from here tap
tap and one more time
now we still see our icon
so people can use the keyboard to
navigate this application
which is
extremely important to make sure this
works
all right lastly
let's go and focus on the delete
so the delete icon
is
a
image just an svg again we're gonna
inline it like we did for the save icon
and we give it an opacity so it's not
too strong
if we look at that you can now see the
delete icon
it is a little bit
um
almost invisible
what we want to do is remove that delete
text
we no longer need that placeholder
because we have the icon
we do this
looks better and now a nice touch here
is that if we mouse over
the
um button
we want to kind of pop it and and show
it highlighted
we don't see it in the mock-ups
and
just so people visually can see that
the
the trash bin can can be clicked
and the way we can do that is we can
focus
create that delete
and on hover
and again thinking about people using
the keyboard also when
it is focused
then
same transition as we used for the edit
icon
opacity 0.2 seconds
and
we want to show it at its full opacity
so with that if we mouse over
that becomes fully visible
if we use the keyboard and we go
and select
the trash icon or focus on the trash
icon it also becomes opacity one
so the only thing that's left is the
done not done
button
and let's add that last the reason it's
last is because
until
we actually know whether an item is
marked as done or not
we don't really know if we should show
the checkbox or just an empty circle
so let's add the css and then we will
comment it out until we have the
functionality to make this work
all right at the bottom
targeting that
done not done
item
the way we do it is
we have
a
we have a
sorry class
called toggle
here this is how we can target that
specific
element
so let's go to
done
toggle
to target that specific one
and let me copy the
background image
for that checkbox
just so that we can have a look again we
don't need the text
since we now have
an
an item or an inline svg
now one thing you see is i used a class
called done so let's just drop that for
a second
and just start with um
with toggle
assuming that
every item is totaled by default
we now have
the check mark
for for that
now whether or not
the
toggle is is on or off
we don't know as i mentioned
but eventually we want to show that
when
when it's checked
so
at some point when we have the
functionality
we will basically just add a dynamic
class
here called done
we will do that programmatically when we
know which item we render
and then when it's
available
then we want to do
certain things versus others so for
example that checkbox the toggle we only
want to see it when
that class name eventually gets added
here so for now let's rename that
to dot done
and it's still here
but if we render
the ui and the done
item
is is not set so if it's not checked
then we don't want to show
the checkbox
all right
the other thing we want to do is if you
look at the mock-up
that entire
row
we want that
to
be
with an opacity of of you know almost
zero so that it's kind of like blurred
out
the way we can do that is we can just
target that done
um element so if we do
done
for that entire
row in here
we can say
oops
we don't want transform
and
we want an opacity
of let's say 0.4
and we'll give it a little bit of a
drop shadow
to
just match to mockup
and then again if we add this done back
what we have now is you can see the
little
um
how do you call it the opacity
0.0 0.4 blurring that out
the last thing we want to do is i notice
we forgot the
circle
so let me have a look at what we're
missing
to get the circle to show up
[Music]
i think we added the
where was it
we did add the toggle
here
um i think that doesn't get applied one
second i'll do some live debugging here
border none uh-huh okay
um
let's just hang on we'll figure this out
there's certainly something missing
it does have a border
one pixel
um
that shouldn't matter oh there we go all
right we got that we got that back by
being more specific about about that all
right all good
so with that
we have everything in place
to either mark this as done not done
but for the time being until we know
when an item is done
let's remove that and because we don't
have to done the compilers telling us
that these classes
are unused
so we will comment this out just for the
time being
and also
leave a comment here so that we don't
forget to bring that back
once we have the api endpoints to tell
us whether an item is done or not so
to do
uncomment
when the api
endpoint are
available
good
so we're back everything looks as if it
was not marked as done
we can start adding text
so with that
we looked at
two ways of using css whether it's
through an app.css file
at the at the root that applies to the
entire application or whether it is
within a style tag
right here in the component where it is
scoped to that specific component
and with that we can go ahead and make
the change we can commit these changes
so let's have a quick review
to do item we did a bunch of stuff here
to make this all look good added some
class names
the layout remember that's
a wrapper around all the roots within
the directory where the file is
specified
and we import the app css file here
and lastly we added some styles
to
the main file so that we can style the
ui
so that looks okay
we seem to have the functionality in the
ui
forum for that
go ahead and commit that by saying
apply css styles
we committed yes
that looks
good
now let's have a look
up here we have the issue we don't have
a pull request yet
so let's have a look what
is going on here if we publish the
changes
nope we don't want to do that
if we go to pull requests
we'll go through this ui
for this time we don't need any of this
i'm using close
issue number
seven
just double check yep looks good
and we say create pull request
and with that we have the application
fully styled all the code is here we
remove the text we no longer need
looks good
we can go ahead
and you know in real world we would ask
a colleague to review we go ahead and
merge this confirm
we no longer need the branch
we also don't need our preview
environment as well as
the developer environment
that is
a thing of the past stop workspace
and get rid of it
that's a pretty good spot to be in so
we're going to move on
and look at what we're going to build
next
we now have a web application that
looks pretty good but it still
doesn't do much it has no interactivity
in terms of
adding or updating
any of the items
before we add that let's have a quick
look at the architecture
to remind ourselves where we are
we have developed the front-end
ui with swelt
and we leveraged swelt kit
to run the dev server
and help us parse the url and load the
correct content
what we're going to do next
is develop the api
so that we can send requests
to the back end
parse the data
and persist an item for now just in
memory but at least we can then
play around with the user interface and
see all these things working together
quite nicely
as always we have an issue
created it's called develop crowd
endpoints
and
what
i've defined here
are four sub-tasks
in order to satisfy
this uh issue
so we will need a post endpoint so http
method of post on the slash todos.json
endpoint
this allows us to create
an item
a get endpoint at the same url
to
load
all the items that exist in the
array for now
and then we want to delete an item the
path for that is to do slash
the random user id
of the given to do item dot json as well
as a patch endpoint
we will need that to mark an item as
done
as well as to update the to do items
text
so with all that
in place let's start
with the post endpoint
so that
we can then go to the user interface
and
create
a new item as a first step
so we're firing up a git port workspace
for that specific issue
and then we will learn about
api endpoints
that
are provided to us by swelt kit
there we go we have our newly styled web
application
let's inspect it so that
we can start do some debugging there
we are not going to use much of the
elements
inspector today
so we'll switch over to the network tab
which is what we are going to be using a
lot more to see what's going over the
wire
from the browser to our backend
back in the editor
we
can start by
having a look at where we have to put
our files
in order for all that to work
as always i want to quickly show you
under kit.swelt.dev
docs
if you want to dive deeper into the
topic you can see under rooting there's
an endpoints chapter
clicking that gives you
all the details you need to know
in order to build an endpoint
the most important aspect
of that is that each
file that is
used as an endpoint
we'll have to export certain functions
that map to the http methods
that we want to use so in this case this
is a get endpoint
we can export other ones as well to do
post patch delete we'll see that as we
go through but if you want to dive
deeper this is definitely a fantastic
piece of documentation here to go read
about that
as well as the chapter about body
parsing
which i will talk to you when we start
to use it
okay
so
first we need to understand
what
endpoints are
at the moment we have
the source directory and then roots
in here we have swelt files so index for
now we previously had
a file called about us dot swelt
whenever swelt kit sees a file
in the roots directory or its sub
directories that ends in swelt it
becomes
an endpoint which it becomes a url that
renders a page
so in our case this is the root page
maps to this file
if we want to expose
an api
we can do so by creating
files also within the roots directory
that end in
ts for typescript or dot js
if you use javascript
now swelt kit is then smart enough to
determine the file ending
and
parse the file differently and the
behavior of that will be different too
but it does use
the roots and the file system
here to determine the path of our api
now if you recall
in our issue
we specified that we want a to do
json
endpoint to post
our
item
we can copy that
to doos.json
and
under roots
we want to create a new directory called
todos
we could call this api
slash to do's
we could call it whatever we want let's
just pick to do's for the time being
and
within that
we want an index file because we want a
to-do.json
so we can do right-click
new file
index
dot
json.ts for typescript
and
within that file
we can now create
an end point that
replies or responds to a get request
so bear with me let's create that and
then i'll show you what we did
so we can say export
const
get
for an http get request
that's a function
and
for now we'll keep it very very simple
what we have to
return
from
this function that's defined in the
documentation
is basically an object
that contains a status code so let's
call it 200 because we want to show when
everything goes okay
as well as a body
in this case we can say
hello from the api
so let's go have a look
if we go to
the url and we go to slash
todos.json
to do stir json exists
because we created a to dose directory
with an index file
so swell kit automatically creates a
todos.json
url if we hit enter
we can see that the response is hello
from the api
and
if we look at that
in the
network tab on the right side here
let's have a look
we can see
that the headers
were a get request and the status code
was 200 that's what we specified in our
code
so that is
the simplest
endpoint
that you can imagine it doesn't do
anything as you can see it just returns
some text
but this is what we eventually need
in order to
return
all our to-do items as well as to add
new ones
so in order to do that let's start
by
first learning about
typescript
and how this can benefit us in this
situation here so the first thing you
noticed when i created that is i had to
type all that by myself
it didn't actually
do any autocomplete for me so let's
for now
just
um
add a line at the top here and i'll
explain what this line does
so if we say import type
and
request handler
from
swelt.js slash kit
this is importing a
type a typescript type called request
handler
now what that request handler does is it
contains
a lot of information about
that function
what parameters it gets
what
return value it expects and all that
so we can come here and
this is now typescript so if you have a
js file then that will not work
but we can say
that get function
i want to
annotate it as a request handler and now
if we remove these two items
i'll copy this because i'll need it
again
if we do that
and
i use autocomplete control space
it is now offering me
the properties
that
are allowed in this return object
so this makes
developing a lot easier because now i
can just say all right
i know i need a status and i want this
to be 200
what else do i have
a body
hello from the api
so typescript
really just gives us some
pointers
and you know suggestions and helps us
write more robust code that follows the
specification
so we'll do a little bit more of time of
the typescript definitions for our own
uh code in just a bit but i wanted to
give you an idea of some of the benefits
of using typescript
again if you don't use typescript in
your project
just drop this
and the import and everything else works
exactly the same way
all right so we're going to leave this
for now
but if we look at the issue
we agreed to work on the post request
first
so let's do that
we can
create the post endpoint
just exactly the same way we did the get
so we can say export const
post
and that's also a request handler
it's a function
and
it eventually will return some
stuff we'll work on that in a second
okay
now
there is
one more thing we can do and
that is a
parameter that's being passed in here to
our endpoint
one of them is called request
if we specify that
then we can leverage typescript again to
give us some information so let's talk
about what we want to do
when
we are
on the
index page let's go back
to look at our application
we want to type something in here like
first issue our first to-do item
and then we want to hit enter
and send that data
to our back-end api
and then read it from the request
and persist it
okay
so
what we can do is
the request handler which gives us
information about what's coming in in
the request and what we have to return
comes in handy here again
because let's say
we want to print
just so that we can test this before we
do any more work
the request
and you can see it gives us some
suggestions what the request provides
there's a body there's a bunch of other
things
we currently care about the body which
will be
the content of
our
to-do item here whatever we type we want
to read from the body
so request
dot body
dot and then we don't have any more
details
here
now there's one more trick we can do
with typescript
and that is
the request handler
we can use a few more details so
this is getting a little bit into the
nitty-gritty of typescript
but basically bear with me we can use
the
less than and greater than
um
symbols and what we can do here is
not worry about the first
argument so ignore that just an empty
object
but then
here we can say forum data
and i'll show you in a second where that
comes from
but now if we
if we do a dot here
we basically taught the
typescript with the second parameter
here
what is the
type of the body
that we're dealing with
and it's saying forum data now it gives
us different
functions that we can call here
one of them is get that we're going to
be most interested in
and if we open that you can see that it
expects a key
so let's have a quick look at
mdn forum data
if you search for that
you will eventually end up here
and the form data interface provides a
way to easily construct a set of key
value pairs representing form fields and
their values
interesting
form fields
and their values
let's have a look
in our index file
we have a form
for the new item
and we have fields in here and remember
that name
equals text
so what that means
is if we submit that form to the post
endpoint
that we defined we will be able to
access that text
property here
so
from the body we want to get
the text
that text
maps to that text if i rename this
to
item
name for example
i would have to
map this one here as well
for now we'll stick to text
we'll read that text
and we eventually will return it
so
um oops i don't know where that comes
from
never mind
maybe if we close it
reopen
all right
so let's see we have a post endpoint how
do we send data to the post endpoint
with the get endpoint it was easy we
could just use the browser to access the
url because the browser sends a get
request by default
for the post request
well we can use
the
regular html form
which
is right here interestingly enough
we have a form the action
attribute here is the
url that we want to target
so in our case it is to-do's
dot json
as you remember
todos.json is this file
now we want to target the post endpoint
so we can say the method which refers to
the http method that is being used
we want this to be
post
there's a lot going on so let's have a
look we'll clear some stuff here
and
we come here and we submit
that form so if we hit enter
it gives us a 404.
now
let's have a look why this is happening
we are calling a post endpoint todos dot
json
so if we look at the
request itself
it's getting a little bit small
but
you can see that endpoint2dues.json
post endpoint
404
and if we go to the bottom
um we have
see if i can find it oh it didn't work
because we have a 404. okay let's fix
that first
so 404
happens because
we
did not return
any object from here remember here we
had a 200
so for now
let's say
we want to return
a status
200
and a body
that maps to whatever we send in so
let's copy
that
and paste it here
so whatever
item name or item value we put we'll
just return
if we go back
and go to the index page
and one more time say first
and we submit
you can see that we ended up on the
toduce.json
url
and the server returned first
if we go back
and
we
say second
now it's a second
so we know that
we can send the value in here read it
from there
and do something with it
another one to remember is if we don't
return
an object from here the default is 404
not found
so always make sure you have a return
with the correct status code
good
one thing
that
i don't like is the fact that
we end up on this toduce.json endpoint
url
that's really not user friendly because
we don't want to navigate back to add
another to-do item
so what we can do is deal with that the
reason this happens
is because that's the default behavior
when you submit an html form
in our case we can deal with that quite
easily so instead of doing 200 return
or response code
we can use
something called 303
this is a special http code used to
tell the browser
that we want to redirect after
submitting a form
and what we have to do we don't have to
return a body
because the browser doesn't care what
was submitted
but
we can return a headers object
and within that
because it's a 300
redirect
response code
we can say
location back to our page
in this case we want to go back to the
root page
let's see what that does to our user
experience
we start
at the root
we add our first item we hit enter
and we're back here we didn't even see
the other page because that other page
never loaded
because we gave it three or three return
code
that brought us back to here
so that's nice
now the problem is
we don't see the item
and that's obviously because we didn't
do anything we just locked it in the
console so if we scroll down
in the terminal here you can see that
printed
here so the server side console log
shows up in the terminal here
and we need to do something with it
for now
because we don't have a database yet
let's create
an array
of to-do items
and
we make this an array
voila
and also we don't really want to keep
that so let's say to do
persist in database
once we have a database
we will come and replace all that
to persist it over there
so
in here
we can now say
to do's
push
and use oops let me just copy that be
quicker request body get text that's the
value of the to do we create
so to do's
push
that text
and now that means
every time
we create an item
we add the text of that item to the
todos array
with that
we can also change our get endpoint
instead of returning the hello from the
api
what we can return
is
all our to-do items
very nice if we
go back
and we add first
and we add second
and now we go to the
slash todos dot json endpoint
you can see we get an array
first
and second
all we now need to do is
when we load
the index page
before we render the component
and before we even return anything from
the server
the server has to call that to-do's
endpoint to fetch the existing elements
and then render
one line per to-do item and then return
all the html to the client so that the
client doesn't have to make another http
request to fetch the items this is
called server side rendering and swell
kit makes this super easy
now before we do that
we probably
need to persist
more than just a string
somehow we also need to know whether the
item
is uh checked so marked as done
and we also want to probably keep some
kind of
date as to when it was created
so let's make this change first and
instead of persisting just a string
here
we want to persist an object or a to do
item
now remember how we use typescript here
to help us
navigate that code and implement
autocomplete
right now the to do's array
can persist a string
but i could also let me just show you
that real quick
persist an
object with a property text
that would work just fine
so this is
okay but we can do better we can use
typescript to help us
and ensure that we only persist
the correct type into this array
how does this work
just like we use the request handler
we can create our own
type
for typescript and then say that in this
array we only want to do items
so how do we do that in swell kit
you notice there's a file
under source
src
global.d.t.s
if we open that up
we can define
our to-do type
right here and it will be available to
us
across the entire application
hence global.d.t.s
d stands for the typescript definitions
so what we want to do is we can say type
it will be a to do type
equals and
don't let you con don't get confused by
these brackets this is not a regular
javascript object
it's a typescript type definition
so we want
a created ad
and that's of that will be a date
and we want a text
which is a string
as well as a done
which will be a boolean
this is probably a good start
to kick things off
and allow us
to specify what
kind of type we want to store
so now if i say
that
the array of to-do's
we can use the type here and say that
hey i only want to do items
persisted in here and this is an array
of those
if we mouse over
you can now see that this is
an array of to-do
types
okay so that's good
and you immediately notice
at the bottom
it is
complaining now
and if we mouse over that error
you can see that
type
text string which is our
text request body get text
this line so that type is missing the
following properties from the type to do
created at and done
interesting let's have a look
if we were to use autocomplete
huh that's cool
it is telling us that there's two more
properties that we need to specify
one is created at
and that's just a new date right now
and then i think there was another one
let's do that again yeah there's done
as well
and done when we create the new to-do
item
then done is
false
to start with
now
typescript is satisfied because we are
now creating a proper to-do item
with it created that the text that are
done it's no longer complaining that we
cannot push that into the to-do's array
so this is pretty good
now we know
whatever element is in this to-do's
array is of type to do and it has three
properties defined
we're making good progress
what's
still missing though
is
the fact that it's not actually showing
our items
so as i said we need to load
all the existing to-do items
when we request that page from the
server
we can do that
in the index dot swelt file
what we have to do is and that's well
documented in the swell kit docs
but
besides the
script tag that we have
we have to create
another tag
another element it's also a script
but it is a little bit more special than
that
because it has
context
equals module
so
this is how you can
differentiate the two
every time
a component gets rendered
this script gets executed
and the script module
only gets executed once
across all the instances now this is the
place where
if you're familiar with like next js or
others
where you would call like get initial
props or
places like that where you can fetch
data from the server before the
component is rendered
this is what we want to do and because
we're using
typescript we can tell
that script that we will use typescript
within so we can say language
is typescript
the convention here is
that we need to export
a function called load
that swelt kit will automatically call
as part of the server side rendering
so let's export that function
const load
a regular function
it's a good start and
we want to leverage typescript here as
well to help us
with the
parameters that are being passed in
and kind of the return values we have to
specify from this function
so
at the top here we can import a type
and it is called load
we grab that from the
swell kit
package
and then we can annotate this load
function
by saying load
and just like that
we can now see what we need to return so
if we say return
and we use autocomplete
there's some error max age props other
stuff in here
so eventually we'll
specify the right things here but
thanks to this typescript
type that we specified we're now able to
see these autocomplete items
so one other thing we want
is at this point
this is where we want to fetch
the data from the backend api
right remember from
the
[Music]
slash
to do json
it's empty now because we restarted the
server automatically when we made code
changes there and our array got erased
from memory but we want to call that
endpoint
get that array
and then render each array item in here
okay the way we do that is
we get an object as a parameter and one
of the values
in there or one of the properties is
called fetch
if we use that fetch not to confuse that
with the regular
fetch that you get in the browser this
is a special fetch
that's provided by swelt kit so always
make sure
you use
this is where we can now call that
endpoint
to get and fetch our to-dos so fetch
slash todos.json
and this is an async call so it's
returning a promise so let's change
our function
to async
and then leverage a weight here
so the response is a weight
a way to fetch
now
if
the response is okay again you can see
typescript helping us here
if it's okay
then we want to convert the response and
fat get these to do items out of it
so to do's equals
await
json response there
now that array
contains the same elements
as that array because we return it as
part of the body
in this get request which we call
with the fetch function here
all right
having these to do items we need to pass
them to our component
so that down here instead of rendering
three static to-do items we want to
render
x amount of to-do items depending on how
many have been added to the array
so if we use
typescript
autocomplete here you see
one property is called props
and that's exactly what we want to do we
want to use the props
to be passed into that component here
so props is an object
and
we just want to pass in the to-do's
which
creates a to do's
property
that is being passed into the script
so we can come here
and
i'll teach you how to do
props in swelt
the way it works is the syntax for that
is export
let
to do's
that
gives us
a prop called to dose that's exported
from this component so here
is where we specify the props we want to
pass in
down here
you can see that it's complaining that
we don't have a type defined
so we actually have
the
to-do type right that we created in
global.d.t.s
so we know that this property is going
to be of type to do so we can say
this is this will be an array of to-do
items
and because we're now using typescript
we have to let
the script know that we use
typescript
all right
that was a lot but basically we exported
a load function
that executes
on the server when we do a full page
refresh which is currently the case
if we were to navigate from one page to
another
then the client side
would
the browser would call this load
function and do a client-side fetch
but in our case because we always
refresh that page
ignore that error
because we always reload the page that
fetch actually executes on the server
the load function and then calling fetch
so we go grab that
and
we
return
if everything is okay
we pass the to-do's
array
into here and then we're currently not
using it
anywhere so it's giving us a little
warning
we will do that in a second but before
we move on
let's deal with the error case in case
something goes wrong
with our fetch what we can say is
if the response is okay we return so
that means that down here on line 13 the
response was not okay
so what we can do is we can fetch the
message
and
we do that from await
response
dot
text
so basically oops that should be
json
so basically whatever we get back from
the server
it will contain a message object we
haven't built that yet but
that's just preparing us for later
and then what we want to do is
we don't want to return
props because if we return props we
indicate that everything was okay
so we can return
an error
and that's just a new error
with the message that we receive
the nice thing about that is that if we
return an error
then as well kit will automatically
render an error page instead of our
component
alrighty
we now have
to deduce array that contains whatever
elements are
in the array on the server side
now we have to use that
to
render
to do items
you depending on how many we have
so basically we need
a for loop
or in swelt
in swelt's case in each loop
the syntax for that is that you use the
open curly brackets
hashtag
each
and then you specify which array
we are iterating over so that's our
traduce array
and then what's the variable name
of the individual to-do
item of this array so as to do
allows us to access the individual
item from the array with the variable to
do
and then to close it
curly brackets slash each
closes the loop now it's telling us this
is an empty each
block please don't do that
that's fine we can have
that to-do item render
and we do not need these other two
items we have there
let's have a look
nothing rendered
because we have nothing added yet
we go to
first
and
we now have one item in the array it
doesn't show anything and i'll show you
that in a minute
how we fix it let's do another one
two items
nice
it doesn't show any text or anything
because
we still just render a to-do item
that if we look at the details under
source lib to do item
in the html it doesn't literally do
anything it's all empty that's why we
just see two empty elements
so first things first we need to
pass this to do
item
into the component
and remember
in swelt
export let is how you specify
a prop
so we can do the same
for the to-do item
so
up at the top we don't have a script yet
we add
script
we also want to use
the typescript here so language ts
and we say
export
let a single to do of type to do
and we get a warning because we're not
using it yet
that is changing right now
the only thing we have for now is the
text property remember in the api
post we said they created at which we
don't display in the ui
we set a text which is the value we
entered and it done that's false
so in the to-do item
we can now go down to
this section here
where we have a text input field
and now we can say value
equals
and then just like
in the index
where we used
curly brackets to access a variable
we can do the same here and say
to do
and
dot text because it's a string
with that
we can go back
and in the index file we now see that
this is complaining
saying that to do
item and that's because we use
typescript it's telling us that it's
missing
a to-do item so we can just come here
and say
the to-do prop
is this
specific to-do item here
in swelt
since the name of the variable
and the name of the prop are the same
we can use a shortcut and just basically
drop this and say curly brackets to do
that will pass in that specific variable
and now
you can see we have
first second
if we were to add third
we would get third as well
now keep in mind
the way this currently works is that
every time we add an item
and hit enter
you can see that there's a lot of
requests that's because we first
sent the request to the to-do's endpoint
where we get a redirect to the home page
and then the browser reloads the entire
page
and all the development stuff
hot reloading everything
what that also means
is that
what we just built
works even if we disable javascript
let's have a look in our developer tools
we go to settings
we scroll down
to
the debugger section
and we say disable javascript
and if we come here
we reload the page
and
we add
a
fifth item
that still works
because all we're doing is we're using
html forms and a post submission
so there's no javascript involved
at all we will
later
improve this so that if somebody has
javascript enabled
we will
just send an ajax request and not reload
the entire page but for now it's really
interesting to know that
the application works even with
javascript disabled
all right we built a lot
and
there's a lot more to do but i think
this is a good point
to
commit the changes because if we look at
our issue
we already created the post endpoint
as well as the get endpoint
they are done so it's probably a good
time to commit that so we can
check these two off before we move on
to building the delete functionality and
then the patch to update the items
okay
so quick review we created a new type
called to do
that has three properties
in the api we created a new
index.json.ts files under source roots
to do's
this is where we have a get endpoint
that returns
whatever
array elements we have in that to-do's
array
we also have a post endpoint
where
we create a new to-do item every time
somebody sends a post request
we read the
text value from the body
and then we redirect back to the home
page
to get that experience of adding an item
and then seeing it displayed in the ui
okay that's a good start
what are we going to do next
is
in
the commit message we can say that we
add get
and
post endpoints
we can go ahead
and commit these changes
and create a pull request
that let's use a better title
develop
crot
endpoints
and here we say we want to close
issue number
nine
we are not done yet so we make it a
draft
there's two more
end points we have to implement but this
is a good start
publish
and with that
it will
have added that crud endpoint so let's
check this off so our team members know
what's the status
we can switch here
and we now see the files we changed
good
so with that
we could continue to work
on that environment
but
i think it's a good time to take a break
go grab some food or drink some water so
what we'll do instead is we just shut
down this environment here
we'll stop it
we'll get rid of it preview done
and we will come back and then continue
with the new environment just so that
you see that it doesn't really matter
how many environments you start
each one is completely independent
all right so continuing on with the
other
patch and delete requests now
let's have a quick look at our issue
to
check what's next so we've done post get
now we're going to work on a delete
endpoint
and as we specified we want this
endpoint to live
at a slash to do slash
uid.json endpoint
where you currently see the colon uid
this will have to be
a dynamic part of the path in the url
where depending on the to do item where
we want to delete that part will
update as we click the delete button in
the ui
so we'll see how we can do that in swelt
kit
and also we will have to create
a unique identifier for each to-do item
so with that
let's switch back to the pull request
that we already started
and
start a new environment
so that we can go ahead and
develop that
delete
endpoint at that specific
and url that we specified in the issue
here's our new developer environment it
also opens up the application preview
which is exactly what we want
we inspect that
and
select our network tab so we can keep an
eye on
what is being sent between the client
and the browser
okay now
we can
first of all start by creating the new
endpoint file
so let's have a look under source roots
to do's
we already have an
index.json.ts file
which
we created previously where
this file contains our post and get
endpoints
now in order to create
the endpoint with the dynamic uid
what we can do is under the to do
directory as well
we can create a new file
and we can call this
square bracket
uid
closing square bracket
dot json.ts
that naming convention
with the square brackets
tells sweltkid
that this part of the
path is going to be dynamic
and it will change depending on
what
id we send
so let's create the file
and then just to
test real quick what is going on here
let's create and get endpoint so we can
use the browser for testing so as you
recall from
the previous endpoint we created export
const
get
and that's a function
and we'll just
do this very quickly without any
typescript definitions but basically we
get a request
here and what we have to return
is the
an object that contains a status
of 200 and a body and for the body
what we want to do
is we want to use request
dot
params
dot
uid
so oops
so what we have
is
the params object refers to
any
path
any part of the path where we have
square brackets so in this case uid
that's wrapped in the brackets turns
into
a property on that params object and we
can access that
by simply
calling request.params.uid
so what we can do now is if we go back
to the
[Music]
browser where we have our application
running
we can go to
slash to do's
slash and then
a dynamic part of the url so that's our
uid let's say abc
dot json
and if we load this page
you can see that the response is abc
that's because as i said we just read
that params uid
and return it as a 200 response
if the
to do item
uid was one two three you can imagine if
we change this to one two three
then the return value
is one two three
so this is great
we can then dynamically generate this
url
when we
are in the user interface and click on a
delete icon next to
a to-do item
now before we do the ui part let's first
complete the api
for that
endpoint here
so that when we built the ui we can
immediately test it
okay so what we have to do in this
file first of all
let's import
the
types for the
endpoints here so same as we did in the
index.json file where we have that
request handler will grab the same
type and we import it here as well
and now we can say that
that endpoint
is of
this request handler type
and the other thing we can do is we want
to change that get endpoint to a delete
endpoint
now delete is a
keyword in javascript that we cannot use
so the
actual name is just del for delete
and now
if we
use request dot we get this autocomplete
because we have the request handler
defined so typescript knows
what's going on here
now
we have a bit of a challenge here first
of all
let's get rid of this just for a second
the challenge we have
is even though we can access that uid
we need to somehow
remove the correct item from this
to-do's
array
right here
unfortunately
we don't have access to this array
because it's in a different endpoint
and from this file there's
no easy way for us to go and access that
um array
so what we're gonna do instead
is we will refactor
that code a little bit so that
anything related to
um actually creating or adding a to-do
or updating or deleting we will move
that into a separate file
and
the
[Music]
index.json.ts and the uid json ts both
of these endpoints
will then
leverage that new file
to interact with the to-do's item
this also makes it easier a little bit
later when
we switch from
an array that we persist in memory
to
accessing the database
we will have just one place in the
source code where we have to make that
modification
so
doing that refactoring now
is is a good point
um
to bring us into a good shape for later
so one thing i can
i can teach you now is that
as i said any file within roots becomes
an endpoint if it ends in dot ts or dot
or a page if it ends in dot swelt
sometimes just like we do what we want
right now
we want to create
additional helper files
that we can use like in this case to con
consolidate certain functionality
we could if we wanted to move that into
lib
but
that really starts to convolute the lib
directory and add a lot of stuff in
there that
isn't really used
across the entire app but only in
certain places
so there's another convention in swelt
kit and
that is if a file in the roots directory
starts with an underscore
these wealth kid router ignores it and
does not create
a path for that file so we can leverage
that knowledge
and under source roots to do
we can create a new file called
underscore
api
dot ts
and this is going to be our file
that we can access from both of the
other endpoints that we created
all right the first thing we want to
move in here
is that array of to-do items
so we'll grab that
remove it from here
and
add it
to our
api
so
with that um
being moved over here
we now
we can ignore this warning
for now that'll fix itself in in just a
second
um
what we want to do now is we want to
export
a function here that we can then call
from
um the different places
such as the get and the post endpoints
here
and we will do all the behavior related
to to do's in there
so let's create that function export
const
api
for now it doesn't have any parameters
there we go
so now what we want to do
in here
is depending on
whether we want to create or delete or
update
an item
we want to
execute different
functionality
so if you recall let's have a quick look
back in the index file
when we look at the form
where we create the new item
you see that we specified the http
method as being post
and we also know that when we load the
index page
the
server
receives a get request from our fetch
here
so that fetch slash to do's
by default is an http get request
so we want to
kind of like an if else situation in our
api
where we say that
if the
http method is get
then please return the array if the http
method is post
then please create
an item for us in the array
so
what we need in order to determine that
is we need a request object because we
need to access that http method
so i'll show you how we can do that
first things first let's
go grab that
import statement again
for the
oh sorry not the request handler what we
can do is
in the api
we're going to say we want a request
and
the type of that request
we can fetch that from the
swelt kit package so import type
request
from
swelt kit
now if we go to the api and we say
the request is of type request we will
get all the other complete
functionality that we need
now
if we have a look
in both cases here
we eventually return that object
so that depends the value of that object
the return object depends on whether we
do a post or a get
so i suggest we will move that code also
into the api
so that
in this file here
we can just make a call
to the api and return the result so we
don't have to do
any more code in here
let's start by
running a switch statement
so switch
and the value we want to check
as i mentioned is request
dot method
which is going to be either post or get
or
patch things like that as we as we go
through
now let's also
make this uppercase
just to be sure in case it is being sent
by clients in different
format lowercase or uppercase mixed
maybe
now the value we want to look for
is
here is get
in the get case we want to return all
these to do items
and
in order to do that remember here we had
a
body and a status
of 200 and to do items
so what we can do in here in our api
above the switch statement
we can specify
a body
and that's by default empty and we can
specify a status
that is by default 500.
now we set this to 500 which represents
an internal server error
just so that
if somebody sends
a request with a method that we did not
add to our switch statement
the default behavior will be a 500 error
which indicates that
whatever the client tried to do with
their method here is not implemented yet
so right now if somebody were to send a
post request they would get a 500 error
as soon as we returned that
now in the case of get
we know that
the body has to be the array
of elements
we had that over here previously
now we no longer have the array here
however we do have it here in our api
so we can say
body equals
to dose and status equals
200. with that we rebuild the
functionality that we had in the
index.json.ts file
lastly
what we want to do after the switch
statement is we want to return
that
status
and the body
so that whatever we set in the switch
statement will get returned down here
now
for the post request
so first of all before we get to the
post let's clean up the get request
and the way we do that is by
importing the api we created
so we can say import
api
from
the
api file
and then
the fix down here
the code change
is that instead of just returning that
object
we can remove that
and
we do need to get the request
because our api expects that and then we
can say return
api
and pass the request
now this just becomes a one line
function here
where we call that api that we specified
here
then the switch statement will
fall into the get case
where we set the body and the status
and down here we return
body and status
back
which then gets returned from this
function and
we are back to
the behavior we had previously
the benefit now is that everything is
consolidated in that api script
let's do the same
with the post endpoint
so
in the switch statement
let's add
a case for post
so
don't forget the break statement
otherwise we'll run into the next case
and that will have on
expected consequences
okay
in the post case let's see what we have
to do
we need to
push
a new item
into the todos array just like we did
here
so
we could
potentially create that
item inside of our api
right here by reading the values from
the request
another way to do that
is to
add
a parameter to the api which is a to do
item
and that will
then basically help us
create the item for
the array
so
either way works i think for now what we
can do
is right here we'll create the item and
then we will pass it into the api
so let's say that
our api also requires
a to do item
and the type of that is to do remember
we created that in the global.d.t.s
there's our to-do type
so we can tell what properties we expect
now in the post scenario
we want to
add
so push
the to-do item
into that array
and then the
body and status
in the post case
we can go grab that
from here
you'll see it was
status 303
and
headers and location
so
this is interesting
because
that return
object
is different from the return object we
had
down here
now
for the time being let's
just
take that return
here
and
because we're working on the post
we can come here and
exit early
to return that
status 303 because we don't really want
to return the body that we don't have
also we need the headers
object
for the post request
so we don't want to
you know deal with that down here where
sometimes the headers is available
sometimes it's not
we'll just move it in here for the time
being
all right
now if we go back to that index file
what we want to do now here is basically
call
that
api
so same as we did above and we'll fix
that error there in a second
so again we want to return
api
the first parameter is a request
and the second one
is the object
that
represents our to-do item
and then we don't need any of this
anymore
so that's good
now we notice that the return
statement up here where we call the api
and the get request is
now read underlined
and if we do that it says that it
expected two arguments
but it got one
that's because we added that to do item
for the post request but when we have a
get request
or maybe later delete request we don't
really have a to-do item
so what we can do in typescript is
after the parameter name
we can add a question mark
to mark this specific parameters
optional and now
the api
accepts a request
or a request with a new to do item
so so far we have refactored
the code
that we had previously to get in the
post
and because we have a return statement
here we don't really need the break we
can remove that for now
now
we did all that work because we wanted
to add a delete endpoint
so we have the wrapper here and now what
we can do
in that specific file
we can
leverage what we already built
in the api file so if we import the api
here
and that lives in that api file
we want this to be returned
api
request
and then we want the api file to worry
about the details of how to implement
that
the way we do that is when we have a
delete request
we expect the http
method to be delete
right so we have
get post
and now
we want
a case
for the delete endpoint
and
a break from that
the response status
for
a delete request is going to be 200 so
status
200. we do not have to specify
a body for a delete request because the
item you know gets removed and doesn't
exist so we'll keep the default which is
an empty object
but we have to
remove
the item based on the
uid
from the array that we have up here
when we have a database that will be
super easy we just say um you know
delete from the database with that id
for now because we just persist that to
do's array in memory
we have to manually just go in and
filter the existing array
but not include the element that we want
to delete so the way we do that is
to do's
we set a new value for that
and we basically filter
we filter that and we say
that we want the
to do dot uid
not equals
to remember request.params
dot uid gives us the
unique id
and what we notice is that
an individual to do item does not have a
uid
because
at the moment if we look at that
global.d.t.s file
there is no uid specified
however
because we
need that uid node to identify
an item
we have to extend our to-do type by
adding a uid
property and that will just be a string
so uid now exists
and our api
no longer complains
about
the uid not being present
however if we look at the index.json
file
we're now getting an error here because
we create a to-do item that does not
include a uid
property now this is
again the the beauty of
typescript really
to help us
identify these kind of bugs before we
even go to production
so what do we do
there's
a good way and and a temporary way to do
that
the good way would be to import a uuid
package
and create an actual uuid
or we can do a little workaround
which is fine for now
but eventually that uid will be
generated for us by the database
so we really just add a temporary uid
for now and what we can do is uid
he calls it has to be a string we
specify this is string type
so we can use string literals here and
say
date.now
which gives us the milliseconds
when this item gets created
again don't do that in production
definitely don't do that if you have two
requests coming in at the same time
you will have
a conflict of two items with the same
uid
so do not do that to do
replace
with
the uid from
database
this is something that we will fix
once the database exists and
we can create the item in the db
but for now at least we get a uid and
when we delete the item
we have access to that and we can remove
it
so
this is a pretty good start
now what we want to do next is
go have a look at
what we have to change in the in the ui
in order to call this delete endpoint
the place where we click the delete icon
is under lib
to do item
in here
you know that we have a prop for our
individual to do
and down in the forms
you can see here we have the
delete to do
uh button
now the action
is the endpoint that we just created so
that end point lives at
slash to do's
slash let's just make uid
dot json
the uid has to be dynamic depending on
the item we render
so if you recall
with the curly brackets we can access
the variables
so we can remove that and just say curly
brackets
and to do
dot
uid again thanks to typescript we have
that autocomplete of the new field
available
and as we said the method
that we want to use
if we look at the api
deleting something in the rest api
is an http request with a method of
delete
so in our to-do item
method we want to say
delete
so that
the
api knows what to do
now let's have a look
at the user interface so we go back to
the index
and
there seems to be a bug
somewhere let's have a look okay
just temporarily because of the changes
we made okay let's clear
this
cleared console
and let's add an item
so that worked
and now
if we inspect the button real quick
you can see that the form
now points to slash to do's
slash
the unique id
that we created based on the date.now
function
dot json so this is just like before
when we did slash to do slash abc or one
two three
we have a delete method so that should
all be good now let's see what happens
when we
when we send that request so we go to
network
clear this clear the console and we
delete the item
interesting we get a 404
it says not phone slash to do's
blah blah blah dot json
what is going on
let's have a look
there's our request that ended up in a
404 but clearly we know that exists
because we just created it
and if we click on it
we notice
that
the request method was get
now why would i be get when we specified
delete
in our method here so unfortunately
i have some bad news
and the bad news is that
an
html form
only supports get
method or post
very unfortunate for us because
we cannot use delete
however
we don't want to change our api
and put all our code to delete and
update items into the post
handler
because if somebody
were to build let's say a mobile
application for our to-do app
they would expect the rest api to
provide a delete endpoint
so this is really
on us to find a workaround
for our web application so that we can
still
make this work
but
rely on the delete endpoints even though
html forms don't actually support it
the way we can do that in swelt kit
is back in our to-do item
we have to conform to the
um post end point
or post method because that's the only
thing we can do
so we'll change this to post
but
we use
a query parameter
here and that's just something that we
agree on there's different ways we could
solve that this is one way to do it
so what we say is that
let's append an underscore method
parameter
and
we call it delete
okay so we are
in the request object that our api
eventually gets there will be
a query parameter called underscore
method equals delete so that will help
us
identify
whether we want to do a delete even
though we're actually sending a post
request over the over the wire
now
we could go into the api
and here where we say switch
request.method
i could show you that request
dot
um
query
we could go and fetch
you know that
um
underscore
method parameter and then we could check
if that is delete
then do something but again
we don't want people who want to build
on top of our application but using our
apis
to create
urls
that contain this query parameter they
can just send an http delete request and
that should work so we have a little
feature here that
the
that we can use in swell kit
basically when that request
is sent from the browser to the swell
kit application
we can intercept the request
before it reaches our api
and the place to do that
is a file that lives in the source
directory
new file and the file is called hooks
dot ts
not to be confused with hooks from
other frameworks that you might be
familiar with
they completely unrelated
things same name different different
ideas
so
definition of the hooks file
again it's documented in this well kit
docs but what we need to know is
if we export
a function from here called handle
we can
do things there before the request is
sent to our api
so
let's do this export
const a handle function
and
if we want to make our life easier to
see what
we have to do what the parameters are
there is a typescript definition for
that so if we import type
handle
from
the swelt kit
we can then annotate our handle function
with that
and right away it's telling us that um
you know type void is not assignable
which means our function currently
doesn't return anything so we do have to
return
something here but first of all we also
get some parameters that are important
to us here
and if we inspect that
one thing we get is the request object
and
a resolve function
so
in order to return the right value here
we have to
call the
resolve function and pass in the request
object and all this happens um
asynchronously so we have to make this
an
async function
and here
return
await
resolve
request
there we go or to make this a bit more
clear in terms of what's going on
we can const response equals
this
and then return response
all right let me explain
so all we're doing here is
we call that resolve function and we
await the result
the request is a parameter we pass in
and then when this is all done we get a
response object that we have to return
so this is the default implementation of
that handle function
so whether we do this
or completely comment this out and
remove the file
we get the exact same behavior however
in line number four here where we say
await resolve
this is when
swelt kit
actually executes the code in our api
what we can do is before we do that
resolve call
we can intercept and modify that request
object
so what we want to do is we want to
check if the query parameter
underscore method exists
so if this underscore method exists
we want to take the value
and set that value as the request method
so that when we get to the api
requested method
is equal to delete
okay
now let's see how we can do that
first
right above that
we can use an if statement to inspect
the
request
dot query and if it has
that underscore method
endpoint
then we want to
change the request method
and we want to set it to
the value from the request query
get
method
and then let's just also make it
uppercase
we don't have to but
it's probably good practice to keep this
as uppercase
okay
so now if we have that parameter
we override the request method
and set the value to whatever we pass in
into url
with that
we now can go back to
the ui
and this all failed horribly in the
meantime which is okay
we'll go back to the index page
clear this up
we add our first to-do item
okay
we reloaded the page that worked well
and now if we click the delete button
what happened is
that we got a status code 200
and our endpoint
was still a post request fine that's
nothing we can do about because of the
html specification
but
we ended up on the
endpoint
url
and we got an empty object
the empty object comes from the api file
as i said the body is an empty object
in the case of delete
we remove that to do item
and we return status code 200
but just like with the post request
where we had to do a redirect back to
the index page we need to do the same
for our delete request
now just to show you
what happened to the server
because
we executed this line but we never saw
the result of that item being removed
if we go back to the index page
you can see that the item is gone
so the api actually works just the
redirect didn't happen back to the index
page
so one way to fix that
is to
copy that
return
down to
the delete as well
or really the pattern that starts to
emerge
when we look at that
is that
if the
request that method is not get
then we want to redirect back to the
home page so we can do that
down here that'll be a lot easier to to
read so if
the request
dot
method
to uppercase is not equals to get
in that case
we want to
do that redirect 303 so we can take that
code
and replace that with a break
and move it down here
so now in the case of post or delete
it will
automatically
redirect back to the
index page i said 303
redirect so now there's one more thing
we need to do
to satisfy the
rest api specification and that is
when we do a post request
when we add an item
the return value of that api call has to
be the newly created
item
so after we do
a to do stored push
and add it to our array
we need to set the body equals to that
new to do item
and the status
code is 201 which is the http created
status code
that is
basically a good point to go back and
see if that if statement here worked and
let's have a look at that
so we add an item
and
when we click on the delete button
it reloaded the page and the item
disappeared
this
is
basically all we need in order for the
delete
endpoint to work at the moment
so we did a bunch of changes i think
it's a good point
in time to commit that because
if we look at the issue
that we're working on
the delete endpoint is now
implemented
so let's go have a look
at the changes
first of all we created a new
uid json endpoint with our delete
request we consolidated a whole bunch of
code into an api file
where we now have
a switch statement and depending on the
http method
we
process
the
request and and do certain things so we
return the elements
or we create a new item in the array
or we delete the item that we specified
in the request url
and then if it's not a get request we
want to
redirect back to the home page
so that
people don't end up on that empty page
of the endpoint
and in any other case we just return
status and
um body
fantastic this is
a good place
to be
at this point one more thing we want to
quickly review
is
html forms
only support get and post methods
so even though we would like this to be
delete
we worked around it by using a query
parameter underscore method where we
specify what http method we really want
it to be
and thanks to the hooks file in the
source directory
we can intercept that
request and overwrite the method
based on the query parameter that we
specified
and then our way to resolve here calls
our api
and the request method is now correctly
set to delete
okay let's go in and
make some change make commit of all of
that push it to our existing
pull request
and then
move on to updating an item
so we say add delete
end point
okay i'm going to sync the changes
and
back to the pull request
we have to delete endpoint here
so here we can close all that again the
environment we don't need anymore
drop that
and with that
we have the
issue here
and what is left
delete this done
is now the patch endpoint
which you can see based on the url
follows a very similar pattern
in order to also implement that so let's
do this now
we're making great progress
with our issue we've done three tasks
already we have one left which is
updating to do item
it lives at the same url where we need a
uid to specify which item we're updating
and if we look at the user interface
real quick
there are two things
we need to implement one is
the
check box so marking is an item is done
as well as somebody can edit
a to-do item by clicking on that text
and
changing what's in it and then use this
save icon
to persist these changes
we will split that up
into into two parts so the first thing
is we're gonna work on that editing text
and then we will work on
editing the check mark last
so edit text let's implement that now
and
then we should be in good shape so
develop
crowd endpoints this is our pull request
still in draft
and we spin up a new developer
environment
so we can work
on that endpoint
should be fairly quick
and
there we go
in
lots of stuff getting up and running
cool
so what we want to do is
we don't need this
over in in source
roots
to do's we created already a file that
has a dynamic uid
where we have to delete endpoint
so
right next to this
we want to export
the
patch endpoint so that we can update
the
item same concept export const patch
and
we
use typescript annotation in just a
second
for now we just
specify the function
all right
now
a quick look at the
post endpoint
remember when we get
an http body
that is being sent to us so in the patch
request
what will happen is the request will
contain the new text that we wanted to
add
so we need to use
the same annotation as we had here so
that our
body we will get the autocomplete
for
the get functions based on the forum
data that will be passed to us so we can
copy that
from the index file
it's the same concept
here as well for the patch
all right
now
looking at that index file again
remember when we have a post
endpoint
we create
an entire to-do item
like this with all the properties that
are required for
to do item
now in the case of a patch
we only get
a text property so all we get is gonna
be
a
request dot body get text
so let's have a look what happens
we wanna do the same as with all the
other endpoints so return api
and then we want to pass in the request
but
we don't have a full to-do item so we
want to just pass in a partial item and
in this case all we have is a text
so request
request
um
yeah it's
all red at the moment that's okay we'll
figure that out in just a sec
um
body get
and then the text this is the same
as we had here so request body get text
and paste that here
um
it says it kind of find a request that's
because we need to specify it as a
parameter
that we get passed in same as the delete
request
but now
it's saying that it's missing properties
so uid created that
that's because if you recall the api
file
over here it expects a to-do item
that is
um
passed in it is optional but if we do
pass a parameter it has to be a complete
to-do
item
so we have two options
one just like we specify
this parameter to be optional with the
question mark
we could go to the global.ts
and
make all these optional but then that
kind of defeats the purpose
of
you know using typescript so alternative
here is that we just change the type in
our api file
and instead of a to do item being passed
in
we can say that
you can send
as an argument you can pass
any
record or any object that contains
a key value pair
and the way to do that with typescript
is that we replace that to do
with a record
of
string and string for the time being
and
what
what that does for us
is oops we're going to close this
so we can now pass
a
object that contains text
which is a property and a string as the
value
and with that
this allows us to pass in a partial
to-do item so now to be fair this is no
longer a to-do item really this is more
of a data
parameter
so to just name that more appropriately
let's change it to data
because it's not a full to-do item
now
what we have is
typescript is now telling us that hey
you have an array of to-do items
and you're trying to pass in something
that is not
um
a a to-do item so even if you change
this to data
which is our new name
it will still complain
now
we know as a fact that
the data we pass in
in the case of a post request
is indeed a proper to do item because in
our index file
the
right here
we specify
that
the
[Music]
object we pass is a proper to-do item
we'll look at that in a second but for
now what we can do
we can
tell typescript that hey
we are we are sure we know what we're
doing so we can say that this is a to-do
item where we pass in that that data
the reason it's still complaining is
because
i said here that
we want the record to be of string and
string
but if we look at the to-do definition
in our global file
not everything is a string some are
dates some are booleans
so the way to get around that is we can
say that we don't actually know what the
value is it's unknown at this time
so we can say unknown
and with that
typescript is now satisfied
that
here we explicitly say data is a to-do
item
and we can say that with confidence
because
in the index file in our api we know we
created a to-do item
so with that
we go back to our
patch endpoint
and that
now
properly creates this object that just
contains the text
which is our new item that we will
create
good
now
patch request we currently don't have
a handler here
now we're swelt
i'm sorry in our switch statement
let's change that right now so what we
do is after the delete
we're going to add a new case
for patch
and eventually break from it
and
the status in this case will be
200 once that's all good
but just like we're here in the delete
case deleted an item we now have to go
find
the correct to do item so basically
we're going to loop through that array
we look at each item in the array
if we find the item that has the
correct
um
correct uid
we will update
the items text
and that is
some javascript
array
uh work here so to do's dot map
an individual to-do item we're going to
look at
and what we do here is that if the
to-do.uid
maps to
the request
params.uid we get passed in
then let's update that item's text
equals to
the data
the text that is being passed in and we
know this is a string in that case
because in our patch
request
we set the text property to a string
that we get from the request
so we can tell typescript hey
trust me i know what i'm doing
that data.txt is of type string
so that's when we find that item we
update that to do and then in
in all the cases we want to return
return the to do item
from from our map
and now
at the end of this we have an updated
to-do's array
that
contains the new text
the last thing we need to do is under
lib to-do item
we have
our form at the bottom
we already added the
delete endpoint
and the patch endpoint as we know is in
the same url
just a patch
so the safest thing to do here is to
copy
that url
from the delete
and move it up here
but it's not a delete
method it's a patch
method and then again limitations in the
html form is that we have to actually
send a post request
which as you recall our hooks.js file
will revert or you know overwrite the
request method if that query parameter
is available
all right
one last thing is
our input field
doesn't have a name attribute yet
and as you see here we are using
the text value
so let's go to our item
and
specify
a name equals
text
whatever you put here it doesn't have to
be text it could be anything you want
but it has to match what's in our
endpoint that we read here
that's the only thing you need to worry
about
all right
let's have a look
let's do some inspecting
and let's add an item
first
let's also add a second item
and then let's change
the
text of the first to first item
and
um persist
that item
now we have first item if we were to
reload the page just to make sure
first item is still here and
with that we implemented the edit
functionality of a to-do item
that was a lot less work than
the previous time when we
had it to delete endpoint because we
already reused a bunch of
functionality like the underscore method
hack we did
to work around some limitations we have
with the uh
method we can use in the form
all right let's have a quick look
at
what's going on
we created a new
patch endpoint
right here
what we do is we call the api and we
pass in a new object
with just a text property that we read
from the request body
the api
instead of expecting it to do item it
now expects any object um in here
and
we used a little bit of typescript magic
to
tell typescript that we know for sure in
a post request
we get it to do
type
data
and then we implemented a patch
where we looped through all the to-do
items in the array
if we find the one that has matching uid
with the request parameter
we update the text
from there we return all the items and
the 200 status code
back to the browser
all right this is
all we need for now so let's commit that
add
patch endpoint
update text
all right yes
we're going to push that
close all our
views here
don't need a developer environment
anymore
and now
i may have just closed that a little too
early so i'll show you how you can get
your developer environment back if you
go to gitpodio workspaces
then
you can see it here that's the one that
was 14 minutes ago
yeah it has unpushed commits so i shut
that down just a little bit too early
not a big deal we can click the dots
here we can
open that environment back up
and
that is just going to take a second and
give us our environment back
so as i mentioned this is
you know if you have enough patient and
wait
for the push to complete then you don't
have to do that
but since i didn't wait long enough
we can just come back here
and
switch over here and then click that
sync changes again
and wait until it gets properly pushed
there we go
and now we can go ahead and shut that
down again
so good lesson if if you do need to get
an environment back
for whatever reason get potted i have
slash
and you will get access to this
already with that in place
we have one more patch
to implement
that is to
make the checkbox work
and then once we do that
we are feature complete in terms of the
api
we can then add read
update and delete
to do items
let's go build that last piece
and then
have that application feature complete
in terms of the api
all right let's move on
go and
start a new workspace
and then build that
edit feature for the
marking an item is done
part of the application
this one should be straightforward
because we already built an edit feature
for the
text of a to-do item
so we can leverage
that exact same
code
that we have in place already
let's go have a look at how this works
all right
so starting out with the
endpoint
we
go to source roots to dos
and the uid json ts file
now
at the moment we only deal with
a
text
property that is being passed in
by the
the web app
so if we add one here real quick
when we edit this text
and we submit it
then
that body has a text property
what happens though when we click this
button
and
we submit a form to the same end point
as the
editor endpoint here
let's have a look
in source lib to do item.swelt
if we scroll down
the
to the html
we have this input field
where we have a
name done
and the value doesn't exist
at the moment
so
the value we want to put in here is
either nothing or
true if we want to
mark an item as done
so
let's have a look
basically
we can use the curly brackets to access
the to do item
and let's do this first to do
dot done
so if the item we are rendering
is
marked as done
then
if somebody clicks on the
circle
the value we want to set in this field
here
is
an empty string
otherwise we want to add the value of
true
so that then basically just toggles
between
a true and an empty string depending on
whether the item is toggled or not
now
with that we also can
update that
aria label here because now we know
whether the item is done or not
so let's do that so we can say mark
um mark to do
as
and then the string here
depends on whether
the item is done or not so if it's done
then we want to say
not done and
otherwise
done
so now this says that if the to-do item
is done
then mark to do as not done so flip it
otherwise we mark it as done
already
in order to test that we need to go back
to our
source roots to use uid json ts
and now because we have a name equals
done
we get
an additional parameter here potentially
so let's go in
and also specify the done
property
and what we want to do is
if the request body
contains that
done
value
then we want to make a boolean value out
of it so request.body
get
the done
and if
we
don't have the done property available
then we just say undefined
all right
let's go have a look at the api
as well so in our api file underscore
api
in the patch section
up to this point we only deal with the
text value
but now we also have a potential done
value so
they will never be set at the same time
it's either text or done
that will be available depending on
whether we clicked the button
on the left or whether we updated the
text
so we can deal with that in our api
by just simply checking here
if
the
data.txt is available
then
we want to set that
and the other thing we want to check is
that else
we can say
we're dealing with the done
property so we can say data.done and we
know this is a boolean
because we set it to a boolean
or undefined
now if there were more features or fla
properties then we could you know
refactor that slightly to make it more
readable but this does the trick for
the time being
and we can
you know use that as a good starting
point
going back to the to-do item
swelt component
we need to
uh provide the action
and the method
now that's the exact same as for the
editing text right we're going to the
same endpoint
so we can copy that
url action from here
paste it
and the method as always is post
and with that let's have a look
at
the user interface
let's inspect
get the console back in case there's
something interesting there
so first
we set that
let's add a second one as well
nice
now
let's check the second one
mark mark this as done
and it didn't update the user interface
hmm
why would that be let's see if we reload
same thing
now the reason for that is
remember when we styled the web
application
we commented out some of the work
because we didn't have a way to mark an
item is done
so now
remember here that css
we said that uncomment when the api
endpoints are available
now guess what the npi endpoints are now
available
so we now have a way to say whether this
to do item
is done or not remember bsd to do
dot done property
we have access to
whether an item is
done or not
so let's first
uncomment
that code
swelt immediately tells us that these
are unused css selectors both of them
and that's because
we need to dynamically
add the done value here so we could use
the same concept where we say to do
done
then add that otherwise don't add a
class name
now let's have a look and just like that
the second item is now checked and
visually you can see
it is marked as done
if we uncheck it
it works we can check this one uncheck
perfectly valid um but oh my god is this
convoluted look at all this code
to
specify
whether this item should have that class
name or not
seems to me like this is a lot of code
that
is also very fragile
because um you know there's an empty
string there's a done here so let's have
a look at what swelt provides us
to
make this a little bit more maintainable
instead of doing some string
manipulations right here within the
class
attribute
we can use
a second attribute which is
a class
and then colon
now
what we add here after the colon is the
name of the class
we want to add conditionally in our case
this is the done
value
and
in order to
specify whether or not we want to set
that class we can use equals
to do dot done
now swelt
conditionally adds or removes that class
from that element depending on whether
the value in the curly brackets is true
just
to make sure this works
let's go back
and add an item
there we go well okay it reloaded from
the server so it's all good we can drop
it
all right that works
if
we had a variable
in our
script
at the top
that is called done
then we could drop that entire part here
as well
now we don't have one called done but if
i were to go up here
in the script and i would say const
done equals
to do dot done
and
we now
can do that so
if the variable exists that has the same
name as the class name we want to add we
can just say class and the name and then
swelt will automatically toggle that
now i think
this is one way to do it i don't think
it's necessary in this case there's a
lot of good use cases for that
in our case i think this is fine enough
to just read from the to do object
directly
but
that
gives us
basically the user interface
where we can add items we can mark them
as done we can remove them
all by
you know using the user interface
now
i showed it once before i think it's
worth mentioning again to just remind
you
if we go to the developer settings
and we go to debugger
and disable javascript
that website
i can reload it just
just to make sure
i can still go ahead
and
work with that api
and the website
exactly the same way as we always we've
always done so there's no javascript
whatsoever being used right now to make
this web application work
and this
is something that
i think has been
forgotten a bit recently that the web
could easily work without javascript and
it used to for a matter of fact many
years ago
so i think it's very important to keep
that in mind
there is a lot of people that have
low powered devices to access the
internet and javascript
is making this
hard and slow for many people in the
world
so if
we do want to provide a slightly better
user experience
for people that have javascript enabled
then we can
we can do that we can enhance this
application
so that if javascript is available
we are able to leverage it and instead
of
you know doing a full page refresh if i
delete an item
you know that does a redirect back to
the home page and reloads the entire
page all this code
we can speed that up
and we'll do that next but for now
let's close this preview
have a quick look at what we've changed
in in our code
first of all we added
a new
done property when we call the api
the api is extended so that our patch
can deal with
text and
to do
done text and done properties
and
lastly we have the to-do item updated
where we could finally uncomment our
css
when a item is called
or marked as done
and we then learned how we can add a
class dynamically
to an item or an element here depending
on whether an item is done or not all
right
this is a good place to commit all that
so
we call this at the patch
endpoint
and
the value for it is
mark as done for example
okay
now
sync the changes make sure you wait
until that's all done
and
we have that
available here
so now it's a safe time to shut down our
workspace
that'll disappear
and with that we can also go back to our
issue
and
we have that patch
implemented
with that
our pull request is no longer in draft
ready for review
somebody on our team can help us
review
the
changes
and then we can go ahead and merge
that pr
delete the branch
so with that we have a fully functioning
api
ready to go
and the application is nice and working
so we're going to look at
a few more things now and
um
make good progress throughout the course
so stay tuned more to come
okay what we want to do now
is
leverage a feature from swelt called
actions
in order to enhance the html forms for
visitors of our application that have
javascript enabled
so we got a new issue called enhance
html forms
we start a new gitpod workspace
for that specific task
and
what we're going to do now is
basically find all the html forms that
we have
and use
this new swelled action that we're going
to create
that will
help us to
make an hx request instead of a full
page refresh i'll show you what i mean
by that
if we come here and we add a new item
currently
by hitting enter here
you remember it reloads
the entire page it adds the item and
then redirects back to the home page
which means it downloads
all the
the css the html and all the code
we really want to just make an hx
request
to the endpoint
add the item
to our array in the api and then update
the ui accordingly
so the way we can do that is by using
swelled actions
and
swelt actions are very powerful tool
well documented at swelt.def
but i'll walk you through and teach you
everything you need to know
the first thing we want to do is create
a new
action
and an action is really just a function
so i like to have them under source lib
and then in the actions directory
and in our case we're going to call it
form.ts
so in here
we just have to
export a function
and the name of that function will
become the name of our action
so export const let's call this enhance
because we will enhance the html form
with additional functionality
in case
that javascript is enabled
so it's a function
and
that's basically it
now with actions
there is
a parameter being passed to us by swelt
that represents
the
html element
that we use the action on
so in our case we will use that enhance
action for html forms
so swelt automatically passes us a form
and with typescript we know this is an
html
form element
and this is passed into us
into this action so before we go any
further
let's see how we can use that in the in
the code
of our swelt component we copy the name
and we go to source roots
index
and here in the
uh at the top
we want to first import our new function
or action same thing
so
import
enhance
from
and remember the shortcut to go to
source
lib
we can use the dollar sign
lib slash now we can see our new actions
directory and within that the form
file
already
with that we can go down and we'll start
by enhancing the form to create
a new to-do item
so we can use an action by saying use
and then the name of
our action
as i mentioned swelt provides a
reference to the element we use the
action on
so this is on the form element and
that's why the parameter we get is a
form parameter
into our action
so let me show you what happens
uh before we go any further let's just
do console
log
action
executed for example
if we switch to
the ui
and we clear the console
and we reload that page
you can see that
as soon as the html form gets mounted to
the dome
we can see that the action got executed
okay
so now this means at that point
we can start to
interact
with the form using javascript in our
action
to
intercept
the submit request
and then instead of doing a full page
reload we can just send an ajax request
before we get there
i want to show you one more thing that
is extremely important
to know when you build actions
and
in order to do that i'm going to rename
that text
form mounted to dome
now anything you do
in the
enhance function here or in your action
keep in mind that this action gets
executed
every time
the html element gets added to the dom
so if we navigate from one page to
another and we come back
that
enhance function is called again let me
demonstrate that so that we can then
see a few things i'm gonna under source
roots i create a new file called about
us dot swelt
and for now this just contains an h1
element
about us
and a link
that brings us back to the home page
like that
and that will
just
move us back
on the index page itself
under the title
i'm adding an anchor that brings us to
about us
so we can navigate between the two pages
uh easily
all right
do that
clear things
we reload the page
and you can see that the form is mounted
to the dom
and
now
oh there we go i had to refresh um hot
modular reloading kicked in
so you can mount it to the dome
and now if we click the about us
we load the about us page and if we go
back
you can see that the form mounted to dom
appears again
this is extremely important to know
because
anything we do
in our action
happens
every time the
html gets added to the dom so navigating
between back and forth we have to
somehow clean up
everything we do
in here for example if we were to add an
event listener
or
create something in memory or whatever
we'll have to clean that up
when the
html form gets removed from the dom so
when we navigate away from the page or
the element gets removed from the dom
for any other reason
to do that
the convention is that we can return an
object from our action
that contains a destroy function
and in that destroy function
we can
print
form
removed
from dom
and now if we have a look
at the
um
the console
when we load the page
you can see the form can got mounted to
the dome
when we navigate away
the phone gets removed from the dome
and when we come back
the form is mounted again
so anything we do
in the action it is very important that
we
undo you know in air quotes um
everything we did so that we have no
memory leaks and
we don't accidentally add multiple like
event listeners and then all of a sudden
our code executes multiple times things
like that
so with that knowledge in mind
let's have a look at what we really want
to do
in order to
make the user experience a bit better
for people with javascript enabled
when somebody
actually before we do that hold on let's
clean this up we don't need the about us
page
and in our index file we no longer need
the link we've proven that this
does what it's supposed to do
so now
when somebody
submits this form
we currently send or we let the browser
send an http post request
to
the endpoint that we specified in the
form here
and then that redirects us back
so what we really want to do is we don't
want the browser to take care of that
if javascript is enabled we want to tell
the browser hey
thank you for your service but we don't
really need your help here we can take
care of
sending
the content of this text field to the
api
process the api's response and then
we'll update ui automatically so we
don't need to reload the entire page
the way we do that is in our action
under source lib actions form
we
have access to the html form
so what we can do
is we're going to drop these console
logs because we know they do what
they're supposed to do
so here we can say form
don't add event listener
and
we can
listen to the forms
submit event
that's when the browser usually kicks in
and does its post request to the api
and
we need to give it a function or a
listener
that will be executed when that event
happens
so let's call this handle submit
and then
let's create
a function here handle submit
and
as i said anything we do in our action
we have to undo it in the destroy
function
so when we move away to another page we
want to say form
remove
event listener
submit and the event listener we want to
remove is our handle submit function
so with that
we have the basic structure in place of
our action
where we
add the event listener when the dome
the element gets added to the dome and
we remove it when the element gets
removed from the dome
so
what do we want to do
when a form gets
submitted the very first thing is we
want to tell the browser
to not do the default behavior
as i said the default behavior is to
send a post request to the endpoint that
is specified in the html
so in this case
send and a post request to that to this
item
endpoint
let's not do that now because this is a
regular event listener
that we added we get a parameter
passed in here which is called an event
and that's just of type event if we want
used typescript here and on that event
we have a
function
that's called preventdefault
that tells the browser hey don't don't
do your default behavior i will i will
take care of it
so let's see what that does to our user
interface
clear out
network clear
all right
we add
a second item
and
we submit i think that did not load
let's try that one more time
clear
add a third item
and submit it now if i hit enter
nothing happens
and that's exactly what we want and
that's also what we said don't do
anything however because we told the
browser not to do its default behavior
it is now up to us
to
make
these this http request to the back end
so let's have a look
whenever we deal with an http request
it's probably a good idea to wrapped up
in a try catch
because things could go wrong the api
could be unavailable there could be
any other
errors that that may occur
so if that happens if we do get an error
for some reason
let's just say
console.error for the time being
fetch error
and
eventually specify what is wrong we'll
do that in a second
okay
how do we make an http request from a
website
well the solution to that is using fetch
and
we have to go to some kind of endpoint
and point here and point
all right
now fetch is asynchronous so we have to
await it and
we will then get a response
since we use our weight we have to make
the handler asynchronous
i will do async
all right
we'll figure out that endpoint in just a
second
but for now
we now have a response
that
if something does go wrong
then
we can
um
do something with it
so
the let's change this here to could not
submit
the form and
the error we get is whatever error we
have
all right
first things first how do we figure out
what's the end point of our form
if we look at the index file
the endpoint we want to use is this
value within the action property
remember that our action we're defining
here
is
generic so that we can use it for any
form
on the application we don't want this to
be very specific
to just one form
and the good thing is that if we look at
the form
elements that we defined under
source lib to do item
and we go down
all these forms
they specify the action attribute that
we want to use for our http request
so the good news here is that we do get
a form passed in as an attribute here
or as a parameter
so let's have a look
what if we look at
what's inside that form
do we have
ah
we have the action property
okay that's exactly what we want
we want to use that action
as the url for our request
so this is a good start
now
if we don't specify any more parameters
for the fetch call
then the default
request method would be get
but
as you know we want this to be post
um like here
so we can
just like we access the action attribute
we can access the method as well
so we can pass in a second argument to
the fetch function
and we call this method and the value is
whatever we specify in the form method
attribute
already
there is
one more thing we need to do
so in the case of creating
a to-do item
or updating an item
we need to send
the
fields the input fields that we specify
within the form
and
in order to do that
we can leverage
a pretty nifty feature
so let's specify
let's say a body
and the way we can do this we can use
new form
data
pass in the form
does this look familiar
forum data
in fact i still have it open as a tab we
looked at that earlier on the mozilla
developer page
and if we switch over to the roots to
do's
the
uid or the index
so index.post here
remember we specified forum data that is
being sent as a body
this is exactly what we're doing here
we create
the body
as a new instance of the forum data and
now in our
request we can
specify a body attribute
and since it's the same as the
variable name we can just leave it like
that instead of you know doing this
short form is just using body
so now we're sending
a request
to the action with the correct method
and the body
but there's one more thing we can do
that is
we
can specify that we accept
uh json response
so let's have a look we can pass in
headers as well
so headers
and what we say here is hey
we accept
application
json
and this will come in handy in just a
second and i'll show you why
for now let's just
you know make this request
we get a response
and then we want to do something with
that response
so let's go here and say that if
the response is okay
then
we want to
console.log
api
response
and for the time being we just say
await
so
what is happening here
we basically just picked the json
response that we get
from the server and we'll just print it
into into the console if something goes
wrong
let's say else
we want console
error
fetch error and
we will just take whatever the response
text attribute is like if something
happened there
then the response will contain some
information of what went wrong
and we can leverage that to
display an error message in the console
for now
okay
so
we did a lot of stuff here
now what we want to go check
is
what happens when we submit that request
let's go back here
and
let's reload the page
clear all that
let's go and create a third item
we submitted
interesting look at that
first of all it didn't do any redirect
which is you know kind of good news
however
it tried to
see this
so our post request 303
is the
response code
and it tried to redirect back to that
index page
so
why is that
well
because we configured it that way
obviously there is a post request
and
if we go to our api
source root studios api
you recall that
we say that if the request method is not
get
then
redirect to the index page
huh that's a problem
we only want to do that
redirect when the browser
submits the form on its own so when
javascript is disabled
if javascript is enabled and we submit
the form
through our action right here
in that case we don't want to do a
redirect and instead we just want to
return
the
[Music]
response and then we parse it here
and we print the value right
all right so let's have a look at how
we can go about that and make sure
we can differentiate whether the browser
submitted the request or
whether we did
now
i already did a little bit of work here
up front i added a new header that says
accept
application json
the browser doesn't do that when it
submits the form the
value for that is is different in that
case but because we are specifying
application json
by ourselves when javascript is enabled
we can leverage that
in our api file and enhance our if
statement
so that we're not only looking for the
request method but we're also checking
the
header that we specified
so here we say and
request
headers
accept that's the one we specified
is not equals to application
slash
json probably a good time to move that
to a new line okay
with that
we now
have
the check so that it shouldn't do a
redirect anymore
when we send the request let's see if
that's the case
because we changed our api file
the server reloaded and it cleared our
items
that's okay
we'll just add them again
so we added first
um that okay and let's clear this a
little bit easier we'll do that again
we'll add
a second
and now look at that we only have one
request
and
if we
move things around here a bit
you can see it's a post request
the status code is 201
and
you can see that the payload was text
second that's what we created
and the response
that we got back from the server
is
a full to-do item including the created
at the uid
the text downfalls
this is
fascinating this is all we really need
and
in fact all we need to do now is
you know update the user interface
to make sure
we show that item in the ui
at the moment if i were to refresh the
page
you can see that our two items are here
that's because the get request fetches
everything from the server
and displays it but we want to do that
dynamically
and the way we can do that is
because we're dealing with javascript we
also can modify that list
and
do so in in a pretty dynamic way
let's look at how we do that
at the moment
when we have a successful result
we just print api response to the url
out to the console
so if we look at that
i disappeared because i reloaded the
page we can do it again if i add a third
item
we can see the api response here
now
let's take that information
and update the user interface
and
the way we do that
is instead of just printing
we have to
update the user interface in the index
file
so let's have a look
in the index file we have that enhanced
action
so somehow
when the request
is made to the server from our action
and we get the response back
at this point right here
we need to
update
the user interface here so the number of
to-do's that we have in this array we
need to push in our new item that the
server sent back to us
with that we can then
let swelt do the rest of the matching
and just re-render that array
and display the new to-do item
but how do we access
that array
that we get in as a
as a prop
there's some good news
and the good news is that
we can pass
additional parameters to our action
the form is given to us by swelt but we
can add our own
parameters as well
and that's exactly what we're going to
do
so
in order to make this more flexible
going forward
let's add an object as an additional
parameter
and
what we will pass in is a function that
we named result
why do we do that
because
this enhance action will be used across
multiple forms
the behavior
of
the success case is going to be
different
when we add an item we want to add it to
a list when we edit it we want to update
an item
and when we delete
a to-do item we want to remove it from
our list in the ui
so because of that
we basically pass in that function again
you could call that whatever you want
but then
instead of printing that
text
what we will do
is
we will call that result function
here
and
we will pass
the response
we could pass the to do object or
whatever
the fact that i'm passing response
allows
us to be more flexible in the user
interface
where we could read values from the
response such as the status or things
like that if we wanted to
you know react to that in certain ways
this is you know up to you how much you
want to pass through here
in our case we'll pass the response and
let the
user interface deal with whatever it
wants to do with that
so that's good
now how do we get access to
um
to that how can we pass that result in
here
very straightforward typescript already
tells us that
it expects two arguments but it got only
one
so we're missing that object with the
result function
so here's how we can do that similar to
how we defined the conditional class
previously we can say use enhance
and then equals
javascript
and then
the
object here
so what's going on
the inner brackets represent
the second parameter here
so that part and
the outer brackets they are there just
like we use them down here to
tell swelt that we're doing some dynamic
work here
all right so now what we need to pass in
here if we do control space
it expects a result property
so let's do a new line
result
and
the result
is a function we are going to specify
in our script where we push an item into
the to-dos array
so
let's have a look we'll just call that
for now
process
new to do result
and then let's go define that function
up here
so const
equals
let's make a function first and then
as you remember
from the
enhance action
we call the result
with an argument called response
so
that means that in our index file
uh oops sorry
process new to do result
we get
a response
as in parameter
we can use typescript
to specify what type that is
and what we want to do here now
is
read
the item that is being sent back to us
just like we printed it to the console
here we can use that a waitress json
grab it make sure you remove that line
because you can only call that json
function once on a response
so remove that
and
in here
we can now say
const
new to do equals
await response json
we have to mark this as an async
function because we're waiting here
waiting
now this is an object that contains
everything we need to know about the new
to do item we saw that in the console
previously with the uid created at all
that information
excellent now all that's left to do
is
update the todus array
to inject
that new object so you would be inclined
to likely do to do is push
new to do
now in swelt that doesn't quite work
because
in order for reactivity to kick in
and swelt to re-render that to doos
array
what we have to do is reassign the array
of that variable which is not a big deal
we can you know change the code here and
say to do's
equals
a new array
with the old to do items plus the new to
do item appended to it
and
with that
we can now go back to the user interface
and
reload that page there was a lot of code
going on
and first second third
let's go clear some things
and add
our fourth item
we hit enter
and you can see
one request to the back end
the fourth item shows up instantly
in the ui
but it didn't clear out our input field
that's a bit annoying
the user experience here is not great
so we can
easily fix that
back here
at the end once we updated the list
it would be great if we could
clear
that form and reset it to its default
values which would be an empty string
for the
input field
so luckily
in our action where we call result
we also have access to the form that we
are using
so we can just pass that in as a prop
as a argument here form
and then in the index file
where we have our function
we now also get
a form
which is of type
html form
element
with that we can now say form
dot
reset
and that will clear the form back to its
default values
let's have a look
first of all let's delete a few things
here
all right
clear that
so we'll add our third item and we hit
enter
it gets added and the form gets
immediately reset
okay
this
is very nice
one request
if javascript is enabled
if we go here to the developer settings
we disable javascript
and
we were to add
a fourth item
and submit that form
you can see that
now the submission happened
by the browser
it used the 303 redirect to come back
but the functionality still works
even if javascript is enabled disabled
we used that before we saw it
but if it's enabled we get that nice
little
performance boost by just sending a
single request and then use javascript
to perform
the addition to the ui
nice
so
we created the functionality to add
a to do item
and we have a
very generic
form action that we call enhanced
now let's go ahead and add that enhance
function to all our other forms as well
so marking an item is done editing
and deleting
the way we do that is we switch to the
to-do item component
and at the top
we import
the
action so we can go to the index file
and grab it from here
now even though
the
index file and the to-do item are in
different
places in the file system thanks to the
dollar lib we
can just copy paste
that import
and now we have our enhance function
here
so the first thing we want to do is
let's start on the right side and do the
delete
action first
so we'll go down
this is our delete form
with the delete to do
functionality
so over here
use
enhance
and pass in
a
result
and then we call this let's say process
the
deleted
to do result
and we go and define that
function
up in this script
so
now we have a challenge
in order to
delete
that to-do item once it's removed on the
server that function will be called by
our action
but
we don't really have access
to
the array of to-do items so that we can
remove it from that array the only thing
we have access to is that item that no
longer exists
so we have to find a way
to
access
the to-do's array
in our index page just like with the
adding a new item
we can
get the existing items and add a new one
we need
access to deleting
an element from this array
the good news is
with swelt
and swell components
we can
just use a prop
the same way that
we pass in the to-do item
we can also expect a prop
to
be a function that we can use to delete
that item
let's see we can export
let
our function
and just like we specified
the to-do item to be a to-do type
the
prop here
is going to be a function that
receives a res
parameter
which is a response
and it will have no return value so void
all right
now all we need to do is back in the
index file
we now get an error
saying that the to do item
expects
the additional
property that we just specified
and
the way we can
do that
is we add it here
just like the to do
we can pass in the new function that
doesn't exist yet but it will in just a
second
where right here next to the one we
create an item we can say const
equals
and
make this just a function
already
and then remember it receives
um
a
response actually let's do this
differently i'll show you another trick
let's delete this
and instead what we're going to do
is we're going to
define the um prop here
but
instead of
um
writing the code above we'll write it
right in line the reason we do that is
because we need access to the existing
to-do
item so that we can read its uid
so this is a regular function
we can just pass that in here
and we say to do's equals
and then we filter them
and we say that
an individual to do if the
uid
is not equals to the to-do uid
then
keep it otherwise drop it
so that will
remove
the current to do
if the id matches to the one that we are
filtering through
let's see what that does to the user
interface
if let's just make sure we have
javascript set correctly
yep javascript is enabled
we clear console
and we delete
the fourth item
yeah okay we have to refresh the page
real quick
let's try that one more time
and we do delete the third item that
sent
a request
if we look at the details
it was a post request
but it had the method delete
in the
query parameter that was our workaround
for the form
and then what it did it removed that
item from the ui
and from the server
all right
so
what's missing now
is editing both
marking it as done and adding the text
this can be achieved
the exact same way as we did for
the delete and the adding a new item
so let's follow that same pattern
in the to-do item itself
we already have a prop that we passed in
here
to delete
the result let's add a new one
process
updated to do result
and then
in our forms
further down
here we go
we
want to add
new
um actions so we use that same
enhance action enhance
and we want to pass in the result being
that
and the same
is going to apply
to the first form where we check it off
as done
so here
we may as well just copy that entire
thing
there we go we can pass
paste here
and with that we now have to specify the
behavior of that function
and
as we know this is passed in as a prop
to our to do item component
so in the index
it will expect that we
define that
function here as well
so
we don't really need
to to do much
other than
just passing that in and making sure
everything is fine
so hold on
probably good time to clean this up a
bit
at the
new properties on new lines
and then we also add the
oops
this new process updated to do
and in this case what we could do is
define that
up in these scripts
doesn't have to be down there inlined
so we can say
const
equals
a function
and as always what we get passed in here
is a response
of type response it will be
async and
what we do inside now is we do cons
similar to how we fetched the new item
we
say give me the updated item
so const
updated to do
await
json
and then the updated to do
we need to go through the
list of to do items
and update the
array with the new item that was updated
the way we do that is to use equals
we map over all of them
and here we just say that
if
the
current item we're iterating over if the
uid
equals to the updated items
updated to do uid then
return our updated item
and
otherwise just return the one we already
had in the array
and don't bother about it
all right now
one thing we um
forgot to do when we built the api
is that you see that when we update an
item
we
expect
the server response to include
a copy of the new item just like we do
when we create an item the server
replies
with the newly created element
we need to update our api to also
include the updated to-do item from that
response
if we go back to
the api
and we look at the patch
case
you notice that we have a status but we
have no body and if we look at
the
[Music]
post
we return
the element that we received
so in the patch case
the
element we want to return is
whichever element that was just updated
as part of this map function here
so we can specify this by saying body
equals and then we just go find that
element
in here
so if the element we're iterating over
its uid maps to the request
params uid
then
please
um you know give us that element and
we'll return it back in the body
send it to the
client
where
we then update the ui so let's have a
look
at what's going on here
let me clear all this
and we add a first item
that went ahead added the item
it downloaded you can see the images
here the inline svgs because it's the
first time we have that edit button
we can now rename that
to first item
that just sends a request
to that endpoint
nothing else and then the ui gets
updated
automatically
and we can mark them as done as well
that's the other feature we built you
see it's another request marking it is
done
and we can get rid of it too
so with that
we developed
a web application that works
with javascript disabled
and if somebody has javascript enabled
we enhance the forms
to leverage that and use ajax requests
instead of full html form submissions
this is a good point
in time to
commit we did a lot of work here
but this is all necessary
to make sure
our application behaves
nicely for everybody
depending on their preferences and
settings of their browsers whether
javascript is enabled or not
let's do a really quick recap
the
first thing is we made
a small change to our api so that a
patch request now returns
the updated element
we also enhanced our function here
saying that we only want to do
to redirect if the browser submitted the
html form
if
the client accepts an http or an
application json
then
we don't want to do that
most importantly we added a new action
called enhance
the action receives
a form that's being that represents the
element where we use the action
and
an object
with a result function so that we can
update the ui when we get a response
back
as an exercise for the viewer
you could go ahead and
enhance that second object to
expect
an error function as well
so that if something goes wrong you
could call the error function
and update the user interface to show to
the user that something went wrong and
they should retry again
um i'll leave that up to
the viewers as an exercise
since uh we want to move on and
you know focus on building
the full that all the backend stuff the
api
that connects to the database
and
persists the item instead of just using
an array in memory
okay so this is a good place
to commit
all these changes and close that pr
that we're about to open
so enhance
html forms
we'll go ahead
and push that
and then create a new pull request
that we want to
slightly rename make this a bit more
readable
and here we say the description close
issue number 11
and with that we can create the pull
request
all right give that a second to do all
this work
now if we look here we have the new pr
and
we are ready to merge
and move on so merge pr
delete the branch
just as a reminder never review your own
code always ask a colleague to do that
um
i don't have a colleague available right
now so
i'll do this myself
and then
our developer environment on gitpod we
can go and throw this away
no need for that anymore
and with that
we
completed that part where we enhanced
the html forms
so that we can now leverage ajax
requests
where
needed it is now time to move on and
look at
the rest of the architecture so let's go
ahead and start working on the database
okay time to move on before we work on
that database
setup for our developer environment
let's quickly recap
where we are in the architecture we've
developed the front end with swelt
we developed an api
using swell kit we had our rest api
in
swell kit exposed
so that we can communicate with the
front end and vice versa
now
it's time to
focus on the
second part of the architecture where we
persisted to do items in the database
instead of
where they currently are which is in
memory on the server
so having a look at the final
architecture
we're going to start with
a postgres database in the developer
environment
so that
we can test the end-to-end flow from the
front end through the api
via prisma over to the database and all
the way back
we want to do all of that in the local
developer environment or in our case on
a git pod workspace
so that we know
all the code is in place before we
deploy the application to production
if you
follow along on your local computer
this is the point where
you have to go over to the postgres
website
and so
postgresql.org
and click the download button
here in the banner or up in the header
there's a download link as well
and depending on which operating system
you use
locally please select the appropriate
installation instructions here
and follow along to set up that database
on your local computer
if you follow along using gitpod
then all we need to do is just make a
one line change
in our gitpod configuration in order to
get access to postgres so that's what i
will be focusing on
in the next couple of minutes
so
we have an issue to install and start
the dev database
we click the gitbot button to start a
developer workspace
for that
particular
issue
and that is pulling the container image
just like it's always done it will also
start
the development server
so we will see the preview of the web
application at this point we don't need
that because we are not focusing on the
front end so we can close the tab
and we are now back
on that development
environment so the developer server here
we can go work on
we don't need to get started and if we
open the gitpod.yaml file
in the root
at the moment we
have not configured
which image we want to use so which
docker container to use as our
environment
that's totally fine and gitpod just uses
a default image that comes with
various languages and frameworks
pre-installed
but now we have a special
interest in getting postgresql installed
so we have two options
one we could specify
a docker container in our source code
and then tell gitpod to use that docker
container so if we have special
libraries or operating system
dependencies we have full control over
what the base image looks like for our
developer environment
however in our case all we care about
is that we have postgres installed and
started
so the way we can do it is
we can use the
image property
and
we specify
git pot slash
workspace
dash postgres
so this is an image that
gitport maintains and provides to
people who use the environment here
if you want to see
what else is available
head over to github.com gitpodio
slash workspace images
and you will see a list of
other
images you can base your environment on
so if you work on flutter
or with a flutter application you can
use that as a default image
the same for
you know postgresql when we use mysql
mongodb and a few others
as in if as i said if you want your own
docker image that's an option too and
the gitpod documentation
explains how you can configure that
in our case all we need
is
the workspace dash postgres
and because we are now starting
a development server for this postgres
database
gitpod will automatically realize that
there is a new port available
on five four three two
which is the default port for postgres
so if we do nothing else other than
adding this line for the image
every time we start a new gitpot
developer environment
we will get a pop-up at the bottom here
saying that a service is listening on
port 5432
we don't really want that because we
don't need to know we know the database
is installed and running so we can add
another port definition to our ports
array where we just say port 5432
and
when we open
the workspace
we want to
ignore that port
that just makes sure that
nothing
gets
displayed at the bottom yet the port
will be
available so we can connect to it with a
database client
that's all the changes
uh there are for this pull request we
literally just added one line here to
base our developer environment on a new
image that contains postgres
and we said that let's ignore port 5432
next step is we commit
these changes and create a pull request
now i already did that
off camera so
for the time being i can just shut this
environment down
and
close it
and then you can see i already have a
pull request
here if we look at that
then you can see that i made the same
changes
gitpod workspace postgres
and port 5432
if we start
an environment based on that new
configuration file
so we click the gitbot button on this
side
and now it's using that new
underlying
docker image that contains the database
so we're going to give that a second to
download all the dependencies and spin
up the environment
and then we can see that
that port is available and also
we now have a cli to connect to
the postgres
in environment that database that we
started up
so let's just
wait until things start up
there's the preview of our app we don't
need that
and
back here
we can close to get started
if we're heading over to the remote
explorer
you can see now we have a new port
available 5432 that is our
database and if we open new terminal
so on the right side
up here we can click the plus
to create a new terminal
and now if we type
p sql
then that connects us to
the postgres database
that is installed on our
computer in our environment here the
gitpod environment
and now everybody
who works on this project
using gitpod they will automatically
have postgres installed
and started up as soon as the workspace
is ready and they don't have to follow
any instructions on how to download
postgres
onto their local laptop this is all
automatically configured for them
this is
a great point
in time to commit we already did we have
a pull request and we validated that we
can
log in to that database
so we're going to
shut this down
and
we know we satisfied that pr
so we installed and started the dev
database
we can now go ahead and merge that pull
request
confirm the merge
drop the branch
and
with that we are now ready to
start the integration with the database
and the api
what an exciting part to be working on
next
we are finally going to find a way to
connect our api
with the postgres database that we
installed in our developer environment
just minutes ago
as part of the architecture
we are going to work on that prisma
part here so the glue if you wish
between the api
and the postgres database
it will help us
interact with the database and the
databases response
depending on
what we do and we can just use
typescript or javascript in this case
where we can call
methods
to add items and fetch items and prisma
will do all the hard work of
converting
between sql queries and
javascript objects
if you've ever worked with
an orm before or have written
your own raw sql queries
prisma will be
an absolute mind-blowing tool
and
seriously increase your developer
experience you will see that as we go
through
the configuration if you combine it with
git pod and automate a lot of the steps
then you'll get the best of both worlds
now before we dive in
we are working with prisma dot io
so having a look at that
um lots of information here fantastic
documentation
that they've put together with all the
details we need to know
i will walk you through everything we
need in order to get this application up
and running
and if you need
more or want to learn more then
prisma.io
is the place to go
okay in github we have an issue
ready for us use prisma orm
so we'll spin up a new git port
developer environment
and once that's ready
we can start by
installing the prisma command line
interface
that's a npm package
that helps us
integrate
with prism and run certain commands
to make things easier for us
so giving gitpod another second here to
spin up the environment
and then we will be off to the races
and
can get started
here's our editor
and in the second we will also see the
terminal
our
preview of the web application
which at the moment we don't need this
is a bit of a distraction so we'll just
close that browser tab
and get rid of the
get started section
we also don't really need the
development server to run so we can
click into the terminal control c to
cancel that
what we do want to do
uh clear
is we want to install that prismacli
and the way we do that is by typing npm
install
minus capital d so that it gets saved as
a depth dependency
and the package name is prisma
if we run that
it gets it all installed
and now we can
access the node module spin directory
where we have a prisma executable
and this is how we access that new
packages cli
that's a lot to type so the alternative
to
that path
is to use npx
and then the name
of the cli that we want to call
before we go any further
i want to show you
what prisma studio is all about
prisma studio is a web application
that connects to our database
and we can then inspect the tables and
the rows and the columns
of our database so we can validate
that
the information we send from the api to
the database gets correctly persisted or
updated depending on the action we
perform
so in order to start the studio
we can say npx prisma studio
and
start that by hitting enter at this time
this will fail
and we will see why
error could not find a schema.prisma
file
so
the schema.prisma file
contains the necessary information for
prisma to understand
everything he needs to know about our
database
such as what's the database provider
what's the url to connect to it
and what does the database look like in
terms of its schema what tables are
available what columns are within these
tables
and what kind of types are these columns
so if we read the error message
carefully
we notice that
at the bottom
it tells us that
the default location of the file is
a prisma directory
schema.prisma
so if we take that
path
we copy it and in our root
in the editor we create a new file
for
prisma schema.prisma
that generates the file that we need and
now we can go ahead and start
editing it you saw i tried an
autocomplete
that didn't work the reason for that is
that we don't have a vs code extension
installed
that understands this file
so we can head over to
vs code extensions
and search for
prisma
there's an insider and a stable version
i prefer the stable version so we click
on it
and over here you remember that from the
swelt
um extension that we installed earlier
under manage
if you say add to git podiaml
that will ensure
that everybody who opens this project
on a gitpod workspace
will have the prisma
extension installed by default
just to show you
it ended up
over here
under vs code extensions within the
gitpod.yaml file
currently we don't have it installed i
just added it to the file so we can
either start a new workspace with that
new configuration file or the easier way
is to hit the quick fix link and say
install prism extension
that doesn't take very long
and once it's installed
then the line will disappear
and now if we go back to our schema file
and we use autocomplete control space
we now have access to
the
properties that we need to define
one more thing i'd like to do
for
future us and our colleagues in a file
like this where
it may not be obvious where we can find
more information about it
i like to just add a comment learn more
about this file
in the docs
and the url for that is https
and
chris lee slash d
slash
prisma
schema
quickly double check that there's no
spelling mistakes
that looks good all the information you
need in here as i said the prisma team
did a fantastic job documenting
everything
so we'll drop that
and
what we can do now is
define
our data source
data source db
and then the values inside let's use
autocomplete
it asks for a provider
and the provider we want
is in our case postgres
so we have other options here as well we
already know we installed a postgres
database
so we'll choose postgres
and
still something missing which is the url
the url
is
depending on your environment so
generally speaking the format
of
a pre of a postgres url
is postgres
colon slash
and then the username that you created
in your database in our case because we
use the
gitpod docker image as our foundation
for the developer environment
i know the username is gitpod
and then add the hostname so localhost
in our case
slash the name of the database we want
to create
so this in theory works just fine in our
local development environment or here on
git pod
but when we deploy the production
this is no longer going to work because
that path is going to be something
completely different
that we need to set dynamically so
luckily
the
prisma schema file allows us to use
something called env
so this is a way for us to use an
environment variable instead of a
hard-coded string
and what we want to do here is um
database
url
so with
that we now have to set
the database url
in our development environment
one way to do that is
as you also see in the docs here we
could create a dot env file
at the root
and configure the environment variable
there
another way since we're using gitpod
is we can go to
the gitpodiama file
and in our
tasks we currently have one terminal
indicated by the one dash here
so here we can just add env
and then say database
url
and the value of that
is that postgres localhost
url that we defined before
so now we know that when we start a new
workspace
the terminal with the server will have
that database url available so that's
pretty neat
that's all we need for the time being
let's go back to
the prisma schema so the schema prisma
file
we have to configure a few more things
here
the next thing
is we need a generator as i mentioned
briefly
when i introduced prisma
based on
our database schema
prisma will generate a javascript slash
typescript client that we can
load into our api and then interact with
the database
so what we do here
we specify a few parameters for that so
we do generator client
and
a bunch of things it's asking for
we'll start with the provider
and
the value is there's only one
prismacline.js
the other thing we want to do
is
specify
the binary targets
and that is important because as you see
in the description
it specifies the operating system on
which the prism client will run to
ensure binary compatibility of the query
engine
a lot of text what it really means is
right now
the git developer environment uses a
ubuntu
operating system
if you follow along on your local
computer may you may use windows or you
may use mac os
as your environment
what we're doing here
is we're just
indicating that
the binary targets we want the client to
generate
is
whatever
i'll show you
whatever the
native environment is that's also
documented but
native means
in this case it will generate it for
ubuntu when we deploy to burcell
it will generate it for whatever
operating system where cell uses to run
our api
so that gives us the peace of mind we
don't have to worry about anymore
lastly and arguably most importantly
we have to define
a database schema
and what that means is if we look at the
api just real quick
source
roots to do's underscore api
remember that to use array
that we specified
and at the moment this is just an array
a variable living in memory
that needs to move to the database
so in the database we need a table
that can hold all the to-do items that
we add to our web application so we are
lucky
in
in so far that we have
already a to do typescript definition
so let's head over there
and look at what we defined
that definition is under
src
global.d.t.s
and you can see we have a uid
a created ad text a done
so let's copy
so that we make sure we don't forget any
of the properties
and we move back to the schema
and then what we define here is called a
model
and the name of the model
you can roughly think of that as the
table name as well
so that would be to do
and
within that we can specify the
properties
so for now let's just paste
our typescript definitions
and now we just have to update the
syntax to match the syntax used within
our schema prisma file
that's pretty straightforward so
we use um we can do it all in one go
we remove
the
columns
replace that with a string or a space
and then
the next thing is that string is a
capital s
so is it here so it's boolean
and date is actually more specific a
date
time
and we also need to drop all the
semicolons
and with that
we
are almost ready to go it's still
complaining
um
about an error
and it's saying that each model must
have at least one unique criteria that
has only required fields
blah blah either marker field with id
now
what that means is remember in the api
source roots to do's
index.json
remember we created that uid
and we used the date.now which as i
mentioned earlier never ever do that in
a production environment
and
we even left the note saying that
replace that with the uid from the
database
um nice spelling mistake okay so
at this point
we have access to the database we are
literally defining the schema right now
so we can now drop this line
we no longer need
to
create it
and
what we do instead
is we remove that and in our schema we
can tell the database to use that uid
field as the
unique id
and in prisma we can use the add id
for that and also we want to give it a
default value
and the default value we can use a
function to create that
global unique identifier based on the
cuid spec
so we'll use that
and with it
every time we create a to-do
record in the database
the database will automatically
add a default value to our uid and we
will provide the created ad text and
done
okay
that was a bit of configuration here
now the error we received in the console
before was that this file didn't exist
so we couldn't start
the server
now
there's one more thing we need to do
remember in the git body ammo we
specified the database url
as postgres localhost blah blah
if we were to commit these changes and
start a new gitpod workspace
that would be available but at the
moment if we do echo
database
url
we
actually we have it because i think i
already ran it but
that
we have to make sure this environment
variable is set so we do have it and now
let's try
to clear this and run npx prisma studio
give that a second
it is saying that a service is available
in port
5555.
we can close that preview here but if we
open a browser
it opens up
the prisma studio
and you can see that it shows us all the
models we defined so in this case the
to-do
model that's the only one we defined
in our
schema
down here
so if we click on that
it gives an error
unable to run script
let's have a look invalidate blah blah
and then here the table
public to do does not exist in the
current database
that is true
because we never actually created that
table
the only thing we did was we defined
the model
but we never told prisma
to create
that table in the database
we could go to the database and manually
run
a sql query that you know create table
with these fields but the whole point of
using prisma is that we can automate all
that
so let's stop our studio
we ctrl c
and i will show you how
we can ensure that the database
is always up to date
so the command
we can use to make this work
is
again we use npx
prisma migrate
def
let's see what happens
basically
migrate
is going to look at the prisma file
it's going to see that there is a to do
record
and
when it sees that
record it will then go to the database
and check whether the database matches
what's configured in our schema and
let's see what happens at the moment
just fyi the database is empty so
there's going to be a discrepancy
between
what we expect the database to look like
with the to-do
table
and the empty
environment in the database
let's run that command
all right
so let's walk through that together
prisma schema loaded from this file
excellent
data source db is postgres
very good
scheme is public and localhost 5432.
that's looks all good
and now it's noticing that
the database doesn't match the schema so
it is asking us
to provide a name for the migration
so at this point
we really just initialized the database
so let's call it init
we say init and hit enter
all right
let's give this a second and then
we're going to go back and
review everything that was going on here
it's a lot
we specified in it as the name of the
migration
and then it says the following
migrations have been created and applied
from the new schema changes
something in the migrations directory
blah blah blah
and then your database is now in sync
with your schema
let's look at that file look at this
there's a sql file
prisma migrations
there's a directory here
and a sql file
if we look at that file
oh my
look at this
it generated
the sql
that is necessary to run against the
database
in order to create
that table
with the necessary columns
such as the text
the boolean the done the uid
it also created some constraints
on the
primary key
being the uid field
that's incredible
all done
for us and all we had to do was just
specify what it what we wanted to look
like
good let's go back to the terminal and
see what else went on here
and then it says that your database is
now in sync with your schema
so not only did prisma generate
the sql file
it also ran it against the database
very cool we had literally nothing to do
here it just did it all for us
and then it ran generate
and it did a bunch of npm stuff here
blah blah blah blah all good
and at the end it says generated
prismaclient
to node modules at prisma slash client
that is something we're going to look at
afterwards
for now just note that in this directory
we now have
a client that we can use in javascript
that is fully aware
of the schema of our database it knows
about this to do item there are
functions available to us that we can
leverage
to find update and delete
records we'll get to that in a second
for now
i want to
go back and clear the terminal
and then go back up and run that
christmas studio again
take a second i'll close that preview
and we can ignore that because we
already have
the tab open
and if we go back to the
reload that page
let's have a look
we are now looking at the to-do table
and you can see there's a uid
created at text we could add a record
from here
uh
and and go ahead you know change the
date add a text
change the value of the done
and commit that we'll do that later but
for now just know that prisma studio
gives you a way to access your database
through a web browser so we'll discard
the changes
one more thing
i want to do anybody who works on this
application
sooner or later is likely going to need
access to that prisma studio
but
they may not know
the command npx prisma studio
and we want to make this so easy for
them that they don't even have to run
the command
again we can automate it
let's imagine
we started a git board workspace
and
in one terminal
we run npm install
and fire up
the
web application
in another terminal
we automatically start prisma studio
and then we open the preview
in a new browser tab of prisma studio
let's see how we can do that just like
we configured the init task here
we can
create another one
and we don't have any in it for that
we only have a command
and the command is simply npx prisma
studio
and we also need to specify the
environment variable so that prisma
studio knows how to connect to our
database using the database url
environment variable
and with that
it will automatically open two terminals
at startup
of the workspace
and
lastly
it will start a new service on port 5555
so let's configure that port
down here
by saying
four times five five five five five
and on open
we want to open
a
browser
window automatically so we will have two
browser windows open one
for the application
and the other one
for the prisma studio
so there's a lot going on
in
in this file
generally in this pr we made we made a
bunch of changes
i think at this point
we can go ahead and
review and then almost ready to commit
and start working on the integration
with the api
i think
the
let me just have a quick look
yeah so there's one more thing we need
to do before we move on
remember how we manually
created the
migration we run prisma migrate dev
we can automate a little bit more
let's assume
somebody
starts
this developer environment
and
at the very first time
their database is always going to be
empty because every environment is going
to be
built from scratch
so in order to make sure
the database is always in sync
with our schema that we specify here
we want to make sure that that prisma
migrate dev command
automatically runs before we start our
swelt kit application
so that's an easy fix
all we need to do is open the
package.json file
we already have a dev script
now in order to run something
before the dev script
we can either come here and say
prisma migrate def and and swell kit def
however if we want to run more commands
before we start the dev server this
starts to get really hard to understand
so here's a little trick that npm
provides we can
take that
and then
take the name of our command
and create a new command
or a new script called
pre and the name of this one here let me
show you in this case we are talking
about
we want the dev script
we want to run something before the dev
script runs so we can say pre-def
which means it runs
before the dev script
and we want to run prisma migrate dev
this
is nothing you know no magic that's just
a regular npm
npm feature
and with that now every time we start
our dev server if we came here and run
npm run dev
and we hit end enter
you can see that prisma migrate that
runs first
and then it starts the development
server
and our application is up and running
so
let's have a really quick look
at
the output prisma migrate f
same output as before it loaded the
schema file connected to the database
but now it says already in sync
no schema change or pending migration
was found
that's because
of the migration we ran before
the
schema our model here
is already available in the database
that's why it doesn't run anything
the next time we start a workspace on
gitpod
this will not be the case the database
will be empty
and prisma will automatically run our
migrations in order based on the date
that's in the
folder name here
so
with that we have a lot of code that is
ready to get committed and that's
exactly what we're going to do next
time to
head over to the source control
and
do a quick recap
of what happened make sure we don't
have any um
any bugs
so we added a new terminal that runs npx
prism studio
we have the new environment variables
and we also open a browser for prisma
studio
we added the
vs code extension so everybody gets the
same experience when they edit the
schema.prisma file
we added a predef script so that our
web application always has the database
up and running and the latest changes
are applied before we start the dev
server so pre def
we added the prismaclient
or the prismacli as a def dependency
and
you can see it also automatically added
a prismaclient dependency that was added
automatically when we the migrate
command the first time
so that
we can then use at prismaslash client
in our code to access the generated
client
to connect to the database we'll see
that in a couple of minutes
the probably most important file
that we worked on
as part of this section
is the
schema.prisma file
we specified that we work with a
postgres database
the url is from an environment variable
and
the provider
for the javascript client is
prismacline.js
and at the bottom we have the to-do
model
and
this is where we now generate the uid
automatically with a um
cuid specification so it'll be a random
generated id that we'll see in just a
second
lastly
we made a small tweak to the api
and the tweak was that we removed our
very bad workaround here
to create a uid because now the database
will do that for us and we no longer
have to do that manually
so with that
let's go ahead and commit these changes
so add prisma
and
init migration
we can commit this and create a pull
request
here
let's call this
use
prisma
or m
and we will close issue number
uh 15. now
we only just configured the prismaclient
the cli so far and set up the migrations
we have a little bit more work to do
to update the api and leverage all the
configuration we put in place so we'll
make this a draft
and we go ahead and create the branch
and the pull request
up on github
that only takes um
a couple seconds
and then once it's ready
we can go ahead and close the prisma
studio here
and let's go have a look
see if that worked
it doesn't seem to have pushed that um
let's see oh it's pending okay let's see
what's going on
i think we can have a look
review no matching
okay maybe what we can do
let's just give it a second
maybe there might be some hiccup yeah it
seems to be
loading
maybe that was it
not yet
let's cancel that here in the console
and have a look
what's going on
what if we push
manually
maybe we'll get around it could be some
um github issues we had something going
on yesterday as well
all right that created the branch
and we should be able to
create that pull request manually that's
no problem at all
um call this use prisma orm
we don't need any of that just close
issue number
15 i believe it was
and then create a pull request
there is many ways that lead us to roam
so all good we want to
convert it to a draft
and
um keep working on it
before we uh mark it as ready for review
good with that we can go ahead and shut
this
workspace down
close the tab
and from here
we'll now move on and start to use that
prismaclient that got generated for us
and use it in the api
so that we can then persist and read and
update items in the database
with the prisma
configured
in the environment and the studio
automatically starting up
it is now time to update our api
in order to leverage
all the work we just did
so firing up a new workspace
to get us going
and then
we will also see
for the first time how
the updates we've made to the git body
ammo file
will impact a startup of a new workspace
so
it will start two new browser tabs
one for the application preview just
like we've always had
and then a second one that is going to
show
the
prisma studio
web application
where we have access to the database to
look at
tables and the content of the table so
we can validate
that the api properly persists the
changes that
we made in the
front end
so this is a fairly
straightforward part of the course all
we will do is
update the api file
and replace that
to do's array that we've had so far
with
functions to interact with the database
just giving gitpod
here another
couple of seconds to
pull down our base docker image
and then
we should be off to the races
that sometimes takes a couple seconds
more than on average but
ultimately it is still
super convenient to have
all that just automated so anybody who
works on our project
gets the benefits
of the work we did throughout this
course
without fully understanding what needs
to be installed and
what needs to be done
all right
we got our two browser tabs
one is the application one is prisma
studio
with the to do model
that's currently empty nothing in here
and
we get also this preview that we can
safely ignore
good
ah let's get going
so
down here in the
terminal you notice that on the right
side
there are now two terminals
the second one that's currently
highlighted is the prisma studio
and the first one
is the one that runs our web application
on port 3000
so you can navigate between the two if
you want to start or stop any of the
services
okay
so the main file we're going to work
with today is source roots
to do's underscore api
now
we moved
all that code into this file a while ago
and now
we're going to actually see
some benefits of that because
any interactions we've had with that to
use array
is now consolidated into that one file
so now that we're going to replace that
with the database table we created
we can just update the code below here
to leverage
calls to the database
so
when we ran
the migrate dev command from prisma so
in the package.json
our pre-dev script
prisma migrate dev
that generated our
prismaclient if you recall
in the terminal
if we scroll up just a bit
it generated the it used the migration
and applied it to the database because
we started a new workspace the database
was empty and it also generated that
prismaclient
into node modules
at prismaclient
okay
now
that client we will see that in a second
is fully aware of our database model and
we can
import that because it's in the node
modules directory we can import it like
we would any other package
so at the
root of our file here at the very top we
can add a new line
saying import
prisma
from
at prismaclient
and we can then use that
instead of
you know to do start push for example
we can use that new
prisma
import now
there is one gotcha and
that is related to
a temporary
workaround we need to implement until
everybody moves to
es modules so
that line import prisma from
prismaclient
works well in our environment but once
we deploy to
um versailles we'll need to import this
slightly different
long story there's um some information
online but we basically want to extract
that
for the time being into a separate file
and
allow us to deal with that
workaround
so just bear with me as we go to source
lib
and we create a new file here called
prisma
dot ts
and within that we basically implement
the loading mechanism of both approaches
one that works on our developer
environment and one that works on
varcell
and then
we will use that in our codes in the api
file so that we don't have to
deal with any if else statements and
whatnot over there so the way we do that
is we import
prisma
but also
we import star as
prisma all
from
the prismaclient
so as i mentioned
depending on whether we run on our
environment here or on versailles
this one or this one will be undefined
one of the two and it's the opposite way
depending on the environment we're on so
all we need to do now is we say
the actual prismaclient
is
either prisma if it's available so
typescript we can use
question mark
so prismaclient
or
alternatively
prisma all again if it's available
dot prismaclient
and then we say export
default
the prisma client
and now with that
we don't have to worry anywhere else in
the code whether
this approach
loaded correct client or
this approach did with the star as
prismacline all because in this line
here we basically just pick either this
or the other one and export to
prismaclient
with that
in our api
we can now simply say
import
the prisma client
from remember the shortcut with dollar
lip
slash prisma
and now we can use that prismaclient
just like we would if we imported it
regularly according to the prisma docs
a small little workaround
that we need to make this work on
the local environment or in gitpod here
as well as on versailles
now the probably most exciting part of
this entire course
is that we can finally get rid of this
to-dos array
and no longer keep the to-do items in
memory
and lose them every time we restart the
server
so
let's celebrate
by dropping this hooray this is gone
we'll never have to worry about it again
instead what we're going to do is we
create
a new instance of that prismaclient
let's call it prisma equals new
prisma client
and now you will see the power of prisma
in just a second if we take this
and
we start to go through
all the places where we access currently
that array and we replace it with a call
to the database
let's check this out so here
we want to
fetch all the to do items that are
persisted in the database
so let's look at this we use prisma
and now the autocomplete
shows us a to do property
with that
to do
we can then say find many
and you can see there's code examples
right in the docs
so that
um get all to do's
is constitutes equals await prisma to do
find many so we'll do find many
we call that
and this is
uh returns in our
promise so we'll say await
and we make this an async function
unbelievably cool
uh you can tell i'm really excited about
this this is such a game changer to
how we've developed
with or interacted with database from
javascript in the last 20 years
prisma really sets the bar high with
that approach that's literally all we
need to do
and as you saw we had full typescript
support
for
our to-do item
if we were to go into the prisma schema
and start to add more models or update
the model
every time we start a dev server the new
client will be generated and we would
have access to these new fields and
functions and everything immediately
through typescript autocomplete here
okay
the next thing is we want to
create a new to do item
so far we just said to do push
now this is no longer
the way to do it
the new way to do it is
that we say
await
prisma
to do
and
guess what
create
so cool
and within that
we
have
autocomplete which asks us to provide
a data property
we will happily do that
and as part of that data property
you can now see that it's asking for
created that done text and an optional
uid
again fully auto generated because of
our model
and
we know
what these values are so let's go ahead
top to bottom create it at
is the data dot created
oops created
what did we call it created at
and we know this is a date so we'll tell
typescript that
and then we have done which comes from
data dot
done
that's a boolean
all right
and we have the text
which is data
dot text as string
and with that
we now have
a new item created in the database
so
that push is no longer needed
now here's one thing we have to change
and the reason we need to change here
is
so far
our
post endpoint
added the uid right here
this is no longer the case but when we
add an item to the database
the response to the
front-end has to include the uid or
basically it has to include the
to-do item
with the same data that we have in the
database
so
we could you know use prisma to go fetch
the newly created items somehow but the
better way is that
the create function
actually returns
the created item for us
so we can just say body
equals
and drop this part here
now we create the item
in the database and when that's complete
the response we get back from the
database is the newly created item that
contains the uid
moving on let's see how we can delete an
item
this doesn't exist but
we can say
um
to pray await
prisma dot to do
dot
let's see do we have a delete we have a
delete right here
and what do we want to do
in the docs it says that
it wants a where clause
where we can specify
which element we want to delete
all right let's have a look
we'll pass in an object
with a where clause
and it's suggesting that we provide a
uid
let's do that
we know that
the uid we want to delete is the one we
get from the request params
dot uid
and that will take care of
removing that
element
we can apply whatever response we get
back to the
body if we wanted to
that's all good
lastly
let's look at how we can patch
an object in the database
so none of that is needed anymore
as well as
the body
we will do that in one
line
body equals
a weight prisma to do
and then guess what there's an update
function
and the
update function
wants an object let's have a look data
and where
okay we're already familiar with the
where so we can just use that
we know it's one they want a uid
which we have
and also
he wants
a data property which
you know presumably is going to be the
data we want to update for the given
to-do item we selected up here
so data
we have data text and to-do done
so let's say
done
and the value for that is data.done
and
the other thing
is
the text
and that is data dot
text
that we want to put there
okay
now
we don't need that code
from before
we don't need that
that looks good
and what we can do now
is
go have a look
at what this looks like in the
user interface
so first of all let's go all the way to
the bottom here
this looks good seems to compile
if we switch over to the application
let's
inspect the
network tab
so here
we'll add a first item
that seemed to have worked something
happened at least we showed in the ui
let's look at
the
[Music]
requests
to do json all right we sent the text
and in return
we got an item there's our new uid
generated by the database
definitely a lot more
unique than our timestamp that we had
before
again a reminder do not use data now as
a uid
um
never ever
so
very cool let's look at prism studio
to double check if that item actually
got persisted so heading over to the
prisma studio tab
and there's a little refresh icon
of voila
we have
our very first to-do item
persisted in the database
which means that
we could now stop our server
let's do that
stop our front-end server
and start it back up
let all these scripts run
and do what they need to do
all right
there's a new preview
and guess what it shows our item still
here because we fetched it from the
database
let's have a look at the done column
it's currently false
just to make sure updating works as well
we check it we come back and refresh and
this now says true
and lastly for good measure
first item
persist
in the prisma studio
first item is now persisted
what a wonderful time
to
be a full stack web developer so many
tools that make life so easy
and we now have typescript support
basically from the database all the way
to the front end
and if we were ever to change anything
typescript would yell at us right away
telling us to update our code
and match
the new code we want to implement
okay
let's close the prism studio close our
preview
and
commit
the changes that we made
we finally were able to drop that to-dos
array
that we now replace with database calls
and
you can see we have
the prisma
instance
of the prismaclient and that now
autocompletes our to-do's and the
functions we can call on that to-do
object
with that let's go ahead
and commit that
we're now using the prisma
client
all right
let's commit
yes
and then since we already have
a pull request open
we can just sync our changes
and let
um
gitpod sent that up to github
and here we go
we now got that code in here
and that
marks the end of
that pull request so ready for review
ask our colleagues to have a look
they can go through
see all the changes we've made
to defile
the different files
as part of this pull request our
migration auto generated
and
our binder file here with the schema
where we defined what the table looks
like
and then the update to the api
where we replaced the in-memory array of
to-do items with calls to the database
to
per
assist and update
all that
wonderful
and
with that we can go ahead and merge that
pull request
and then move on
and start to look at some
more things in order to deploy this
application to production
merge it
and delete the branch
good that's all cleaned up
that environment is no longer needed
we'll stop it
get rid of it and that marks
the end of this issue that we worked on
what an exciting time
we now
have
our full stack application
that is running
perfectly fine in a local developer
environment or in a gitpod developer
environment
we have a front-end in api and the
database everything is connected
everything communicates and
what's missing
in this course
and to wrap it up
is in
order to
use that application we need to deploy
it to production
so for that
we have two tasks ahead of us
the first one is to deploy
a postgres database to railway
and the second task is to deploy the
api
and web app to versailles
we will start with the database
so that when we deploy the api it will
be able to connect to the database right
away all right first things
first we head over to issues
we have two issues left one is the
deploy database on railway
that's the one we want to work on
so we fire up a new gitpod developer
environment
and
once that is ready
we will be able to make a couple of
changes
just so that
when we deploy the application to
versailles
everything
works and is in place the way we expect
it to be
so here's our developer environment
spinning up
and
it fires up prisma studio which we don't
need right now
and our web application preview
we don't need that either
so all we really need here
is the package.json file
where we're going to make a couple of
changes
so
we can cancel that prisma studio we can
control c
and switch to the other terminal here
this is where our
application runs we'll cancel that as
well for now
and
what we now need to do
is
in the package.json file
you remember
in development
before we start the dev server
we created a pre
dev script
where we run the prisma migrate
dev command
this helps sure helps ensure that the
postgres database is always
up to date with the latest migrations
that exist under prisma migrations
now
this
as the command says is for development
but when we deploy to production
there might be changes to the database
schema that we have to apply to the
production database as well
and in that case
we don't want to run
prisma migrate def
we want to run
a production
level command for that
now
when do we want to run that command when
we deploy to vercell
the
versailles adapter
for swell kit will automatically execute
the build
script
so
or in other words versailles will
actually execute the build script and
the swelt kit
command line
interface here that will then execute
the versail adapter and deploy the
application we'll talk about that when
we deploy the web application but
the build script
is something where
we
want to
run that
command
to
upgrade update the database and migrate
if there are any migrations
the problem is
we could run that build script in our
local environment as well
so
this would be confusing we wouldn't want
to update the database by running the
build script locally
so luckily there is a script
that we can leverage so if we add a new
script to our package.json file and we
call it
versel build
this script
is only executed
when we deployed to versailles and at
that time
this is the perfect place to
upgrade our database
the way we do it
is we use prisma
prisma migrate
just like we did in the predef script
but instead of def
we use
deploy
and then once that's done and the
database is
updated
we can say
and and npm run build
so that versailles then kicks in
first deploys the database
and then runs the build script for the
web application
so
let's quickly run that build script so
the one we're going to execute here
npm run build let's run that
in our environment
to see what actually happens
when we deploy dubair cell
so npm run build
and it is now telling us that
it could not detect a supported
production environment and that's
because we are not
actually running on versailles so
because in our swelt config
we use that adapter auto
it tries to determine where we are
executing this command from
and because it doesn't see
this environment as being their cell
it um
automatically basically gives us that
error
now i spend a lot of time in these
wealth kids source code so i know that
if we temporarily export a variable
called vercell
and we give that let's say a value of
true
and then we run that npm round build
script again
it goes through the same steps
and
now it determined that we are on
versailles
so we basically just
you know cheated a little bit but
this is only temporary because i want to
show you
what happens on versailles
so the first thing we notice is that it
created a new directory
called dot versus build output
and
within that
directory
we have a functions
subdirectory
and then node and then render
so that index file
here within the render directory
this
is our generated
code
it's very very long
but that's basically our generated code
for the application
that we developed our server side
application
now
when we deploy
to
production
in that directory here
we need to include
our
schema
dot
prisma file that needs to be available
so that when we run prisma migrate
deploy
prisma can find this schema
and in the schema as you remember it has
the information on how to
connect to the database what database it
is
and all the schema information
so because of that
we
want to run
a script after
we build
that directory
so we can say here in the package.json
file
um post build
so just like we had
pre dev
that runs before the dev script we have
a build script and if we say post build
that script runs after the build
completes
so what we want to do here is copy our
prisma
slash
schema.prisma file
and
we want to copy it
into that render directory that we have
here so let's right click and
see copy relative path
and then
in our copy command
we'll paste that so that we
go from
dot versus build output into here
functions node render add a slash at the
end
so that copies the prisma file and
there's one more thing we need to copy
that
are these binary targets so
they get generated
by default
into the node modules directory
and
within the node modules under
the
um
prisma
we have a directory here called engines
and within the engines
you can see the lip query engine debian
open ssl something something something
that
file
or a similar name depending on what
environment where cell runs
needs to be copied into that same
functions directory
so the way we can do that is
just like we copied that prisma file
we can add
another copy command
and this time
let's go back node modules prisma
engines
we want to copy that relative path
so from that directory
under at prisma engines we want to copy
everything that contains query
and the place we want to copy it to is
the same one here
under the versailles build output
functions node render
and we'll drop that at the end here
so that makes sure
it copies that
query these query files if there's more
than one
it would take all of them
put them in the right place
and
the other thing we can do
just in case we were to run that build
script again
let's ignore
the versailles build output
because
we don't really want to commit that that
would be
a bit of a mistake so in our
git ignore file
we can say that
we
do not want
that virtual build output
committed to um git
so that's good
all right
a few things happened here we basically
just prepared
the
application so that on versailles
it makes sure that it runs prisma
migrate
and then um npm run build and after the
build in the post build script we copy
the schema
to the function
on versailles and we also copy the query
files
to the same directory
okay
let's
go and commit these changes
so
configure
configure
um versailles
build and
post build scripts
all right i will commit that
yes
and we can open a pull request
so
let's call this deploy database
on
railway
and this will close issue number
18.
all right
we'll say create yes please publish
let's give that a second to do its job
and
we now have
a pull request
that
contains these later latest changes
so
as part of the deploy database
on railway
we also actually have to go create
that database on railway
so the way we can do that is we go to
railway.app
and
even if you're not logged in
we can just say start a new project
and provision postgres database
that runs
for a few seconds
and
now we have
a
postgres database running
you can see that this is a temporary
project
and will be deleted in seven days
that is because i am an anonymous user i
will eventually claim that so that the
database stays online and you know you
see all this working in action
for now
this is all we need
one important aspect is if you click on
the post aggress
link on the left here
we can then eventually see some data
but for the time being
if you click on connect
you can see our postgres connection url
listed right here
this is something that we're going to
need when we deploy to versailles so
let's just keep this browser tab open
and we will come to that
and copy it in in a second
for now though
we've done the work that is necessary to
deploy
to versailles and we have a few scripts
here that are needed
to make sure the database in production
is up to date with the latest schema
and we can deploy
so we are good to go
and can merge this pull request
into the main branch
drop the branch
and go ahead and
shut down our workspace
already
and we can now go back to issues
where we have one left that's deploying
the application
to versailles
and then configure it so that it can
connect to the database we just deployed
let's go and do that now
last step of this course
we have to go ahead and deploy the web
app
and the api
onto versailles and if we
compare to
the architecture this is
the piece right here
where we have to go and deploy that
and then make sure it can properly
connect
from prisma to the database
we just deployed a little while ago
okay
here is
the best news
that you can possibly
imagine
when it comes to deploying
a
swelt kit application
to
at the time of this recording
versailles netlify or cloudflare
you don't have to do any code changes
the reason for that
is that in the
swelt config file
we have an adapter that is being
imported
that's called adapter auto and
that is used here as you recall from the
very beginning adapters are
used by swell kit to prepare
the application
for the different environments
so if you deploy to netlify
cloudflare or cell at this point in time
then you don't have to make any code
changes
if you're curious what the latest
supported environments are
head over to
kit.swelt.dev
docs
scroll down
in the navigation
until you get to adapters where it says
supported environments
and you have a list here of supported
environments so the three are here we
are deploying the versailles so we are
in luck
and we don't have to actually make any
code changes
the only thing we have to do is
log into vircell
so make sure you create an account
pick the right team
and then you can say new project
and
from the
screen
you select the
um
organization or the account
and then the project you want to deploy
in my case that's the full stack web
development project
so i can import it
you can see that it automatically
recognizes this as a swelt kit project
so it analyzed my code
in github and it saw that this is as
well kit app
no need for me to make any changes
however
if we look at the environment variables
there is one thing that we want to
configure
which is our database url
that we configured locally or on gitpod
as the as part of the developer
environment
in production
we also have to specify
a database database
url
so that prisma knows how to connect to
the database
the value
that we want to add here
comes from
the railway.app
remember we created
a
postgres database here and it has a
postgres connection url
so we want to copy that
and
over inversel
add this as the database url
we say add
and with that that environment variable
is available
for prisma to pick up
and we then can say deploy
and you can see down here it starts to
build so four seconds ago
it's running all the necessary scripts
in order to
build this well kit application
it will also run the post build script
that we specified
so that
the database will be
populated with the table that is needed
as well as
all the
other things that are necessary
to make this work
lots going on
we can see here that one migration found
in the migrations
so it applies that
this is happening because we specified
that
versailles build script which runs
prisma migrate deploy
so this is why it said hey i'm running
this migration
and apply to the database
it does a bunch of other stuff there's
two warnings we can safely ignore that's
okay
and eventually
we
are uploading the build cache
to
the server and
i have seen this page getting stuck
at certain times and it looks like this
is one of those days so
this has been running for a minute
which is
a bit longer than it usually takes which
is fine what we can do
is instead of waiting here
for that to
never finish
we can just go back to the top and click
the back button here
that brings us to that
page where we can import a project so if
we just click at the top
on our
team
we can now see that we have that project
configured here
and if we open it up
we get a nice little preview
of our to do application and over here
we have the url
available to us so if we click on that
you can see that full stack web
development versailles
is our production environment
and if we come in here and we add an
item
saying first
we can enter this
hit enter
and see what happens
in the database
let's do that one more time
there we go
and now we have
the first item added to the database if
we head over to railway
and we select the data tab in our
postgres database
we can see that prisma created a
migrations table
that's okay prisma will manage that
nothing for us to worry about
more importantly we can see the to-do
table
that now contains our
first
to-do item
if we were to go back to production
mark this as done
and then head over here you see that
this done column changed to true
and we could go ahead and add
a second item
and even a third item
this works just like it did locally
and we could even go ahead and remove
certain items
that would then reflect
what we see in the database
first and third
true and false true false first and
third
what an exciting time
truly
how we deploy web applications
as a full stack developer has
dramatically improved over the last
couple of years
thanks to
amazing companies such as versailles
and railway
development
of these applications as well is
dramatically changing thanks to
developer environments in the cloud by
using gitpod.io
with that we can head back to our issue
and
one thing we want to do here
is take that url
and leave a note
saying that
application
deployed
to
this url
we leave that comment
and we can go ahead
and close
that issue
this completes the coding part of this
course
amazing work congratulations on making
it all the way through
you now have a full stack
web application
available here built with swelt swell
kit
using prisma to connect to a postgres
database and all of that is deployed to
versailles and railway
excellent congratulations you have
developed a full stack web application
deployed it to versailles deployed a
database to railway.app and connected
all these pieces together
so that this is now a really good
foundation to build
anything on top of it
let's quickly recap what we've done
and
how you can move on and do more features
development on that or add other
things you might be interested in
first off we created a
user interface with swelt
that was really
the basic
foundation that we needed for the web
app in order to
create to-do items update them delete
them and display all of it
we then moved on and created a swelt kit
back-end api
there was a rest api with endpoints to
create
read update and delete to-do items
we used rest over http to connect to
that back end and return json data
to display in the ui
at the very beginning we started off
building that application
with
javascript disabled
so we used regular html form elements
and post
requests to submit the data
we then
enhanced our forms
with swelt actions which allows us to
intercept the html form submission and
instead
do an ajax request so we don't have to
reload the entire page for every action
we do
so we now have a front-end that works
with javascript it also works with no
javascript enabled in the browser
in the second part of the course we went
ahead
and used prisma
an orm to let us connect to a postgres
database
this really simplified
the entire integration with the database
we did not write a single line of sql
code
all we really did was using generated
typescript
and javascript in order to connect to
the database we were reading
data updating data all by simply just
calling functions within our javascript
and typescript files
lastly when we had all this working in a
developer environment
we then deployed the web application to
their cell
and we deployed the postgres database to
railway.app
where it is now running so that we can
connect to it from our production
environment
when we developed the project
we
did all of that in a gitpod developer
environment
so you notice that for every task that
we worked on
we started a new gitpod workspace
and this is the concept of
what ephemeral developer environments
all are all about
you start an environment it's fully
automated it started our developer
server installed the dependencies
and we then basically could just write
our code
stop the environment and for the next
task we open the new environment to do
the work we wanted to do
amazing achievement congratulations once
again this is
a full stack application that you know
can use
as a foundation to do further work and
build your own projects
let's spend a few minutes talking about
what's next
how can you
further enhance the application in order
to deepen your knowledge about the
technologies that we used and the
different
providers where we deployed the
application as well as the database
the first thing i want to bring up as a
suggestion to look into is
try to deploy the web application and
the api endpoints to a different hosting
provider as part of the course we used
versailles
and i introduced you to the adapter
concept of swelt kit
so an easy kind of next steps it would
be to maybe deploy this entire
application to netlify or
cloudflare or any other hosting provider
that you might be familiar with
so this would be a good next steps
minimal code changes in order to get it
resolved so you would get some
quick success by
looking into this
another
suggestion
would be to play around
and try to use
a different database maybe you are not
familiar with postgres maybe you're more
familiar with mysql
try to change
the
database to
mysql instead of postgres
read up about
the prisma configuration how you can
change that and you know try railway or
try
planetscale or any other database
provider see if we can connect the api
to that database system
and learn about that part of the backend
development in this entire stack
lastly a third suggestion
to
look into
might be to enhance the project right
now this is a very
simple
to do application where
everybody who's using it they'll get the
same
list of to-do items
now it would be more helpful if
for example there were
people you could assign items to and of
course if you just had your own list so
add some kind of authentication
to the system where you know you have to
log in with github or maybe email
address and password
and then you could add
due dates where you say that this item
is you by friday
so try to learn how to persist that in
the database
and
overall this could really be
an application that you can build out as
part of your learning journey
for the full stack application
development
alternatively you could take what we
built
use the concepts and build something
completely different i would love to
hear what you come up with based on the
course so do reach out and let me know
otherwise
let's
wrap this up with
a few more words about the overall
course
with that thank you so much for taking
your time and working through this
course it was a great pleasure putting
this together and i hope this gives you
a good foundation for your next project
when you want to build a full stack web
application with the front end an api
and a back-end
database
you can find me on twitter at mike
nicholas i'm also available on my
website at mike nicholas.com where i
have blog posts i have links to
open source projects that i work on so
do check these out
and also have a look at www.gitpod.io
the underlying developer environment
that we use throughout the course where
we spin up a fully automated developer
environment for each given task
and we then shut it down when we're done
and move on to a new one the next time
we work on an issue
do check out these links let me know if
there's anything can help you with i
would love to hear from you if you have
feedback please let me know i'd love to
make a follow-up course or maybe
something else
to
help spread the knowledge and
let people learn from the experience
that i have